Do not search substances tweet Twitter history, okay? Or his
Discord logs looking for an instance of him calling Stardust
a cow, okay? Do not search. Do not search. Do not find it. >> Okay,
that totally sounds completely
That sounds so sane. That's such a welladjusted thing to do for
a human being. Oh my god, substance is such a >> It's like
the craziest virtue signal when she's done so much disgusting
herself. I just like, how do you say this? How do you do this
with a straight face? Did you know that trains are the natural
predator of Indian people?
Did >> No. No. Not funny.
>> What a disgusting. I'm sorry. I am going to have to
be I might have to break the seals on the misogyny, the racism.
Okay.
Well, I got sent some some debate timestamps from the Wick panel
tonight. Do we check out some of the Wick panel?
Pis Pisco. Apparently, Stardust hopped on the Wick panel tonight.
Is that worth checking out?
Is that I think that's where we're going. Is Stardust going to
press press pisco on something? I've heard Stardust >> Okay,
ignore me. >> Quite literally pressed Pisco to ban
bro? Okay.
for off-platform behavior.
Does Stardust want to go at people for off-platform behavior?
Because I don't know exactly what Substance did, that he was
like really gross with racism. Okay? Cuz I've heard that's what
it is. I don't know what he did, but I do have a hard time believing
that it's worse than using um six childhood as a dunk on him.
Like, shouldn't Stardust also go for offplatform behavior if
she's trying to like single out substance?
I think the thing with sick was pretty gross to me. But hey,
that's just that's just me, man. That's just me, man.
Apparently sent her graphic images of dead Indians. Okay, that's
pretty gross. Well, we'll see. We'll see what happens. >> Uh,
just one I'm so sorry. Give me one second here and then I'll
get I'll just um It's >> been a while, Stardust. We haven't
seen you in a minute. >> Good to hear from you. >> Yeah,
it has been a while. Yeah. >> Is it though? Is it good
to hear from >> Nope. This is I did the wrong tab. Sorry,
just one second.
>> we're chilling.
>> I heard it was a cow head, not dead Indians. That's
a lie. This whole thing felt weird. Like some kind of proxy war
against the pit board or maybe anywhere substance hangs out.
No, it's it's about like
basically
um it's about me. Listen, to me it's about being friends with
Quean and how it has drawbacks, okay? cuz Queman's snarked on
basically everybody and Stardust is just really mad that Queman
snarked on her until her relationship blew up. Okay. And so she's
taking that back out on anybody who associates with Queenman
Substance being one of these people. Okay. And she knows she
could tie into like a bunch of narratives and people will support
her because it's like against these communities, against like
it's just she's just mad. She's ultimately mad that Queen did
his whole Hog Rider segment. That's ultimately what this all
boils down to. Okay. She doesn't care about anybody's particular
actions. She's just very angry at Queenman and can't go after
him directly. I'm I'm just I'm telling you that's what it is.
>> Everything is actually about something else. Um Okay.
Uh also, it's probably bad that she got sent a cow's head or
something. [laughter] I will say if if Substance sent her like
a cow's head or something, that's gross. That's weird.
Obviously bad.
Um Oh, well, I thought you were joking. I I could say whatever
substance did I probably disavow if that's what happened. No,
not No, we're not. No, don't send cowheads. That's not okay.
Don't do that.
I'm still not back yet. But there ain't no way that Stardust
came in with a PowerPoint presentation. Is there She didn't really
come in with a power She didn't do the thing that everyone makes
fun of her for and come in with a literal PowerPoint presentation,
right?
Yes. Yes. Okay. >> The dear Pisco please presentation.
>> Yes. Yes. Okay. All right. So, let me just preface this
and say that um that I uh want to preface this conversation to
say that what I'm about to talk to you about, I'm not sure you're
even aware about. Um uh it's not an indictment of your character
or even your community's character specifically, but it is about
um somebody that I was let known that may be a prominent member
of your community. If I'm wrong, I apologize. >> Okay.
Um and then also uh let me just also preface one thing. Over
the years, I h I have been online. I have taken every type of
abuse um and rolled with the punches because I just you know
it's I I I you know that I it's part of being online, right?
And also >> um I think I think
by definition
I would almost have a policy that by
if somebody tried to do this to me in public I would say no automatically.
If you want to have this conversation without the emotional blackmail
of like an audience and trying to like basically make me make
a call in public.
If you want to have that conversation then maybe. But if you
want to try to press me in public that like, oh, this is really
bad. You need to change one of your your policies right now.
Yeah, go yourself.
Like, actually, just go yourself. Like, it's just it's so it's
so transparent, right? Even if you have a point,
>> even if you do have a point,
okay, it's still bad.
>> Um, like remember when Lav tried to force you to give
her mod? Um, I do remember that. I think that this like a slightly
different thing. That was her being like emotional in the moment.
Again, this is Stardust made a presentation to pressure Pisco.
Stardust made a presentation to pressure Pisco
Even if she were correct about the conduct, this is a ludicrous
thing to do as a creator.
This is such a embarrassing thing to do. It's transparently manipulative.
It's transparently gross. And there's no way Pisco can look good
here, right? Pisco says, "I don't moderate off platform behavior."
He said it multiple times, right? That just don't don't break
the rules of the Discord.
And now basically, you're coming up with your best way to make
him look like a hypocrite in or make him look monstrous,
>> right? It's
that's that's what she's doing. Maybe hold on. I would actually
accept this if she's just like, I want to Pisco over explicitly.
this guy you pisco I'm coming here to you over if she did that
if she was transparent about it but what she's going to do is
she's going to be like I'm really concerned about your community
and like I think that you guys are like you're getting some people
in your community who are like bad and I um I um um um I like
I think that's really
and I'm going to have to shoot myself in the head in a video
game. Okay, >> if that's if that's how this goes. if she
tries to like moralize and just say she's concerned for a >> um
it is part of some of the spaces that I've engaged in the in
the past, right? You can't go into some of these spaces without
expecting a certain amount of vitriol and abuse, right? Um but
um
>> all she's doing is providing evidence publicly. She's
making this a public thing. So it's not about Pisco's true position
where in private he could say while I find this disgusting, I
don't want to do Right. If you were doing it privately with Pisco
or Pisco's mods, I don't have a problem with this. You let him
make the call privately. You don't hold his policies against
him when he stands out of position. But what this is is going
to be like emotional blackmail, right? Trying to say something
really disgusting happened to me and I think you need to ban
somebody for it. And if you don't ban him, if if Pisco doesn't
capitulate, he looks monstrous. And if he capitulates, he looks
like a >> What I will say is,
>> oh, another fantastic point from Kilo here. If you are
going to bring this up, I want to see evidence he went to the
mods first.
Did you report this to my mods or did you literally compile this,
keep it in your back pocket to use against me on a wick panel
months later, weeks later?
>> Is um I do not expect this to come from progressives.
Um and I do not expect them to engage in this type of of very
specific
um aggression. Um, so let me break something down for the audience
so they understand where I'm coming from and just in case Pisco
and Wick might not understand. Okay. All right. So the cow an
Indian >> dude there's no way.
There's no way. Okay. I just I'm sorry. I kind of get how you
might have to do this. It's just like everybody understands cows
find or sorry Indians find cows sacred >> culture. I'm
sure Pisco is a very um educated man. I'm sure he understands
this but um most people recognize the cow as being sacred in
Hinduism but beyond that um I'm not a Hindu right but beyond
that respect for cows is something that is a foundational pillar
of Indian cultural identity uh it's part of our psyche right
um uh basically
>> oh also I would be okay with this if she asked Pisco
if she could do this that is another way that I wasn't thinking
about right off the top of my head if she asked Pisco she could
do this publicly.
Uh while I do think that's a different kind of like weird man
manipulation and he would probably say yes and it would still
lead to this. I I would probably give her a pass on that if she
asked Pisco and said like this is what I was going to do. >> Um
uh beyond that um it it is uh in rural Indian history the cow
was seen as the backbone of survival. It provided milk. uh it
dung for for fuel and fertilizer labor when plowed
>> and so and despite all that the cow requires very little
in return um and then another principle that the cow embodies
is um the most one of the most foundational principles of Indian
culture which is a himsa or non-injury nonviolence right the
cow is the living embodiment of this principle uh cows are strong
they are large but they don't use that to harm others Um so even
though I'm not Hindu um uh you know an attack on that can be
significant to me right um uh it's not just Hindu theology it's
like a
uh value um so as an Indian Muslim um you are raised in a culture
where this animal represents the spirit of the land right um
but anyways >> wow so >> that's so cool >> uh
on Christmas Eve
this person Mr. substance here. Um, uh, in response, um, >> heard
of this guy >> to something that I said on Twitter, um,
responded to me with a severed cow >> on Christmas Eve.
Substance
on Christmas Eve of all days. On Christmas Eve? Are you serious?
On Christmas Eve,
>> head and severed cow legs. Um, I know that this substance
person um posts clips uh for several other content
who she hates. That's, by the way, I'm
How am I supposed to believe that this isn't explicitly because
I've shouted Substance out and said he does a great job clipping
and we love Substance. How am I supposed to believe that this
isn't because of that? How am I supposed to believe that this
isn't explicitly just because I've shouted substance out and
he posts clips from this stream and Queenman's stream? >> I
don't know those other content creators. I have a >> bro.
She doesn't even >> immense amount of respect for Peace.
I think he's very person um posts clips uh for several other
content creators. I don't know those other content creators.
I have >> I don't know those other uh
>> Wait, what? Wait, what? Wait, what? Wait. Wait. Huh?
Wait. Huh?
I mean, you just did a whole presentation. You didn't look through
the content of the account and see if there's people you knew.
Wait, what? Hold on. I don't know what tweet this is. I hope
it's not going to be something that I don't want brought up on
stream. No, it's not.
Like, if she just scrolled Hassan Willy, heard of them. Fairy
Queen. Heard of Stardust. Obviously knows Fairy Queen. No idea
who this is.
Uh
Pisco
Andrew Wilson feel like you might know them. Uh you're literally
talking to Pisco at this precise moment in time.
Becket Copen with a not so erodite tweet. Amazing.
Uh Chud Logic, you know him literally. Wait, is there a creator
that that Substance posts clip clips of that Stardust doesn't
actually know? Is there a single one? Like it's actually the
precise opposite. Is there a creator that she doesn't know that
substance post clip clips of? I >> have an immense amount
of respect for Pisco. I think he's very educated, very good at
what he does and I think he shares my values. Um, and again,
I normally would not even go to anybody about this. Um, but it's
not just words at this point. It is somebody sent me
>> Um, and uh, and that is an escalation
of rhetoric. Um, it uh I I can give you some of the backstory.
I I made a I made a joke a three >> totally disavow this
by the way. This is like by the way this is just stupid to do.
Um like in a real sense it's stupid to do because even if I I
don't necessarily think Stardust I don't think this the even
close to the worst harassment Stardust gotten. I don't think
it's anything like that. I really don't think it's that bad in
her mind. But just giving her the ability to go and do this is
pointless. Like it actually hurts you. It's like strategically
just a bad thing. Um if I if I thought Stardust wasn't able to
like go hard on like other people in a whole bunch of ways. Like
she's obviously I Dude. Oh yeah, I see. I specifically didn't
bring up the tweet she's referencing cuz it was just gay of her
to bring this up. like just bizarre of her to the whole tweet
chain was just I just let it go because then I I understand I
let it go because it was going to be me violating toss and not
substance. So I just I just moved on. Okay. But uh yeah, don't
let don't let people being like bait you into doing things that
aren't smart.
>> Don't do it, man. >> Word joke. Uh
incredible rebrand tbh when it was something about Cherry posted
about God or whatever.
Um, he quote uh tweet somebody else quote tweeted me. Then I
said, "I have my own personal conflict with Cherry. Has nothing
to do with Destiny or anybody in that space. Um, I was friends
with her for years before I was friends with." No, >> you
weren't >> with Destiny. Um, I wasn't even really that
close with him to be honest with
>> Sorry, I'm going to miss that. >> Yeah. Substance
did the This is like a cow's head. Like it's a dismembered cow,
I believe. >> What was that in response to?
It was in response to Cherry uh saying something about like how
God is good and all of that, right? And so my my I was a sub
tweet. I screenshotted it and I put incredible rebrand tbh. Then
somebody quote tweeted that and said because Destiny retweeted
that tweet that I'm like helping aid his um image or whatever,
even though my tweet was literally three words, had nothing to
do with him. Okay. Um I don't choose who retweets my tweets,
you know? I don't have control over that. Anyways,
so then I said I said basically Cherry and I have our own issues
prior to any of what you guys are talking about. Um, and I'm
allowed to be in public about it if I want to, right? Um, but
you know, I'm using my words, right? This guy says, "Yes, starter.
You you are in fact allowed to be a petty and vile vindictive
[__] on Maine if you want to. Truly brilliant stuff
here." I replied, "Boohoo. I hurt your sensitive feelings." that
>> I truly believe that
this what Substance did is less bad than what Stardust did to
Sik
>> 100%.
Like start what Stardust did to Sick is so much worse than what
Substance did to her. It's like they're not even in the same
ballpark.
It's actually totally
it's totally insane and disgusting that she'll bring this up.
What did she do again? um she used as a dunk on sick the fact
that he was as a kid and then so the fact that he I think is
his sister or something and it was basically that sick was himself
as a kid and as people know if you get if you are as a kid you're
likely to not understand why it's bad and do it back. It wasn't
something he was like doing and and wanted to do and like like
he was but he was like 10 I think. I think he was like 10 or
11. He was like a a little kid. Yes. Yeah. Yeah, he was like
a little
It's But you're like trying to hold him responsible for that.
You're like make you're like making fun of him for it.
>> But it's just it's crazy that she'll virtue signal about
this. She'll like moral frog about this when she's done something
so much worse like in very recent memory that I just don't even
remotely under. And by the way, she immediately backed off. She
was like immediately like trying to pretend she didn't do it
when she like after it turn. So first she doubled down if I remember
correctly. I think first she doubled down on with him and then
she started getting people like pointing out how it was for her
to do this and then she like deleted the tweets and backed off
of it. But yes, she basically I think sick was criticizing her
for something and she decided as a dunk she was going to bring
up the fact that he his sister when it happened when he was 10
like he he literally was as a as a little kid. He was abused
and he in turn did that abuse on somebody else in his life as
a child pre-teen. Oh, October 19th. I feel like this is roughly
when it happened. Uh maybe um well, everyone kind of made fun
of him at first when they didn't know the story, but she um
but she went off. I think he he leaked something about uh Arodite
or something. He leaked his DMs with Arerodite or something and
she really didn't like that. Um,
yeah. Hold on. Hold on. But everyone kind of made fun of him.
I'm sure a lot of people did make fun of him charging Jim. But
those people wouldn't go and try to moral frog on a stream about
some gore post in their replies, would they? Is Chud Logic going
to go, "Oh, they sent me they sent me a cutup cow. A picture
of a cutup cow. They sent me a picture of a cutup cow. What am
I supposed to do
to do this? You can't engage in the behavior she's engaged in.
Oh, also this stupid is from like the sector blood sports age.
AND SHE'S GOING, "OH NO, A CUT UP COW. OH MY GOD, IT'S so bad.
It's so crazy. What
does she Is she like
does she have she like in momento? Has she lost her memory? The
people she used to hang out with?
This is like not even remotely close to over the line for anybody
she's hung out with her entire internet career. And she could
say, "Okay, well, I'm resetting or something here,
but like what? What the [__] man?" She clearly hasn't
reset. She did the sick thing. Ethan literally told her to stop
spreading her lips on a stream once, screaming at the top of
his lungs. I do remember that. Yes. The response to that I feel
like was a a huge escalation to go from boohoo, I hurt your sensitive
feelings to sending me literal severed cow head and and cow legs,
right? Um
so, uh >> okay, who's going to be the person? I we need
this. Okay, the next time Pisco does callins, we need this. And
don't put anything up in the in the presentation.
I need somebody to recreate this presentation with these stardust
and sick like tweets. Okay, because I think there's archives
of them out there. I'm pretty sure there's archives saved. Okay,
somebody needs to go and put that together and give.
Don't actually do it. Don't actually do it. I'm joking. That's
a joke. That's a joke. That's a joke. Don't actually do it. It's
incredibly gay to do this. Okay,
the Kathy PowerPoint would go hard though. We could do that as
a Hold on. We could do that as a
skit somewhere. Okay, we could do that as a skit or something.
We're not going to do it literally, though. I'll explain this
further why this is targeted harassment. Okay, it is it is discriminatory
selection, right? He this wasn't a random he didn't pick this
out of nowhere. It would be one thing if he sent me gore by itself
and it wasn't targeted. We would still find that gross, but it
wouldn't be this level. Um,
this wasn't like a random edgy meme he had laying around. He
knew my
He specifically sought out a mutilated cow or he had one and
he sent it direct. He said he quoted quote tweeted me because
he knew I was Indian, right? That's all he knew.
>> no, that's not why he quote tweeted you.
In fact, you already showed why he was quote tweeting. Like he
Okay, he it wasn't discriminatory selection. This is actually
just wrong. This is obviously
wrong. It's sought out. No, but even the selection wasn't discriminatory.
The selection was
you're being like a total to Cherry. That was the selection.
That was how he selected you. He actually got mad about the the
other previous tweet, right? That was the selection.
He did weaponize the culture in a dehumanizing way. Yes. But
like the >> This is not I didn't offend him on the basis
of his God. Um uh it was just because I said that I hurt his
feelings. I called him sensitive. Uh,
>> no. The first the reason he didn't like you, the reason
he was annoyed with you was because of your tweet, the original
tweet. I'm not the person who can virtue signal about that, okay?
Cuz I obviously am going to get
annoyed.
So, I I'll leave that to somebody else who can lay that out for
her why the first tweet was offensive. But he was offended by
that tweet, not by you saying, "Haha, your feelings are hurt."
You were making light of the first tweet and his response to
it.
Do we do we really have to >> So this from internet beef
to being like a calculated targeted thing against my identity
um if he had sent this to anyone else um it would just be gross
right because um if they didn't have my background it would just
be gross
by the way I'm not going to defend that I truly believe that
basically these pe substance was probably aware that you've been
complaining about anti-Indian discrimination cuz you complained
about it a lot and he's probably aware that he thinks you're
a disgusting vile like imu
You put those two things together and he's going to go, "Oh,
what's the thing you're [__] about?" Oh, anti-Indian
racism. Let me cook up a little anti-Indian racism. Here you
go, [__] I fully believe he did that 100%. >> It's,
you know, severed cow selection added cultural >> that
you're saying the selection of the cow was deliberate based on
your identity, right?
>> Yes. Yes. Um he turn it's cultural weaponization. He
took a symbol of peace, right? Um a cultural taboo basically.
Um >> it'd be like sending a sending a black person a picture
of a cross on fire,
>> Well, I think it's a little bit worse than that because
it's gore. >> It's right. It's just gore, right? Uh but
um uh basically I think he he you know it's like you're sending
what is an image of peace to somebody but >> Who would
Stardust needed to do? Stardust needs to plug into Hindu Twitter
and she should have just retweeted Substance has tweeted her
with like adding some anti-Hindu hate account. Dude, you get
that guy plugged into Hindu Twitter. Holy Substance is going to
be harassed for the rest of his >> That right. Um and then
obviously identity dehumanization.
um he is using he has stepped over the line from going to just
a normal um conflict back and forth to using my identity and
that is fair game for him now. And it's not just that he's using
>> uh a dead cow is not equivalent to sending a black person
a burning cross. Holy
um so she's trying to build the argument, right? She's trying
to build the argument that she's like a devout Hindu. She thinks
the cow is a symbol of peace, right? And that it is offensive
on the level of like a a deeply and if all of that is true, she's
a devout Hindu. She believes the cow is a symbol of peace. Substance
explicitly like is using that, weaponizing that against her,
right?
Remember, she's not even Hindu. See, that's the thing is like
I I get the feeling that Stardust is not particularly religious
and it's like just cheap like h you you're Indian cows.
Like it's not it's not the level. She's not taking it to the
level. And that is not in the same way that like that'd be like
tweeting a watermelon at a black guy, right?
That's more what it's like.
It's like I'm I'm just tweeting a watermelon at you.
Like there you go. What's Is there a gorier version?
I don't know. I don't know if there's a version with gore that
could be like funny in the same way. It's It's more excessive
than that because of the gore element. It's obviously more excessive
than that, but it is that vein of like it's just a cheap throwaway
super fast, right?
>> identity. He is he's saying like it it is a it's a fair
target and um and he's basically communicating that um that like
that's what he feels about me, right? How else am I supposed
to interpret that? Right? How else am I supposed to interpret
that?
>> No, I think you should interpret it as he doesn't think
you're human. He thinks you're a like horrifying like vile. But
honestly, he seemed to have thought that from the moment the
first tweet went >> When somebody so mad at me, if somebody
is so upset with me that they are willing to de completely dehumanize
me to the extent that they're that it's not even just my my sensibilities
as a person of Indian origin, it's my sensibilities as a woman,
right? Like what kind of
Wait, what? I Wait, what? Wait, huh?
It's my sensibilities as a woman.
>> Pardon me.
>> Uh Steve only warning >> uses that kind of it's
like this is this is a this is common classic, right? >> So
just to be so you think it's it's targeting you uh both because
of your ethnic background um and national background but also
because you're >> I don't know. I don't know if it's intentionally
targeted because I'm a woman. I just think that it's offensive
to me as a woman, you know.
>> Stardust operating under clear delusion. Okay. She was
she was sort of operating in reality before, but now we've strayed
into clear delusion. Imagining that substance sees her as a woman
is just obviously false. Obviously a delusion. That's crazy.
>> That's wild. >> Yeah. Um uh but you know >> who's
just just to be clear, who is this person and how is it connected
to Pisco specifically? um that I have been told that this person
is like a member of his >> By the way,
this is
>> this is deeply embarrassing.
>> Just this whole idea that you're trying to press him
on Wick
>> about his about his Discord or
>> It's so deeply embarrassing, man. I just I have to go
back to that. like you you wrote a presentation with Pisco's
name in it to go after this guy weeks after it happened.
Is Substance a Chatter? Uh probably. I would imagine he watches
Pisco
I think Substance is a part of like that sort of left-leaning
crew here who do watch like Pisco, me, Queenman. I do think so.
Yeah, >> he's like a part of this community. Um, I understand
like I again like I totally chastise sending somebody something
like
I don't think
>> it is my personal subjective opinion
>> Stardust was not as disturbed by this as she says and
she's just weaponizing it because it's convenient. >> But
I also think you shouldn't do this because you don't really know
somebody's mind and I could be wrong, right? You should shouldn't
do it. >> Uh, it's bad to do. I think if I remember correctly,
I do believe Substance has said, "Uh, my bad, it's too far. I
apologize." Or something along these lines. We'll maybe get to
that in a little bit. >> So, and I don't >> Yeah,
I won't let you finish your presentation though. If um I don't
know if you want me to respond yet.
>> If you think they're if they're not a member of your
community, I'll just like stop here. You know, that's that's
fine. But yeah. >> Well, I So, so I'll respond on on a
few things. First, >> I do think that that's racist and
I'm sorry that that that that's totally inappropriate. I don't
think that that should happen. I totally disavow sending gore
of any kind, but certainly one which seems um you know I don't
think I don't know that what other reason there would be to for
it to be a cow. Um and it certainly crosses a line. Um that if
that conduct occurred sort of, you know, in any of my spaces
or
>> the funny thing here is I don't know if I like people
are like, "Oh, Stardust wants to be in Destiny's." I don't even
know if that's true that she wants to be in like Desty's community.
I think this is more her relation to Lonerbox and how some of
those like left-leaning chatters go after like like don't like
loner box and that community. I think that's more what it's about
if I had to guess,
>> Like in my YouTube chat or in my discord that would
be a banable offense. It would totally be against the rules and
so and I am really sorry that that
>> is he going to stand out business on >> just because
you take a view on a controversy. I don't think that it's justified
to to cross that line where we're getting into kind of more hateful
rhetoric. And so I am really sorry. >> And it wasn't even
on that controversy, right? It wasn't even on that controversy.
It was about a personal disagreement that I had with somebody
and it was just a threeword joke, right? Um but yeah. Yeah. >> Well,
I'm not commenting on the joke. Listen, I I don't want to talk
about like [laughter]
>> is is Stardust pretending she doesn't know that when
she goes to dunk on that person that she doesn't know what community
she's going to invoke when she goes to do that? Like I she could
say
whatever. It's like she she's just pretending it's like performative.
>> The the whole >> again I'm trying to just keep
that whole like the original premise of this to be >> drama
like that specific drama >> um is in like case and situation
is banned in my Discord. I I recognize that that Twitter handle
because I do see that person clip things and um I think I I follow
them um because they will like
>> either moments of mine or they'll clip people and they're
like at so they're very active in clipping. Um I'm not sure if
I've ever had a conversation with that person. I certainly never
noticed them um in my discord or
>> again I would say almost certainly substance is not
broadly racist even though this was a like a racially um discriminatory
thing. I do think it was, oh, you're you complained about Indian
disc anti- Indian discrimination, [__] you. Right.
I do think that's what he was doing. But you would never find
out, you never see substance be racist in a general sense of
any kind. Like it's just it's literally just you. What pissed
you off? Here's what pisses you off. I I if if they were there
and uh and yeah, I don't know why they would um like I don't
know why like this is awful that they would send you that, but
um but yeah, no, I I I don't deny that they're part of my Discord
because I don't I just don't know if they are. >> Okay,
fair fair enough. Yeah, I yeah, I don't know. And again, that's
why I preface this with saying I don't know if you're even aware
of this or even if I'm correct in this knowledge that I've been
told, right? So, I just wanted to and I know that you're a a
good person. Um, I just wanted to like finish I guess with
um you know it is um
uh I guess also just like it's it's a violation of norms to some
to send somebody something like that, you know. Um like in all
my time online, I have been sent plenty of things like that.
But to get it from somebody who is a progressive, somebody who
I have seen tweet things that are like, "Oh, men who use um violence
to intimidate women should be condemned." I've seen that guy
tweet that. But you're using a violent image to like in like
what are you communicating to me? Am I like I what am I supposed
to get from that? You know, >> I'm I'm in fear for my physical
safety because of that tweet. I'm sorry. No, you're not. No,
you're not. No, you're not. No, you're not. You engaged in the
sector for like years. I don't understand how you could possibly
virtue signal about this. It's so insane to me. >> And
it's just
selfinsert as the cow. Oh no.
Oh no.
Oh no. Um >> um no normal person and it's like >> do
not do not search substances tweet Twitter history. Okay. Or
his Discord logs looking for an instance of him calling Stardust
a cow. Okay. Do not search do not search. Do not find it. >> Antisocial
behavior, you know. Um and then Yeah. And then and then there
he said he did this apology, but I don't think the apology is
good even. Right. >> Oh, wait. and she still brought it
up here.
[laughter] Wait, there's really no excuse. I should have kept
my critiques of you centered around what I found to be objectionable
character and conduct in this situation. Yet, I allowed myself
to run a foul of any norm or standard myself. I do genuinely
apologize for debasing myself to a point of attacking you on
the basis of your background in such a disgusting depraved manner.
It was too far to say the least, and not how any decent person
should conduct themsel.
Bro, what? Bro, there's no way that she decided she was going
to bring this to Pisco. There's no
way.
There's no
possible way.
>> Like, uh, people were, "Oh, it's okay because he apologized."
I don't think so. I think the ap >> Well, you don't have
to forgive him. It's not okay. He's literally saying, "I I shouldn't
have done that. It was wrong of me to do, and I apologized. Made
a mistake. He He did it. He was angry. He did it. He made a mistake."
And then he apologized to you directly. And it doesn't seem like
it's even that far after the fact. It seems like it's literally
still Christmas Eve. 3:00 a.m. December 22 was terrible. It's
self-centric. Like he he focuses on how it affected him, how
he debased himself, how it was a
>> Yeah, I don't Wait, he would just be li If he said he
apologized to you, that would be lying. Like he doesn't Wait,
he
that that would be a lie. He He doesn't He doesn't ap Sorry.
He apologizes for using this tactic. He thinks you are a vile
human being. He wants you to feel bad. If he said, "I'm sorry
for hurting your feelings," that would be a lie. He did want
your feelings hurt. He is sorry that he debased himself, right?
He's he is apologizing for the nature of the attack because that
violates his principles and he doesn't think anybody should suffer
that, right? I do genuinely apologize for debasing myself to
a point. It's I I could see where she's coming from a little
bit, but it's like it's he's saying I I don't Yeah, I don't want
I don't want to be racist. It was wrong of me to do it racistly.
I do think you're a vile person and I do want you to feel bad
for being vile. So, I will refrain from doing racist in the future
because obviously you you were correct in your criticism of me
and I don't want to be like you. >> A uh failure uh or
not failure, it was like um lowering his own standards and he's
more concerned about like his his reputational damage than about
like the harm he is inflicting on me or anybody of my origin
who's looking at that, right? Um and then >> no no no.
um to base myself to the point of attacking you as in he thinks
it was gross and wrong of him to attack you on the basis of your
background. As in he is he is saying it is it is bad. It is something
that is inherently wrong to attack her on the basis of her background.
As in anybody else who sees it probably for the exact reasons
you could expect. He could have gone into more detail, but it's
like the reason you don't want to attack somebody based on their
background, based on their inherent characteristics, is because
that's going to cause like collateral damage. You're going to
hit other people. And it's just he talk he talks about what he
did as being depraved, but doesn't even like label what it is,
what he exactly did. You sent me an image of gore that was culturally
targeted, you know. Yeah. >> So I I just feel like Yeah,
it's just um so that's uh um yeah, I that was my that's basically
my presentation.
>> What do you think would have made this an acceptable
apology if you would edit it? I think yeah I think he I think
he needs to acknowledge exactly what he did and acknowledge
>> he does acknowledge exactly what he did that he well
I mean you could say maybe I I don't know if he has a genuine
like um that he feels like Gore is genuinely wrong even
but like I I think he's identified the thing that is worst about
this and said he apologizes for it the gore element I mean I
it's whatever right it I think it adds something but I I think
that's pretty subjective how you feel about that right that's
like a that's a more difficult one I think the broad basis like
90% of what's wrong with this he apologized for >> um exactly
how that is >> it like so so I I sent you a picture of
gore of animals >> I would say I sent you a a highly inappropriate
violent image um that um that was targeted uh based on your ethnic
background. I shouldn't have done >> I do not attack you
on the basis of your I'm not trying to like >> Pisco Pisco's
like trying so hard not to just like poke holes in this in the
most obvious ways. He's trying he's genuinely trying his hardest
not to just be like super but like he he actually seems this
seems like a pretty good sincere apology to me. Wait, why would
you change about this apology? [laughter] >> Like defend
this guy, but I'm just saying in terms of the apology, >> I
don't think it's stop.
Do not send Pisco beheaded guinea pig. Do not send Pisco beheaded
guinea pig. Okay. The guinea pig is not the symbol of peace in
Peru. Okay. Stop. Stop. Stop.
>> By the way, that's
I'm sorry. I'm going to rat you out in case Pisco sees a clip
of that. That was Kosher Kathy. That was the real Kathy Doyle
on YouTube. I'm ratting you out, Kathy. You're I'm not I'm not
the only one going down for that. Okay. I'm not the only one.
You're coming with >> enough. I think he's down. I think
he's minimizing it. He's minim because this is not just attacking
me on the basis of my background. I I I'm used to that, right?
If it were just mean comments, um you know, whatever, right?
But it is escalated to where you are sending me violent images,
right? That's that's a different line, you know. >> So,
you would have liked to see more specificity, more connection
to the harm it caused and an acknowledgement, but he's using
strong rhetoric like disgusting, depraved debase. Um, you're
saying that that the fact that it's >> it feels when it's
when it's connected with the fact that >> literally says
he he did something that was disgusting and depraved.
Yeah. Like I it seems like he's pretty excessive in his language
right now. >> It's all about him. The the first part of
it where it's just it's just about him. Um it seems like he's
apologizing for debasing himself and not demeaning
>> Okay. Yeah. >> Um
Yeah, I see. >> Yeah. No, I think that's accurate though.
This would be like this would be like the the example I give
to Pisco is like imagine if you tweeted something about Trump
or imagine somebody around you tweeted something about Trump
and they were like racist about it or somehow they they were
somehow like racist about it, did something culturally insensitive,
went after his religion, something along these lines. I do believe
Stardust is about as religious as Trump is, right?
Like it was something like that. And then they they they're not
going to apologize for being mad about the thing they were responding
to, right? or thinking Trump's like evil and deserves to be demeaned
and like debate demeaned for it. They're not going to apologize
for that because they do believe what he's doing is gross,
but they will apologize for going through a vector that's >> Yeah,
I I think that uh it would have been a way better apology if
he also included references to
um how it must have felt for you as opposed to I do think an
apology necessitates a self-look because what is an apology?
Apology is is just like um an expression of rem >> Oh,
Pisco's too.
Pisco's like, "No, no, no. This is that's the whole purpose of
an apology. What he did there? He's explaining why what he did
was wrong.
How you feel is subjective, but what he did wrong, that's an
objective thing he can do. He can introspect and say, "What did
I do wrong?" >> But how you feel like you could have not
been bothered by this at all. >> Morse, an expression of
contrition. And so, I think that it presupposes
self-reflection. Um, and it is personal. And so I don't think
that that the sort of self-centered aspect of it is necessarily
wrong, but I do think the failure to um you know tailor it to
like the things you must have felt etc. and how you would have
reacted to it. Um and why specifically um you know not just
>> Yeah. Like when you think about it, this is from a guy
on Twitter
like like a a random guy on Twitter.
It's like uh
like
I don't know. I I don't know what more you could expect. Well,
no. Sorry. I'm saying like technically random guy on Twitter.
I'm actually probably bearing the lead. Maybe it maybe even makes
it better. The reason Stardust doesn't like this guy is because
she would have gone through his profile and seen that he clips
me, he clips, he clips Pisco, right? And Stardust knows that
she can go to the Wick community and get them to lean into this
narrative that these are unhinged anti-fang communities, right?
So, she's trying to get one over by emotionally blackmailing
Pisco. Kind of just basically going on here and saying, and maybe
I would say I could almost say maybe she doesn't realize this,
but she's not she's not that stupid. Okay, she is, but she's
not that stupid. So, she thinks she can go on here and this is
what everybody's done to Pisco, which I find embarrassing. Okay,
they'll go on and they go, "Hey, we're going to make you look
bad in a way that's totally disingenuous.
We're going to make you look bad and you're going to take an
economic hit from this. You're going to take a viewership hit
cuz they're going to go, "Oh, I guess he supports totally crazy
people, right? You know that you don't really have a point here
that you don't have something concrete you're coming with. That's
why you're doing it in public to try to emotionally blackmail
him into making a decision that favors you, right? And he's no
matter what he does here.
and you set this situation up intentionally. Wick facilitates
it and it's just a direct attack on Pisco.
Substance, let me let me just give you a little tip. Substance
don't give a if he's banned from Pisco's Discord. I don't think
he gives a single in this entire world if he's banned from Pisco's
Discord. People talk in their if Pisco's like live
and like maybe in controversy it gets a little busy. Otherwise,
it's just Pisco's little niche community that that runs in there,
right? It's like I don't think it he cares, dude. You'd have
to be connected to your emotions to get emotionally blackmailed.
Is that about Pisco Sophia? [laughter] I think he is connected
to his emotions. I I just think it's
Listen, he's a little he's a little like Asmin Gold sometimes.
All right. He's just not going to like if if somebody's explicitly
trying to get him to do something stupid using like emotionality,
I think he's pretty easily going to put the wall up there.
Even Wick seemed to think this was cringe. It is cringe cuz it
it's basically saying you should it's feeding into like the Destiny
narrative about these quote unquote anti-fan communities. It's
trying to piggyback on that to get a like get a dunk on this
one guy. And the downside is is if Pisco does just stand on business
and say no, I'm not going to ban for offplatform behavior. That
apology seems reasonable. That doesn't matter. People are still
going to cover this. They're still going to say, "Oh, look, Pisco
like once again catering to the anti-Fan communities. Once again
going to going to support these snarkers. He'll say that he doesn't
actually support the Snarkers. He'll say that he's like friends
with Destiny or something or he used to be friends. He'll say
he's going to be ignorant of it, but he actually takes their
side every single time. And if you're too stupid to understand
that, what the are you even doing here? Why are you even making
content?" Anyway,
yeah, I don't think he actively interacted with Pis with Pisco's
community. I've only seen I don't see substance is super active
on Discord to be honest. Um at least I I don't think he's super
active in my Discord at least.
Anyway, >> also like ethnic, racial background, whatever.
I think the the failure to have specifics makes it a less than
optimal apology. I do think it is >> Oh, did he chat in
Pisco's Discord a lot? Okay. Damn. >> An equivocal apology,
but I will agree with you that it's like it's not optimal for
sure. >> Yeah. So, this apparently this substance person
is in your discord and they have like let me see they have like
they speak a lot uh in your discord there about 3k messages from
them. Yeah, >> from them. Okay. >> Wait, what?
No shot. Really? What the what the I didn't know that. I didn't
know you talked in there. What the what, bro? What? This guy's
actually a member of his community. Oh, well, I
No, Substance does talk a lot in Pisco's Discord. That's That's
my bad. I Listen, I don't I don't look at Pisco's Discord that
often. Damn. He be
He be talking in Pisco's Discord. I didn't even know >> 3K
messages. Not that much. No, it's >> I can send it to I
can send you just like the search result. Yeah. >> What
are just just so I'm clear, what what what are we what are we
asking Pisco for here? I would ask that until this person like
makes a more decent like apology that they be outed from the
community. I'm not saying forever, but like like I don't know.
I feel like a week at least, right, for for that kind of behavior,
right? Like a >> Okay, I do believe that you are allowed
to litigate pretty openly whether or not I should be doxed in
Loterbox's Discord. Have I ever gone publicly and tried to press
Loterbox on this? Or have I if I feel like somebody is a doxer
in there, do I just message a mod and say, "Hey, seems kind of
weird that this person's here doing this cuz I'm not a loser."
>> I don't know. I feel like a week at least, right, for
for that kind of behavior, right? Like a uh you know, sending
somebody violent imagery. That's an escalation. Like any other
person
>> a week. So
in conclusion,
Stardust made an entire PowerPoint. She's a creator. She made
an entire PowerPoint
explaining the sacredness of cows to Indian people.
She included multiple tweets to go after somebody with less than
a thousand followers on Twitter. Okay, less than a thousand followers,
830 followers.
She put together an entire PowerPoint. She went on Wix's panel.
She pressed Pisco in this directly
for a week. For a week timeout,
for a week long timeout, she paid to skip Zip Zip. She paid to
get on the stream. Apparently, I'm hearing I'm hearing from a
reliable source who doesn't hate Stardust at all that she paid
to skip Zip Zip to get on this stream. Dude, how could you possibly
make it as a creator if this is what you're trying to do? Like
you have to understand that every single person around you looks
at this who is a creator and says, "Oh yeah, you're not going
to make it. You literally can't possibly you you're this is so
worthless. You have no idea of how to prioritize what to cover
on your stream, what to do with your time. That's
insane." What do you mean? Apparently, you could pay to skip
people in the queue to get on stream here. I don't
dude, it was her viewers that paid. Okay, her viewers might have
paid. I don't, man. That's that's like dire stuff, dude. That's
crazy. I like I couldn't I couldn't imagine I couldn't imagine
having this level of concern over what like a less than thousand
sub clip account does when they've apologized. Like if if he
was doing it consistently there, I I don't even know. You have
to totally warp the situation for this to make any amount of
sense.
Like if he was doing this consistently, if he was consistently
like constantly berating her with the most vile racism, then
maybe you get somewhere close to this. There's another option,
right?
Uh block just block him. Just go and block the the substance
guy on that platform. You know, you could just do that, but like
and and not dude. And she apparently didn't go to his mods first
with this. This is
so I don't know how you do this.
I'm trying to think like I think this is more self-deprecating
and demeaning than every piece of Aiden content we've watched
in the past week. Like this is actually worse. I think less of
Stardust than I think of Aiden. Um except outside of maybe the
the literal doxing, but I didn't see that as content. I'm talking
about Aiden going in and debating. I find this less demeaning
than what Aiden was doing to himself by going and debating like
whether or not he loves Gokado.
Okay, this is more demeaning than that. Like at least Aiden At
least people are interested in that. At least people know who
Aiden is. At least like there's something going on there. Star
wants to call in maybe
to what? To like virtue signal about this. Why?
Why? Why do I want to talk to her with her 20 viewers so she
can virtue signal about this? Okay, you understand? She's just
going to she's just going to come in and comment on like my personal
life, right? That's like literally all she can do. If she wants
to come in and talk about this presentation and why she thought
this was a thing to do or let me know that she gave Pisco's mods
a heads up and that that like I'm incorrect on that, I would
take that. But she could just
if she does that kicker. Okay. Uh she can join. It's discord.gg/jc
if she wants to hop on. I just find this disgraceful, frankly.
And then she asked for a week long timeout. She did this all
for a week long timeout, dude. A week long timeout.
Did all this work. She built up a
for a week long time out. What did Pisco >> Maybe even
feel that was a threat, right? Like you feel so negatively about
me. You feel so you feel I'm so low that you're justifying using
a symbol from my culture towards me in in violence, you >> Yeah.
So here's why. Hey, first of all, I I think that you're making
accurate points about what this
>> um attack was. I think it's an attack. I think that
um the apology is
less than optimal. I think that um it is racist and I think that
it is totally unacceptable. It crosses a threshold. Here's what
I'm >> just to be clear,
the person who made the attack also said it was racist and totally
unacceptable. concerned about. Um,
it's like sort of off and I think you knew what I'm going to
where I'm going with this. It's kind of like off platform.
>> It's not happening in the community. And
>> concerned that if I set the precedent of
any kind anytime like a racist or unjustified thing happens out
in the world between two people that um I
have to like adjudicate that and that a it will be sort of um
maybe I'll be unindicted with those kinds of requests where there's
not a clear connection um to the conduct that happens in my spaces
and that doing so will open the door um to like, oh, they did
this, they did that. Well, this was bad for Stardust to critique
Cherry this. And it just gets into a game of like, well, um are
we
>> saying that I have to have a rule where I should enforce
a rule that takes any complaint against any person that is even
involved on the server. So, I'm asking like how do you think
I should balance that? So, I think that when it's a bit different.
>> Uh, hold on. Is short fataku still dodging you? Yeah.
Well, I mean, he is he's been dodging me the whole time. I don't
know why. I asked him to explain like how things changed from
the previous entries
like a while back, but again, I've not I I've still can't bring
myself to even care or read about that stuff. I'm trying, man.
I'm trying. I'm hoping there's like some resolution on the
on like some of that court case stuff soon. But yeah, dodging
when um it is
when it is let's say like bad behavior, off platform, people
being mean versus somebody using somebody's
specific ethnic background, their cultural background. Um and
>> Pisco already made it pretty clear he understands. No,
I thought Pisco made it very clear he understands and didn't
disagree with
I again I do believe it's like emotional blackmail here. like
she's she's trying to say it just more refusively to get him
to change his mind. >> Escalating it to the point of sending
violent imagery and sending gore. Sending somebody gore is just
antisocial behavior. It just is. Right. I'm not asking a Yeah.
I'm not asking you to to police every single person who says
>> here. I'm gonna as a peace offering to Stardust, okay?
And to to try to entice her onto the stream, I'm going to do
something totally epic.
Give me a second. Hold on. Hold on. This is She will be safe
to join my Discord. Okay, cuz we have we've we've neutralized
the threat. Okay. What? When Pisco wouldn't capitulate, I was
so moved by her plight
that I myself have time substance out for seven days for my Discord.
Okay.
The the true scourge of my community, Stubstance, has been timed
out for my Discord. Okay, he is gone. Stardust, you are safe.
You won't have anybody posting this stuff at you. Okay, he is
gone.
07, he gone. He gone. We don't We don't accept anti-Indian hate.
No matter your cast, no matter your creed, we don't accept anti-Indian
hate in this community. Okay.
07 substance. He's gone.
He's gone. He's gone thing like um mean outside of your discord.
But I do think when it is escalated to the point where they are
sending violent imagery to me and that violent imagery is symbolizing
the you the um desecration of a foundational
principle to me uh or a foundational principle to somebody like
I do feel like that there should be some sort of consequence
there, right? Especially this person is not completely disconnected
from you on Twitter. They are posting your clips and they are
engaging with other creators.
>> Would you at least consider unfollowing him on Twitter?
Would you at least consider unfollowing him on Twitter? I really
think it's really bad that you follow him on Twitter. I don't
think she knew that. >> I have no I have no problem condemning
this action, calling him out. I'll do it right now. Substance
is you should apologize further and clarify what the damage is.
I um think that it's really insane that you would do this. I
know >> you can already tell that's a no from Pisco, right?
Like the second he says, "Here's what I'm going to do." Instead
of just saying, "Okay," you can already tell it's a no. >> Apologized,
I think that you should amend it. Um, and I totally disavow the
conduct. I think it's irresponsible. Um, just so that you're
aware, I'm not like in communication with this person to clip
from stuff. And so I know that he clips. That's why I follow.
>> They are though, they are like one of the highest tiers
in your Discord though. And they do have over 3K messages. Yeah.
I sent you a couple of screenshots. Yeah. So, I I've you know,
I'm considering what you're going to say. I'm going to talk to
my mod team and we'll see if we think [snorts] that there's a
violation of the rule. >> Aren't they I didn't think they're
they're not in the highest tier, right? They're not in the lowest
tier. They're the middle tier, right? Aren't they in the middle
tier >> of of our >> like there's the colors, right?
You get like green or orange or red. I thought he was in like
the middle tier >> our place. And perhaps there is. Um
I'll I'll take a look. Um, and we'll I'm not gonna make a decision
right now. Yeah. >> As you know, in the the stream, but
I've definitely heard you. I you know,
>> hey, Pisco. Pisco, just real quick question. If you
are going to talk to your mods,
if you're going to if you're going to take the step of talking
to your mods, could we get an address like an addressing of the
Doobie situation? Have we gotten that yet? Has he talked to his
mods about Dubbie yet? Okay. You're agreeing to talk to your
mods for Stardust. Could you maybe throw in a little bit of like
a doobie ban request? Ban re review. Could we we take a look
at that, please?
He has no reason to say that. Now, if if he is doing this, if
he's going to go talk to his mods over the Stardust situation,
then he needs to also talk about the Doobie situation. Okay.
Dubbie has been wronged. Dubbie has been
Pisco did confirm he agreed with the mods banning Doobie. Bro,
what? That's >> agree that it's horrible and we'll we'll
take a look in the in the mod chat and if um I would ask people
not to like debate it in the server. We're going to come to the
decision we're going to come to. Um but in general um thank you
for bringing it to my attention and we'll definitely take it
under investment. >> Okay. Thank you so much. I really
appreciate it. Um and I hope you have a a great rest of the stream.
>> Thank you and later. >> Have a good one. >> Yeah.
Thanks uh thanks for coming on Stardust. That was Well, she's
gone.
>> Wow. Oh, I Wow. Wow. Wow. Now,
apparently
Stardust does come back on the stream eventually.
So, do we watch through? Apparently, there's a zip zip call.
Is the zip call good? Do we watch the zip call? Can anybody tell
me the zip call is the zip call?
No, no, no, no, no, no. There's a second time she comes on after
Zip Zip. I've heard it's just horrible, man. Okay. The zip zip
stuff sucks. All right. All right. All right. So, then there's
a there's a second time Well, um, thank you for bringing it to
my attention and we'll definitely take it under >> What?
Second time Stardust joins. Wait,
First time stamp.
>> Oh, sorry. This is a second time stamp. Wait, what?
I think you up one of these >> General, um, thank you for
bringing it to my attention and we'll definitely take it under
investment. >> Okay. Thank you so much. I really appreciate
it. Um, and I hope you have a great rest of the stream. >> Thank
you and I appreciate you later. >> Wait, is this is this
it? Uh, thanks for coming on. Wait, I thought there was a second
time. Hold on. What am I supposed to second time star joins Wick?
This is What is this?
There's like a post right here. You were sending me time stamps
for this. This is This is literally at the end of the Stardust
presentation. It's after Zip Zip. Well, I know it's after Zip
Zip technically, but Okay, we'll scroll. Still in Zip Zip. We're
still in zip zip.
Still on Zip Zip.
We're still on Zip Zip.
Apparently, she hops back on right here. Okay, here we go. We'll
talk. We'll talk
>> No, no, it's fine. I really should have just scanned.
That's my bad. I was being like, uh, high maintenance. I should
have just scanned forward. >> Okay, Stardust, you missed
something. Yeah, it's something. Oh, wait. Give her a sec. Okay,
there she's important we have to add, guys. What you got? >> Hey.
Uh, sorry, one more. One second. Uh, just need to Okay, there
we go.
Camera back on.
Okay. And then
um
I just wanted to present some final evidence in my favor that
this person, this isn't just a one-off thing with this person.
Um I'm sending that. >> Oh no. Uh
substance. Are you ready to apologize to Chronic Sonic? Are you
willing to apologize? I think you've
>> obviously sending the gore was like an escalation, but
it's not a one-off thing. Um,
>> yeah, you don't like you. >> Uh, let's see here.
Um,
>> I did actually. Okay. >> No, it's not. >> I
was just memeing. I don't know if you've ever said anything to
Sonic. Let me come back. Um, hold on. Wait, what am I looking
for? >> Oh, here it is. It's not just a one-off thing with
them. Um, uh, it's, um, like personally, I'm not going to be
offended by this, but in case this affects your mod decision.
September 30th, 2025, he posted a picture of an Indian man on
a computer under a racist tweet.
Oh my god,
bro. How does anybody take this seriously in these communities?
Do you know what communities you're in? Do you know like the
kind of [__] these communities have supported in
terms of like racist humor and are we actually pretending none
of us understand?
Are is this honest? Is this serious, man? >> Or anything
like that. There are um several uh things of them just posting
pictures of Indian people in response to things. Um uh you know
>> like racist like like a history of racist jokes and
>> just basically yeah using Indians as like the punch
line which like normally by itself I don't care but like them
stunning gore to me was like over the line. So I'm just going
to throw this in there as like backing evidence that's all. You
know >> and using like racial slurs like I see there. Uh,
oh yeah, using racial slurs. Yeah, for sure. >> It will
just be your paper and then >> reban Ruben donated $3.
When Stardust left, Wick should have said, "Thank you. Come again."
>> Not funny. Not funny.
Do not a post in my donations. That would be terrible. That would
be terrible if you guys figured out that Kickbot probably has
like an apoo voice. Hold on. Wait, does Kickbot have an aoo voice?
Cuz we should probably just do that. I should probably go enable
that if that exists. One second.
>> Uh, but do not use it in a racist way if I were to enable
it. Okay. Do not use that for racist means,
>> but I will go and see in the voice library. Does it
exist?
>> Yeah. Yeah. And I can send this to you as well. So,
I I appreciate it. Thank you so much. Have a good night. K. >> It
doesn't exist. Oh my god. >> Wow. What a time. >> Okay.
Okay. Obviously, we have the
Rees sing one. Okay, that's this voice. >> This is a sample
of the custom voice.
>> That's the That's the Rees. >> Hey, I am exhausted
and I want to go to bed and I got to do things. Well, probably
not go to bed, but I got things to do. Peace. Go, thank you.
Thank you for taking time out of your day to spend with us here
at Wick TV and take on all comers. I thought it was very, very
fun.
>> Wow. That's the whole thing, guys. She forgot she had
more examples of this guy doing racism on Twitter. I mean,
again, I think that's that's different than like targeted I know
you're Indian and doing this. I think in those examples, they're
hypothesizing that somebody is Indian. It's still racism. It's
just not targeted. I sent you more. Oh, there is more. Hold on.
Like, I I can tell you what she's probably doing. She's probably
the kind of like totally
intellectually bankrupt person that is sitting here waiting hoping
that I'll just be like openly racist or misogynist to her like
looking for that so that she can do the only thing she's capable
of intellectually and freaking the [__] out about
that. Right. That's what she's hoping for. Instead, I just criticize
like what she's doing here, the exercise she's undertaking.
She's just sitting here waiting for like a [__] like
a a trap card to be activated. And unless I activate that trap
card, she has no commentary. She has nothing intelligent to say,
nothing to provide. It's why she has no viewership. It's why
she's totally [__] raped as a content creator. Okay.
Metaphorically, of course. >> So, I think that when it's
a bit diff >> uh hold on. Is short Potataku still dodging
you? Yeah. Well, I mean, he is. He's been dodging me the whole
time. I don't know why. Why would I talk to
>> I asked him to explain like how things changed from
the previous entries
>> like a while back. >> Here's the thing. Uh, Jtock
didn't want to give me his give me an interview oneon one. He
didn't want to give me an interview oneon one.
>> Wait, I actually No, I totally offered her an interview
oneonone. That's just a lie. That's like an objective lie. I
literally just said come and we'll talk. Wait, what? She's just
lying.
She literally watched me say you can come on the stream. Quimma
is not going to do anything. Like I can kick Quan out. He can
leave. What is she talking about? What? She's just lying.
>> So I don't know. I'm not joining his server. Certainly
not.
>> I thought Pisco made it very clear he understands it
and didn't disagree with
I again I do believe it's like emotional blackmail here. like
she's she's trying to say it just more effusively to get him
to change his mind. >> Escalating it to the point of sending
violent imagery and sending gore. Sending somebody. >> Yeah,
I remember I remember the whole time saying like, "No, just come
hop on the stream." And like obviously if we tried to like ambush
you or something, that would look horrible for us. Like that
nobody's doing that. Why Why the [__] would we do
that?
>> Like just come on. >> Gore is just antisocial
behavior. It just is. Right. I'm not ask
Yeah. I'm not asking you to to police.
>> Hey, I just want to point out that everyone who is Is
this guy? Maybe he'll come on. Hold on. Will this guil Hold on.
Where's Becket?
[cough] Hold [clears throat] on. Maybe this guilded poo guy will
come on. Let me message Becket. Becket. I just I wonder what
he has to say. This guy have anything to say? I I messaged Becket.
Asked if he could get this kind of call.
I think it shouldn't be that hard, >> Person who says something
there. I'm gonna as a peace offering to Stardust, okay? And to
to try to entice her onto the stream, I'm going to do something
totally epic.
Give me a second. >> And it's just going to be it's just
going to be something stupid. I know it is. I know it's going
to be something
>> Did she open up the weekly top? Hold on. >> Stupid.
I know it is. >> You guys aren't pulling your weight. Resets
in 4 days. 10 subs. Seriously, you guys, are you gift more subs?
Are you serious? This is embarrassing. This is tragic. 10 10's
going to be the 10's the top number for the week.
Are you guys serious? >> Is I know it's going to be something
stupid.
Wait, where is it? Where is the volume here? >> Hold on.
>> No. Why do I How come every time I click on this? >> She
will be safe to join my Discord. Okay. Cuz we have we've we've
neutralized the threat. Okay. What? When Pisco wouldn't capitulate,
I was so moved by her plight
that I myself have timed Substance out for seven days from my
Discord. Okay.
The the true scourge of my community, Substance, has been timed
out from my Discord. Okay, he is gone. Stardust
totally raped. It's so funny.
It's so funny, dude. This person has zero
zero neurotto connections. Okay. There's just nothing firing
up there. >> You got nothing at you. Okay. >> He
is gone.
>> 07.
He gone. He gone. We don't we don't accept anti-Indian hate.
No matter your cast, no matter your creed, we don't accept anti-Indian
hat. >> I don't believe that for one second. You have like
>> Yeah, I'm sorry. That's a lie. If it is funny, racism
is totally acceptable. That is she's she is correct. Hold on.
She neuronal connections. Neuronal neurons in her brain. Neuronal
connections. Nothing. If it's funny enough, basically all racism
is allowed, including against white people. So >> we're
talking about me a couple maybe a while ago. I don't even remember
last time I listened. And uh la last time I listened uh last
time you guys were talking about me, you immediately followed
up talking about me by playing a prank call with a guy with an
Indian accent. [laughter] And
wait, is any mimicking of Indians or Indian culture racism?
Does she understand the lines she's drawing here?
Oh, wait, wait, hold on. There's no way she's talking about a
Cathy call. Is she just talking about a random Cathy call? No
shot. No shot. What? Bro, she just hates fun. This person just
hates fun. What other explanation is there?
By the way, Kathy's not even racist.
I've never Kathy. Well, I guess the accent leads me to believe
that maybe he's got some racist bits he does, but like he's not
racist when he does the accent. He literally memes aside from
it. The accent is like a second skin for >> Like, I don't
believe you for one second. I've seen the things that people
type in your chat. Are you kidding me? No way.
He doesn't like you, Stardust, because you don't have BPD and
didn't sleep with >> See, it's like literally it's just
attacking other people. They have nothing intelligent to say
about me, so they just attack other people. He's >> I'm
unfollowing him on Twitter. Would you at least consider unfollowing
him on
>> I really think it's really bad that you follow him on
Twitter. I don't think she knew that. I have no I have no problem
condemning this action, calling him out. I'll do it right now.
Substances is up. You should apologize further and clarify what
the damage is. I um think that it's really insane that you would
>> I don't know. It's some random person in their community
who does the Indian from Pisco, right? Like the second he says
>> it is a Kathy. It is a Kathy stream. >> Instead
of just saying okay, you could already tell it's a no. >> Apologized.
I think that you should amend it. Um and I totally >> I
think this Jtock guy is so easy to dunk on. It would be funny
to see him crash out. I just don't want to engage with the guy.
I'm sorry. I just >> Dude, like I would get if she wasn't
plugged in at all, I would get not understanding and getting
totally taken in by this. By the way, she wants to mock She wants
to mock Cathy.
My Cathy detection meter going off the charts right now. Okay.
This is a This is a girl with a microphone avatar
with a username of Zog Unboxed.
Now, if she didn't if she wasn't literally friends with Spider
and Loner Box and wasn't literally in Lonerbox's
I could maybe understand how she doesn't understand what's going
on here,
but it's just so transparent and on the nose. And again, just
nothing clicking upstairs at all. How long is she going to talk
to Kathy before banning Kathy?
How long is she going to complain about us listening to a guy
with an Indian accent getting on a call? How is he so good? This
isn't even good. This isn't even good. >> Just don't I'll
watch him and I'll make fun of him, but I just don't want to
engage with him.
You have over 3K messages. Yeah, I sent you a couple of screenshots.
Yeah. >> So, I I've you know, considering what you're going
to say, I'm going to talk to my mod team and we'll see if we
think that there's a violation of the rule. >> Aren't they
I didn't think they're they're not in the highest tier, right?
They're not in the lowest tier. They're in the middle tier, right?
>> I I could be wrong about that. What it looked like to
me based on the screen
Does she think that's serious? Like that matters?
Um, I think you got the tier of chatter wrong. I'm like joking.
Sorry, I'm That is a meme. That's like No, I think they're like
the middle tier. >> Thought that I saw is that it looked
like he was in one of the highest tiers. Yeah. So, >> place
and perhaps there is um I'll I'll take a look.
>> I'm not going to make a decision right now. Yeah. >> As
you know, >> now I'm just watching Kathy interact. >> But
I've definitely heard you. I you >> dude, I get it though.
Listen, Stardust does desperately want that Kathy like chatter
right there because I assume that is Kathy. I'm sorry. Sorry
for having you Kathy that is I assume Kathy and Stardust desperately
wants like someone here to be a person who genuinely engages
in her chat and so it's difficult to ban them. Okay, it's incredibly
difficult to ban them. [laughter] Hey, Pisco. Pisco, just real
quick question. If you are going to talk to your mods,
if you're gonna if you're going to take the step of talking to
your mods, could we get an address, like an addressing of the
doobie situation? Have we gotten that yet? Has he talked to his
mods about Dubbie yet? Okay, you're agreeing to talk to your
mods for Stardust. Could you maybe throw in a little bit of like
a Doobie ban request? Ban review. >> You replied to my
You'll have to link it to me in DMs, Gilded. >> He has
no reason to say that. What?
>> I replied to your tweet. It'll make you feel better.
I think you link it to me in DMs. Guilded. >> He has no
reason to say that. Now, if if he is doing this, if he's going
to go talk to his mods over the Stardust
>> then he needs to also talk about the Doobie situation.
Okay. Doobie has been wronged. Dubbie has been wronged. >> I
do. I feel like
banning Doobie, >> bro. What?
>> That's agree that it's horrible. And we'll take a look
in the don't chat if um I would ask people not to like debate
I see you with that message. If I see additional messages in
Stardust chat, I'll just time you up for my chat. >> Thank
you for bringing it to my >> Stardust chat. Okay.
>> Don't It's >> okay. Thank you so much. I really
>> going to get accused of hate. >> And I hope you
have a a great rest of the stream. >> Thank you. And I
appreciate you later. >> Have a good one. >> Yeah.
Thanks. Uh thanks for coming on, Stardust. That was
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. So I Wow. Wow. Wow. Now,
>> as predicted, >> Stardust does come back on the
stream
>> So, do we watch through? Apparently, there's a zip zip
call. Is the zip call good? Do we watch the zip call? Can anybody
tell me the zip call? Is the zip Wait, what did she Wait, did
she predict something before she started watching it? Hold on.
What? What did she predict?
You predict something? >> He's saying you have a flat ass.
Is he really Wait, is Jtock saying that? Uh, >> no. I'm
I would never say that. I I'm not going to. Sorry. I I had a
joke I was going to go with there. I really
had to be a little careful.
>> Why is Gilded Poo talking about her ass? >> Difficult
to say. >> I want to listen to his >> voice though.
>> Is that Is that all she could say? She just does have
an actual criticism of anything I'm saying throughout the entire
VOD. Wild.
>> No, I'm justified in this. I feel pretty good about
this. Let me Brett, right? Like you feel so negatively about
me. You feel so you feel I'm so low that you're justifying using
a symbol from my culture towards me in in violence, you
>> So So like >> I'm just going to keep highlighting
how she's going to attack me on being fat,
okay? And I'm just going to point out that she's super boring
and nobody cares about her opinions and she can't get viewers
on Twitter because instead of actually working on a docket or
coming up with content, she spent all of her time putting together
a PowerPoint to get a chatterband for one week from a Discord.
Okay, you are so filtered, it's
You are so beyond filtered out of ever being a popular influencer
or having a point to make. Okay, it's over.
she kept watching my stuff. >> Talk to friends about this.
If he thinks this is all about him and Queman, his brain is so
rotted. He >> went back and watched the start of it. Oh
[__]
Let's [__] go.
Hold on. So, she was watching it before and she just watched
the end, but now she's apparently going to take on my challenge
of trying to show that she has any level of intellectual curiosity,
intellectual engagement, intellectual anything, some level of
IQ, and she might actually react to the whole thing. Oh, damn.
>> until like hold on
>> today. Maybe.
See you later. >> I don't have a problem with this. You
let him make the call privately. you don't hold his policies
against him when he stands out of position. But what this is
is going to be like emotional. >> I don't think I even
I don't think I even held it against Pisco. I quite literally
said that.
>> Yeah, you
you didn't hold it against Pisco, but the whole point of doing
it publicly is because you want the audience to get angry at
Pisco. You know exactly what narratives you're leaning into.
Why are you pretending you're stupid? as I was uh I said after
I left the call uh that you know Pisco is a good guy. He's got
a good moral compass
and you know I I'm not I wouldn't hold it against him if he didn't
do anything right. I would hope he would because I do hold him.
>> Okay, I need like five subs right now. I'm going to
keep doing >> standard because I respect him. But what
can I say?
What can I say?
>> Right. trying to say something really disgusting happened
to me and I think you need to ban somebody for it. And if you
don't ban him, if if Pisco doesn't capitulate, he looks monstrous.
And if he capitulates, he looks like a >> I can see how
he sees it that way. >> I again I can see how JTO
>> Oh, bye. >> sees it that way, but no.
>> Why did Why didn't he comment? He could have been here
commenting and he just left. What the >> Oh, another fantastic
point from Kilo here. If you are going to bring this up, I want
to see evidence he went to the mods first.
Did you report this to my mods or did you literally compile this,
keep it in your back pocket to use against me on a wick panel
months later? Weeks later? >> No. Yeah. Not months later.
This happened Christmas Eve. >> Okay. Weeks later. >> Is
um I do. >> Okay. So, she's just being like brutally watching
this like that she can't actually contend with any >> expect
this to come from. Also, also, by the way, I actually didn't
even know that Pisco was like having a weird call-in thingy,
like a Pisco versus the world thingy until like
today, maybe, maybe last night. I don't know. I had no idea.
Um, and I do not expect them to engage in this type of of of
very
>> Okay, so that contends with the statement. How?
How does that contend with the statement? No, no, no. That doesn't
matter. It's literally that you didn't take it to his mods. You
weren't upset about it. You didn't want any like enforcement
action at all. You didn't try to do anything,
right? You just you just let it go. This guy apologized. You
let it go and then you bring it up later. I don't even know why.
It's sad. >> Specific um aggression. Um so, let me break
something down for the audience so they understand where I'm
coming from. just in case Pisco and Wick might not understand.
Okay. All right. So, the cow an Indian >> Dude, there's
no way.
>> There's no way. What? >> Okay. I just I'm sorry.
I kind of get how you might have to do this.
>> Yeah. Uh, okay. Because I've had people already say
like, "Oh, how's the cow significant in this?" So, >> I
mean, >> are you considering writing a Substack outlining
Substance and all his behavior towards you? No.
The behavior I find unacceptable is the gore. >> Dude,
it's crazy that all the people in her chat are just random haters.
There's like Gilded Pooh and a bunch of haters in her chat.
>> It's crazy. >> Um, I put him on blast publicly.
He can do without what he wants. He can choose to
>> Oh, no. Dung Devil. She's She wasn't called the L cow.
What happened with Stardust was uh she she made some stupid reply
to Cherry going in on her for no reason. And people didn't like
that cuz I think Destiny retweeted it, right? And
what happened was some people who I think have followed the Destiny
stuff were pretty that Destiny retweeted it to make fun of Jerry.
And so they went back at Stardust. Stardust, you know, gave them
nonsense.
And somebody posted a butchered cow in her replies.
So Stardust been complaining about anti-Indian like sentiment.
Somebody posted like a picture of a butcher like a cutup cow
like a cow's head or
>> Sorry, someone substance did it. I someone make a better
apology or not.
>> Who knows? But of course, of course, I'm going to put
him on blast. Why wouldn't
just like we didn't put him on blast.
You didn't put him on blast. You came and asked for a ban in
a different
and she's just pretending she's we have to get through to where
she's actually
Hindu theology. It's like a
uh value. Um so as an Indian Muslim um you are raised in a culture
where this animal represents the spirit of the land, right? Um
but anyways, >> wow. So >> that's so cool. >> Uh
on Christmas Eve,
this person, Mr. Substance here, um uh in response, um >> heard
of this guy >> to something that I said on Twitter, um
responded to me with a severed cow >> on Christmas Eve
substance
on Christmas. >> Loser behavior, by the way, you don't
>> to be on Twitter on Christmas Eve. I agree. Yeah, I
agree.
who was fighting with him on Christmas Eve. Yeah, it's loser
behavior. Yeah. >> Anything better? Like I'm having fun.
I'm meing. I'm having a good time on Twitter. I'm making jokes.
Okay.
On Christmas Eve. You decide. This is the very
>> Was I streaming on Christmas Eve? I don't think so.
I'm pretty sure I was at home
if I'm not mistaken. I think I'm pretty sure I was at home. thing
to do is go search for for
that's very specific
type of gore to send to somebody based on their cultural background.
That's a
uh hold on quick check. Okay, really specific. You spent your
Christmas Eve. Hold on. Hold on. Um Hold on. Cut up cow gore
images.
Uh already found images of a cutup cow. Already found pictures
of a dead cow. Took me eight seconds.
Wow.
Wow. WOW. WOW.
WOW. WOW.
Why are we pretending this took a long time? Uh, if you want
to get really specific, severed cow's head. Severed cow's head.
I see a lot of pictures of severed cow's heads now. Took me one
search, two seconds. Oh my god, this was very difficult. I could
never I could never have done this.
>> A totally normal thing to do.
>> So normal. Eve of all days on Christmas Eve. Are you
serious?
On Christmas Eve
>> head and severed cow legs. Um I know that this substance
person
um posts clips uh for several other content creators. I >> who
she hates. That's by the way.
>> Oh, I don't care. I I think I retweeted Substance before
because he tweeted he like tweeted a clip that I liked. So I
don't care like business is business, right? Um yeah, sure. I
don't particularly like Jtock. I don't particularly like Queen.
But yeah, Substance has posted stuff from other people. I like
>> No, you guys see about us a lot
in your chat about that. Um,
but no, when you post things that are gore, I am not
like I'm not down with it. I just am not down with it.
>> It's not all I like I feel like as much as they complain
about there being like
people making a conspiracy about there being a cabal of Queen
and Jtock people. They do the same thing with me. There's a what
am I running am I a witch? Am I like a a seamstress? Like am
I spinning a web? Where? >> Okay. I regret asking her to
actually give her thoughts. >> I'm like trying to take
down
Queenman with every move that I make. Hello. Like
I like Yeah. Is >> I didn't say she was trying to take
down Queenman. I said she was trying to take down she was shoes
she with Pisco doing this. He's like emotionally blackmailing
>> Like a Is there a Stardust conspiracy?
>> Do I have to go open up Wix like VOD to go look at this
and see what the chat's saying?
I have to go up Wix. Should I go open Wix VOD and see how the
chat's reacting to this whole thing as it goes
That would be a fun exercise, wouldn't it? Hold on. Let me see.
Wick TV. Wick-tv. Let me go to the Wick TV VOD. See if we can
find the actual reactions to this as it was happening. Pisco
versus the world. Pisco versus the world. Pisco versus the world.
Do we have the chat from this?
I do have the chat. Don't be disabled. Don't be disabled. Don't
be nice. Disabled. Okay.
>> So, go. We'll find the stardust call in where we get
our little PowerPoint presentation. Okay.
Why are we talking about Hinduism? Okay, that's fair. Um, >> so
you think it's it's targeting you
because of your ethnic background. >> How long is this
beef going to take? Why is this on the show? Okay, never mind.
Actually, sorry. I never mind. Actually, everybody's just being
like, Stardust, why the [__] are you doing this?
Oh, never mind. Jesus.
Everybody's just actually doesn't care at all. >> Send
somebody something like that, you know? Um, like in all my time
online, I have been sent plenty of things like that, but to get
it from somebody who is a progressive, somebody who I have seen
tweet things that are like, oh, men who
>> um, violence to
you would have liked to see more specificity, more connection
to the harm it caused >> and an acknowledgement.
>> Dude,
thank you, Wick. She is venting, but this poor woman has dealt
with a lot of hate for speaking her mind. Not enough. Is Stardo
going to apologize to sick? She should apologize to sick
>> vile [__] >> But he's using strong
rhetoric like disgusting depraved debase. Um you're saying that
that the fact >> it feels when it's >> when it's
connected with the fact that it's all about him. The the first
part of it where it's just it's just about him. Um
>> yeah. So So here's why. >> Let's see here. Okay.
I'm looking for literally anybody to say anything useful >> Hey,
first of all,
>> never mind. I really thought people in Wick's chat would
be, but I I guess nobody cares. We'll see if anybody else covers
it. I suppose >> that I'm just behind like No, I am [clears throat]
offended by >> Do you think we'll win in a debate? Sardis
or Hutch?
>> I wanted to call him out.
>> I'm sorry.
So, you didn't want to do that on Twitter? You didn't really
call him out. You called Pisco out.
Did she not understand that? That she like literally put Pisco
on the spot. She didn't put substance on the spot. There's no
way she's too dumb to understand that, right? >> How am
I supposed to believe that this isn't explicitly because I substance
out and said he does a great job clipping and we love >> Bro,
I literally do not watch your stream. The last time I watch your
stream is when I tweeted about your fat voice. Okay, that is
the last time I I tweeted about your stream or sorry, last time
I watched your stream is when I tweeted about it. That is basically
you can guarantee
if I
>> this gets one ompic prescription and starts calling
other people fat. You hate to see it. >> If I have watched
the stream, I have tweeted about it. Otherwise, I don't waste
my time. I have other things to do.
I have like a life to live. >> Substance. How am I
a life to live?
Uh, you just put together an entire PowerPoint presentation to
complain about a random
less than thousand subscriber Twitter account. Do you that Pisco
is almost entirely unaware of? He said he followed it cuz they
clipped him once or twice.
You put together a PowerPoint presentation and then tried to
ambush Pisco with it on a stream.
Please never ever ever say you have a life to live ever again.
Dude,
are you serious? Okay, sorry, Sophia. You're right. An entire
PowerPoint presentation, it probably took her like 20 minutes
to put it together. You're right.
You cared enough to put any effort or thought into trying to
get substance banned from Pisco's Discord. That makes you the
biggest loser on planet Earth. You are aing loser. Don't try
to say you have a life. You don't have a life. Am I supposed
to believe that this isn't because of that? How am I supposed
to believe that this isn't explicitly just because >> his
brain is so rotted if he thinks this is all about him and Queman?
His brain is so rotted. He wishes. He wishes I thought about
him that much. My
>> Sorry. You're right. You're right. You're right. You're
right. You're right. She tried to get him banned for a week.
She tried to get him banned for a week. I've shouted substance.
a totally irrelevant consequence for anybody in this space. And
to prove that, I timed him out of my Discord for a week. Nobody
gives a about being timed out from a Discord for a week. Get
the out of here. And he posts clips from this stream and Queen's
stream. >> Oh boy.
Conspiracy runs deep, guys. I don't know those other content
creators. I have a >> bro. She doesn't even >> immense
amount of respect for Peace Go. I think is very person um posts
clips uh for several other content creators. I don't know those
other content creators. I have >> I don't know those other
>> like I don't know them personally. I don't know them
personally >> but I do know uh I do know Pisco personally
and Pisco is a nice guy. I like him.
When a guy drives on about what a
ally he is, he doesn't get to send racist gore to a woman without
some sort of backlash. But no, this is all
>> the subs drone on about what a respectful non-racist
ally he is.
>> queen? Very true.
Very so true.
>> Wait, what? Wait, what? Wait, what? Wait. Huh?
Wait. Huh?
>> I mean, you just did a whole presentation. You didn't
look through the content of the account and see if there's people
you knew.
>> Wait. Okay. So, yeah, we can play this game with words
or whatever. But again, it's like I don't know the other content
creators, as in I don't know them personally. On a personal level,
I do know Pisco on a personal level. I do know his character.
I do know that he's got a good moral.
>> Wait, would you say you don't know Queman's character?
Did you say you don't know my charact? You have a lot of opinions
on our character. What are you talking about? You don't know
them personally. As in you're not friends with them? Then why
didn't you just say I'm not friends with the people who get clipped
by this account? Still wouldn't be true, by the way. It's just
she's just coping for saying something totally,
>> you know. Hey, keep >> um Okay. Uh Turkey, I understand
what you're saying. Um I am not aware of Pisco being attacked
for having a bad community. I >> Uh-oh. I'm not aware of
Pisco being attacked for having a bad community. It's just like
Aiden, right? It's just the same thing where she's just like
gonna lie.
Oh, me when I lie. Me when I lie. Oh, boop. Suddenly a little
lie pops out. Oh my god.
>> I am only like I I preface that
by saying that this is not an indictment on his community and
not an indictment of him.
I I very much said that. So I think that >> Okay.
Well, I wish I wish Substance would have had the foresight
when he posted that tweet to go, "Actually, this is because I
think you're a cow and I'm threatening you physically. It's not
racist at all." I wish he'd had the foresight to make it clear
it wasn't racist. I don't actually wish that. I'm just aiming
along. But Jesus Christ, man. Like, you can't just say, "Well,
this isn't racist," and it's now not racist, right? You couldn't
do that.
You couldn't do it. You can't say, "Well, actually, this is a
racist." And then post something that's racist intentionally
and then be saved. What what you say is disconnected from your
actions. What your actions are doing is irre like it makes sorry
this what you say is irrelevant when your actions like follow
through and do put him on the spot and do get him in trouble
And again, just anytime you're going to complain about moderation
with regards to a community, you should have gone to that community's
moderators first. Yeah, I'm sorry. It's just not this is not
relevant to me, okay? I'm not following whatever drama that is.
But
yeah, of course I'm going to put substance on blast. >> Yeah,
DW, you just missed it. >> Uh Destiny went on a whole thing
about how he wanted Pisco to start moderating his community because
they were saying mean things about Destiny. There's a whole thing
with um Doobie donating money to Pisco to like post facts about
Destiny that he didn't like. >> He deserves it. What >> people
need to know that this dude who claims he's a feminist, who claims
he's not a racist, he's against racism,
>> is a psycho who is neither of those
>> and yeah. So again, Jtock can play whatever word games
he wants with this, but when I say that I don't know these people,
I mean I don't know them personally. I don't know the character
of you. All I know is that you're like
>> she doesn't know the character of me. She should have
been talking about my character a lot
and she she's made a lot of tweets about my character. She's
made a lot of tweets and a lot of comments about Queen's character.
I don't know you per I don't know you personally. I don't know
your character. You sure whine about us a lot >> like a
online. Okay. Um Pisco is somebody I know the character of. Okay.
Uh I believe in the character of Pisco. I appreciate Pisco.
Um, I know that he's an intelligent guy. I have an immense amount
of respect for him.
That's what I mean when I say I know Pisco.
I don't know those other >> hop on stream. I do in this
in this stream. She doesn't want to do it. >> I don't know
them on a personal level. >> Hold on. I don't know what
tweet this is. I hope it's not going to be something that I don't
want brought up on stream. No, it's not.
Like if she just scrolled
Hassan Willy. Heard of them. Fairy Queen. Heard of Stardust.
Obviously knows Fairy Queen. No idea who this is.
>> Uh,
Pisco
Andrew Wilson. Feel like you might know
>> Uh, you're literally talking to Pisco at this precise
moment in time.
>> Becket Copeny with a not so erodite tweet. Amazing.
>> Uh, Chud Logic, you know him. Wait, just hold on a second.
Would you know Becket?
>> What kind of person sends gore in the first place? That's
what I'm saying. Why would you do that? It's like such a antisocial
strange thing to do. I like that he apparently he stopped watching
me live. He should have kept watching because I I don't know.
I guess he's scared. I guess >> it was boring.
>> You're not going to react to this. J. Somebody tell
him.
>> Somebody tell me. But >> I guess he's too scared
to to handle people about him,
>> I guess so. You're right. >> It's all the stardust.
She's right. my my grand plan to take down. >> That's what
this is about. It's totally not about substance sending me gore
and me not liking that gore. It's totally not about me being
disturbed by gore.
>> Wait, also, just to be clear, we all said don't send
gore. Everybody said that. What this is about is you being a
totally neurotic freak who decided to go on a stream that was
about Pisco and and his political like thoughts and you decided
to make it about you and beef you had with somebody who clips
him
because he's in their dis he's in their sorry yeah substances
in Pisco's Discord. That is an insane neurotic loser thing to
do. You are a total complete and utter loser.
That's what this is about.
I I want to know exactly what Pic was sent. It's a dismembered
cow
with its head cut off. Like it's And by the way, for a oneweek
timeout,
for a oneweek timeout, that's insane loser behavior.
you didn't think, "Hey, I'll go study Pisco's position on this
and ask him some questions." You didn't think, "Hey, I disagree
with Pisco over here politically. I'll go ask some questions
about that." You went, "Hey, Pisco, this guy's like in your Discord.
Could you time him out for a week? It's really He's really mean.
>> Like, yeah. >> No, like cut up in a I I don't
know, dung devil. Like cut up in a field or something. Think
of the worst example you could think of and consider it that.
>> Just wait though because just wait
until she gets through this. We'll keep >> No evidence
to back up me being disturbed by it. There aren't group chat
logs of me being upset by it. There aren't,
you know, logs with me talking to my friends being upset by it.
Yeah, totally. Doesn't exist. Not a real
>> Everybody thinks you could be upset by it. Nobody said
you can't be upset by it. I I'm
skeptical that you're actually upset by it. Okay. I'm quite skeptical,
but
Okay. Block him.
Block him.
tell him that's really up.
There's a whole bunch of things you could do to go crash the
panel that has Pisco on it to bring up moderation in his Discord
and then say, "Oh, well, I didn't know there was anybody else
accusing him of something like this." Oh my god, I didn't know
it. Shut up. Wait, is there a creator that that Substance posts
clip clips of that Stardust doesn't actually know? Is there a
single one? >> It's just more word play with like know
and doesn't know. And obviously what I mean is no on a personal
level, right?
>> like it's actually the precise opposite. Is there a
>> Why would it matter if you knew the creators clipped
on a personal level?
>> Creator that she doesn't know that Substance Post clip
clips of >> go to anybody about this. Um but it's not just
words at this point. It is somebody sent me gore. Um, and uh,
and that is an escalation
>> of rhetoric. UM, >> WOW. WOW. WOW. >> I
can give you some of the backstory. I I made a I made a joke
a three.
>> Totally disavow this. By the way, this is like, by the
way, this is just stupid to do. Um, like in a real sense, it's
stupid to do because even if I I don't necessarily think Stardust
I don't think this the even close to the worst harassment Stardust
gotten. I don't think it's anything like that. I really don't
think it's that bad in her mind, but just giving her the ability
>> actually. It is. It is. It is. Uh, words on the internet
are one I become completely desensitized. And I understand for
somebody like Jtock,
this is kind of incomprehensible because I've talked to friends
about this and they also were like, "Oh, this is what bothered
you." So I understand it.
I understand like that he maybe doesn't comprehend this, but
for me I he maybe
friends about this and they also were like, "Oh, this is what
bothered you." >> Wait, her friends were also confused.
So her friends were also confused and then she's like it's incomprehensible
to this guy.
>> Understand for somebody like Jtock
this is kind of incomprehensible because I've talked to friends
about this and they also were like oh this is what bothered >> This
is what bothered you. It sounds to me like she's trying to say
that it's like not shocking for me but regular human beings but
maybe she's saying it's not shocking and she's giving me credit.
Hold on. Maybe she's saying, "Oh, I understand why people wouldn't
believe this." Cuz my friends also thought that this this was
weird. That is >> so I understand it.
I understand like that he maybe doesn't comprehend this. But
for me,
>> I have dealt with the words. I have dealt with the insults.
I have dealt with literally every insult thrown at me. But I
cannot deal with the violent imagery. I cannot
I cannot do that. I That is one. It is just too far for me. It
is
Okay. Um, that sucks.
But like block
um I Twitter automatically like catches these things and censors.
I there's like a million different things to like filter this
stuff out.
>> Just too far. You know, I was a vegetarian since I was
like 16 or 17. Uh, I only recently switched to being a >> Oh
god, I just realized that she's
This is um this is one of those things where she just went and
basically explained to everybody what actually upsets her. Um,
I've already said if you if you post this in her like responses,
I'd probably just ban you for being annoying, right? But she
is sort of laying out precisely the kind of thing that upsets
her.
Uh, that's pretty stupid to do. pescatarian
in recent years like since I was like yeah 16 or 17 I was a vegetarian
and I was strict vegetarian I did not break up the day I did
it was done totally completely entirely unacceptable
>> it was um
it it was very very upsetting for me
>> and and the way that I became a vegetarian was actually
I was at this
>> play this alltime Stardust clip right now. Hold on.
What is this? >> Oh my god. An insult. Jesus. >> Okay,
let me finish. Let me finish.
>> Let's say you're forced into a human centipede. You
You are the middle. You have no choice in this. What you can
choose is who is behind and who is in front of you. Your choices
are from mom and dad. Who do you choose?
>> I choose to [__] your entire country. You
brown, savage, disgusting animal. the important question. >> What
the [__] >> WHY IS THAT OKAY, BRITNEY? Why
do you not mute them, but you mute me? Like, why is that okay?
This is why people think this whole platform is racist and nobody
wants to come here. >> You're a felon. >> Do you
not understand that? >> Hey, it's Dingo. That guy's a minor
in this video. That's weird.
>> Oh, yeah. Cope and cope and see, right? Cope and
>> cope and see. Keep coping and seething.
>> Uh,
wow. What a clip. and somebody approached me and said, "Hey,
you should take one of our flyers." I took the flyer and it was
all about how the torture that these animals are in these
>> Um, but also again, the cow is is a it is uh something
that is
I I can't tell if this is
like aristocracy tier like I'm traumat I'm
Is that like what this is where she's like convincing herself
it's like so much more hardcore than anything else she's seen
on the internet? Like I I think this is some kind of like self-traumatizing
thing where she's like trying to pretend she cares about Hinduism
or something >> is very respected in Indian and DY culture.
It just is. Even in Pakistan when they you know which is full
of Muslims they have cow farms even in even in Pakistan
they will put uh dressings on these cows they'll put you know
um like all these flowers garlands all over the cows
cows are deeply respected in my culture
American culture you stupid [__]
What is she talking about?
Cows are deeply respected in that they are the backbone of the
American food economy. Okay, go to any Burger King or McDonald's
to see how much cows are respected in your actual culture.
The are we talking about? Whether I am Hindu or not, the this
principle of nonharm, nonviolence is a a cornerstone
like uh you know of Indian culture. The cow was so important
to the average person in India in rural India
through throughout history. >> Okay, maybe I'm maybe I'm
like maybe she actually spent a lot of time in India as a kid.
Maybe she's very connected to her Indian culture. I don't understand
what we're going for here, okay? She wasn't connected enough
that it mattered when she hung out in all these white supremacist
panels and constantly got mocked in a racist fashion. So, I just
don't understand why the culture is such a major thing now. I
do believe people accused her of being like a pick me minority
for racists in the past and she totally said like that's not
that's not who I am. That's not who I am. That's not who I am.
So, like what
now apparently this stuff's all really >> Three star who
harassed by Vene. already explaining it to you. You're just here
to
uh try and divert things. I feel I already explained things to
you. It's just it like it to act like this has no cultural significance
for me. >> Um I'm sorry, but it was a deeply upsetting
and deeply violent thing. What made you decide to go pescatarian?
Um I >> Dude, I don't I straight up don't believe her.
Like I I would still say like don't do it on the grounds that
it's stupid to do it on the grounds that like there's no reason
to give her like the like there's no reason to do it. I I would
say even on the grounds that I could be wrong. Okay. And it maybe
does really affect her.
But holy [__] I don't believe >> realized I
needed protein
and it is way easier to get fat as the vegetarian.
We're being real. So >> to go and do this is pointless.
Like it actually hurts you. It's like strategically just a bad
thing. Um >> it hurt me deeply. It hurt my heart to see
that. Like it it actually hurt my heart to see. >> Okay.
I just don't understand.
Like
again, maybe I'm not the creator to go over this, but why the
should I give a [__] about this whole character swap
she's done when she's mocking Cherry? reason that sick is going
after her is because she's mocking Cherry for her conversion
to Christianity.
Why should I care about any of this? She's taking Cherry sincere
thoughts, right? I'm I I'm just going to leave it alone. It's
just like it's so transparently hypocritical. She's so full of
Please let there be clips contradicting these takes. Oh, she
already is insensitive to other people's.
Yes, Velvet Moss. That's how this whole thing kicks off is she
decides that she's going to go on Twitter and like quote tweet
Cherry and mock her and then Destiny retweets her and so substance
is in her replies getting mad at her and now she's like you guys
really need to respect my d newfound like deep connection to
my culture and how like sensitive I am about it. It's like okay
do you remember how any of this started?
You remember how any of this started right now as you virtue
signal about this? You stupid.
I sorry I should use a different word cuz I don't want to give
her the card. Oh no, they're being misogynistic.
But holy, it's just embarrassing, man. >> That cow
and then, you know, to see the violence of it like uh it >> Oh,
didn't she bully some trans women that didn't pass into crying?
I do believe there's a whole thing with Jaylen as well, right?
hurt my heart that somebody thought so lowly of me that they
felt they they felt I'm so inferior that it's justified
to send me an image that symbolizes violence against my culture.
>> what if he posted fish? >> Such an unbelievable
>> unbelievable twist. >> Obviously, if I saw a fish
head, I probably wouldn't feel the same way.
I again just with how it started >> the fish doesn't have
that cultural significance to me. The cow does and he knew that
he knew I was Indian and he went out and he he sought that picture
to send to me.
He sought that picture to send to me.
>> He did. If I if I thought started just wait if you guys
didn't watch this segment when it started if you're not aware
of how this ends with with with
what substance says to end this. Okay, it gets even better. >> Wasn't
able to like go hard on like other people in a whole bunch of
ways. Like she's obviously I Dude. Oh yeah, I see. I specifically
didn't bring up the tweet she's referencing cuz it was just gay
of her to bring this up. Like just bizarre of her to the whole
tweet was one joke. >> I just let it go cuz then
>> I understand. I let it go because it was going to be
me violating to not substance. So I just I just moved on. Okay.
But uh yeah, don't let don't let people being like bait you into
doing things that aren't smart.
Don't do it, >> Word joke. Uh incredible rebrand tbh when
it was something about Cherry posted about God or whatever.
Um he quotes uh tweet somebody else quote tweeted me then I said
I have my own personal conflict with Cherry. Has nothing to do
with Destiny or anybody in that space.
>> Yeah, I know. I know. wrote a message. I know. I know.
It's unbelievable.
>> Years before I was friends with >> No, you weren't
>> with Destiny. Um, I wasn't even really that close with
him to be honest with
>> I'm sorry, I'm going to miss that. >> Yeah. Substance
did the This is like a cow's head. Like it's a dismembered cow,
I believe. >> What was that in response to?
>> It was in response to Cherry uh saying something about
like how God is good and all of that, right? And so my my
>> Cherry does like a totally positive tweet. You just
[__] on her for no reason and then you're like, "No,
respect my new found respect my new found love of my culture."
No, you have to respect it. Why?
I It's so baffling. >> It's a sub tweet. I screenshotted
it and I put incredible rebrand tbh. Then somebody quote tweeted
that and said because Destiny retweeted that tweet that I'm like
helping aid his um image or whatever. even though my tweet was
literally three words, had nothing to do with him. Okay. >> Um
I don't choose who retweets my tweets, you know, I don't have
control over that. Anyways,
so then I said I said basically Cherry and I have our own issues
prior to any of what you guys are talking about. Um and I'm allowed
to be in public about it if I want to, right? Um but you know,
I'm using my words, right? This guy says, "Yes, starter. You
you are in fact allowed to be a petty and vile vindictive on
Maine if you want to. Truly brilliant stuff here." I replied,
"Boohoo, I hurt your sensitive feelings." That >> like
I just don't I don't understand the victimization at all.
>> Maybe she can make it make sense. >> I truly believe
that
this what Substance did is less bad than what Stardust did to
Sick.
>> Oh, really? Okay. >> What Stardust did to Sick
is so much worse than what Substance did to her. It's like they're
not even in the same ballpark.
It's actually totally
>> It's totally >> not even in the same ballpark.
Okay. Or Okay. Which part of what I did to Sick? >> Insane
and disgusting that she'll bring this up.
>> What did she do again? Um, she used as a dunk on sick
the fact that he was as a kid and then so the fact that he >> Okay,
you want to go that far? What did Cherry use as a dunk on on
Kelly?
Cherry used Kelly's medical condition to dunk on her.
>> A medical condition that is deeply painful for Kelly.
>> Oh, wait. What? >> Well, do we want to go there?
Yeah, I used this thing. What did six say about me imply that
>> cuz she's she's going to say it was about the vaginismas
and it wasn't at
>> I think I think Cherry said something about white women
self victimizing or or some [__] It was like a vague
comment that was barely even on the level. Dude, it was it was
about Kelly like basically faking an illness not get on stream.
>> I was taking money for my videos.
If you're going to tell a lie about me, I will
tell a truth about you. I will tell a truth about you. >> What
is she giga chatting the fact that she uses guy's like um trauma
as a child against him?
So, hold on.
Yeah, I also don't even understand why would that be relevant.
I
I literally don't understand why that would be relevant at all.
What does that have to do with anything? Wait, what does that
have to do with >> on Kelly?
>> Why? Where is Cher? Where is Cherry?
You're the person You're the person who goes after Cherry. She's
not here.
How is this helping? How How Why are you bringing that up?
>> Oh, whoops. Muted. deeply painful for >> Also,
just to be clear, I'm not the one saying, "Oh, you have to be
nicer to everybody." Where am I saying that? >> Well, do
we want to go there? Yeah, I used six thing. What did six say
about me? Implied that I was taking money for my videos.
If you're going to tell a lie about me, I will. Um, actually
sick implied that I took money for um for like my videos and
so I made fun of him for his childhood
He he kind of implied that I might take money to put ideas on
the internet and so I was like you and then your sister when
you were like 10, loser. [laughter]
Sardos is amazing,
dude. She Why does she keep reacting? What is her problem? Why
did she keep reacting?
She doesn't know. I think so. This is a whole thing where Briana
Woo is approaching people Koser for
to write like a hit piece on Froggen apparently that was leaked
and then people thought because Stardust wrote a Fro made a Frogen
hit piece around that time that she took money for it. I think
people were saying that
>> tell a truth about you. I will tell a truth about you.
>> Blessed I think his his sister or something and it was
basically that sick was himself. as a kid. And as people know,
if you get if you are as a kid, you're likely to not understand
why it's bad and do it back. It wasn't something he was like
doing and and wanted to do and like like he was but he was like
10, I think. I think he was like 10 or 11. He was like a a little
kid. >> Yeah. See, um, and there are people in other people's
audiences who've said equally horrible things to me as well.
>> What? Equally horrible
in other people's audiences? I don't What? Where where is she
moving the goalpost to? This this
uh I need to think of I need something I need something that's
just not going to hit any of the thing any of the this person.
Okay, I'm trying not to give her any of her stupid outs. This
is asking for empathy
while consistently explaining why she doesn't have to give any
empathy to anybody else. [__] is way too personal
with you guys. if we could just call each all call each other
racial racial slurs. No, hold on. Somebody sent her like a dead
cow because she was being a [__] and she's like,
"Oh, Gore is actually the worst thing that's ever like I was
totally rattled. This hurt my heart." It's like, bro, I've heard
Ethan Ralph talking about you flashing your flaps on stream.
I've heard this rant from him.
How mad were you about that? Did you go on stream with him ever
again after
Like, what are we what are we comparing this to? I don't know
what to say. >> She's acting like her culture is this deeply
important, deeply like ingrained thing that she has to protect.
And it's like, we saw you on the stream. We saw you be like the
Pikmi minority that constantly racially demeaned.
Why are you acting like your culture is really important to you?
You're perfectly happy to use your culture to get on like streams
and that you never would have gotten on otherwise, right? just
to be the person who is racially demeaned and >> Like,
I mean, these are words. We exchange words, okay? That's what
we do.
>> And now she's trying to make it about gore when nobody
gives a about this. It's, by the way, it's animal gore, which
is gross,
but I don't know why we pretend that you're like scarred for
life. Hold on. This woman watched any of the October 7th videos.
Those are way worse, aren't they? Carrie said horrible [__]
to people.
>> Uh I'm sure Jason
>> and and
so this all started Koser I'm glad you're here. This all started
because Stardust decided to hop on a panel and she put together
a PowerPoint presentation for Pisco guy who's like a leftwing
debater to say this guy sent me a picture of a dead cow and I
think you should time him up from your discord for a week supposed
to be Pisco arguing about politics. She put together a PowerPoint
and went to this thing and explained how the cow is sacred to
Indian people and how actually this person who sent her a cow
said on Twitter was really mean and he needs to be banned from
your discord for a week. He should be banned from your discord
for a week.
Does she understand that what we're criticizing here is the neuroticism
it takes to do that? sock said horrible to
like people in some of these community. >> Oh, by the way,
I listen I
may have laughed at somebody making a joke about it in chat and
at some point, but I've explicitly gone out of my way never to
weaponize Destiny's like childhood trauma.
So, no, even somebody who I very much hate, very much like dislike,
no, I've never gone out of my way to weaponize that against him.
I might have laughed at a joke in chat about it. I I'm not going
to lie. I don't I don't recall. But it's like I will laugh about
really really insane in chat unfortunately. Okay. But I've never
I've gone out of my way even though it would be convenient to
not weaponize that against him. So no, I think there are some
lines and you know mocking somebody's childhood trauma or their
like life struggles because of that childhood trauma. Pretty
weird. have said horrible below the belt stuff and used like
my against me just like Cherry's used Kelly against her and used
other people's [__] against them.
>> What is this argue? I c can anyone trace the argument?
>> Uh I'm sure JC said horrible to people
like people. >> No, Koseri is explicitly not Hindu. This
is just an insane virtue signal for I don't know what. >> And
some of these communities have said horrible belowthe belt stuff
and used like my against me just like Cherious used Kelly against
her and used other people against them.
These people are really mean with words.
I What is she Does anyone know where she's going? Can anybody
explain what she's trying to argue even?
I actually don't know what she's trying to argue. Does she understand
that you're supposed to line up like premises to come to a final
conclusion? Like there should be some directionality to it. You're
like actually trying to make a point. What point are you trying
to make? That everybody talks this way and everybody's a little
unhinged in these spaces. Yeah. That's why Pisco told you to
off. I don't know if you realize this. That's why he told you
to go kick
because obviously this isn't a standard you would apply to anybody
else. Hey. Okay. No, never mind.
Uh, these are words.
Okay,
words are very different from pictures of violence. They are.
They just are. I'm sorry. There is a line. I am not okay with
that. That is a That is the line for me. >> Yes. Yeah.
He was like a little kid. So, it's it's that it's a picture of
a cow. It's a cultural comment, but it's a picture of a cow.
That is where the line is,
apparently.
which by the way I'm I'm fine with if she'd messaged Pisco's
mods if she'd messaged Pisco privately but instead she made a
PowerPoint and went on a Wick panel to try to weaponize this.
It's but >> I mean don't volunteer the information if you're
not ready to get have it used against you. That's what I I learned
from you people.
Don't
>> Okay.
Um Okay. So,
she understands. She understands.
Why is she opting into these things? >> She doesn't understand.
I don't know why she's saying these things.
Is this the way it is or not? You just gave people a bunch of
information about what upsets
Is that now something now? Now
you can't be this this you can't be mad it's used against you,
right? You just gave people very personal information about what
upsets you on Twitter, right? >> Volunteer the information.
actually have no idea where she's going. >> Nobody has
this consideration for anybody. This is a standard that I am
only only me is held to. Only me >> because you're trying
to go hold others to that standard right now. Yes. I think we
all have opted like out of oh, somebody like sending you an offensive
picture probably if it's not illegal probably isn't something
you should get that mad about. Or if you're going to, you just
go to somebody's mods.
So, it's the combination of you like virtue signaling about this
and doing so on a public platform, interrupting Twi Pisco's Wick
platform or sorry, Wick panel thing, whatever. Pisco versus the
world to bring this up to talk to him about his Discord moderation
and then he just asked for a week ban. By the way, just in case
you guys are getting a little bit bored, just wait cuz when you
figure out like where this goes actually,
okay, wait, maybe I should spoil a little bit. The spoiler is
Substance wrote out a very like like a multi paragraph apology
for sending the picture. He literally apologizes
like the the same day. He says, "Oh, that was really wrong of
me. I'm so sorry." Like I I I need to apologize cuz I've actually
demeaned myself by sending this picture. Dude, trying to hold
him responsible for that. You're like make you're like making
>> I can't wait until we get there. One second. I'm just
going to grab some
Uh she did also like tra sorry repost material that was from
revenge porn of sick. Yep. >> I don't know if >> uh
no it wasn't revenge. It was a profile picture or not even a
pro. It was like a picture of his face and it was from one of
those like apparently he did in the past. Um they can keep saying
it's like revenge or whatever that that that is that was no like
the people I have talked to who have seen that I've had friends
who have seen that material.
I have not looked at it myself but um yeah people say that it
is not it is uh it is that is that somebody volunteered to take
part in. So yeah >> she knew it was from revenge sick.
I don't know the whole detail there. >> I I don't No, it
wasn't from revenge. It was like stuff that he put out there.
He put out there, >> but she did repost like a picture
of Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Okay.
If it was from commercially available sick,
then that would not be revenge. Okay, it wouldn't be.
But she understands that if it's sick made in like an amateur
way himself and he sent it to somebody else and it was released
that is definitionally revenge. Okay,
we know that, right?
We have to know that. I I hope
is he tried to have scrubbed off the internet, bro. Well, it's
definitely not revenge if he did it for economic reasons.
That does suck for him. But I will say if it if it's not re that
would make it not revenge. No, if if you're selling it that means
it's not revenge.
>> I get that he might be trying to have it scrubbed off
the internet and whatever, but that's like explicitly not revenge.
Different crime. It's still a scummy to do, right? It's still
a scummy thing to do, but it's not revenge porn. doesn't really
save her because honestly the picture of his face that might
have been from revenge I think that's way less disgusting to
be honest with you than the actual
>> Oh you don't know how it was originally produced yeah
okay then maybe it is still revenge but the comments about his
childhood like his childhood trauma >> worse obvious him
I think she uses her avatar a picture from revenge born of
>> it was a fully clothed picture of him
that I put my avatar the picture that posted was a fully clothed
picture of >> I think I say the avatar in just a second.
What? >> I think something like that. Gummy burst. Thank
you very much for getting this up. Another hour on the stream.
Let's go. >> But it's just it's crazy signal about this.
She'll like moral frog. >> It's totally a virtue signal
that I don't um appreciate violence
>> when she's done something so much worse. Like in very
recent
worse so much worse and very recent memory. I've got a fat voice
because I'm
>> Remotely under. And by the way, she immediately backed
off. She was like immediately like trying to pretend she didn't
do it >> when she like after it turn. So first she doubled
down if I remember >> Like I didn't know what website it
was from. I just know that it was from him
>> I think first she doubled down on
>> if she wants to go like running.
>> I'd go run with her.
>> Compare 5k times. I'm fine with that with him. And then
she started getting people like pointing out how it was for her
to do this. And then she like, >> "No, I stand by what
I did. I stand by what I did. If you're going to tell a lie about
me, I will tell truths about you. If you're going to tell a lie
about me, I will tell truths about you."
>> Your mile stat. Um,
I don't know. I got my 5K under um,
>> dude. I think I got it down to like 24 minutes, actually.
>> But I need to start running again. And it's probably
up to like 28 29 minutes
>> Wait, what did she just ask?
>> Tell a lie about me. I will tell truths about you.
have been told truths about Stardust
told me by people who asked me never to bring it up that it was
like about a separate point. And I do feel like I do feel like
she deserves those truths to be like talked about, but I won't.
I won't. I'll leave it. I'll beg post. I hope she sees this.
>> You do not get to slander me and imply that I took money
for my videos and not have me hit back at you.
I will not take >> So, call him like ugly or something.
Say he like failed as a content creator. There's like a thousand
different ways you could mock sick. There's like a thousand.
I like it's so easy to just leave that one thing alone. And by
the way, it's not even that you couldn't make fun of it. I definitely
would talk to people who have made fun of it like with sick.
I'd say I'd probably wonder if they like had a proper opinion
on it now, but you could easily make fun of it. Like that's not
even a problem, dude. That's not a problem. The real problem
is that you're now trying to say like, "Oh, actually, like, don't
be mean to me." By the way, we should probably write it to Dan
Selman, who's going to do sick. Uh maybe I don't know. >> I
will not take it.
>> I am not playing these games anymore with you.
You can claim that oh all this stuff about substance is about
uh Queen and and Jtock.
No, it's not. You sent me gore. You do not send women gore. You
do not send anybody gore. Let alone you went out of your way
to find
Gore specifically that would speak to >> I'm just going
to keep laughing at her for doing this virtue signal. It is a
virtue signal. You've never been connected to your culture. This
is like a brand new thing and you just mock somebody else for
doing a similar level of switch up. Actually, probably way less
of a switch up than this. This is straight up embarrassing. You
are the person who was the intentional token minority to be demeaned
and denigrated for white supremacist the internet over for years.
And now you've come back and gone actually internet culture is
really s really really important to me and sorry internet culture
Indian culture rather Indian culture is really important to me
and when you guys mock it and when you guys mock it with gore
it's it's so crazy I can't even imagine it dude off
>> if she wanted to just stick on the gore thing okay she
just wanted to stick on the gore
I would get it okay I would get it but when she tries to go to
the cultural thing and pretend that that's like actually her
sacred cow. All right. It's just goofy, man. No, >> you
look goofy. >> Like I'm not doing it. I am not doing I
am not
sitting by anymore. I'm just not >> deleted the tweets
and backed off of it.
>> I didn't back No, I didn't back off. Maybe I deleted
the tweets. I don't know. But I don't remember doing that.
I changed my profile picture to a image of him that where he
is fully clothed
and the one picture I posted of him, he has a shirt on. I don't
know what the he's talking about. I don't know what website it
came from, but I do know that he did in the past. And for a guy
that wants to like
uh
go after everybody else and their moral failings, maybe you should
look inwards to yourself. >> Doing a moral failing or is
she talking >> Maybe you should look inwards to >> She
I can't tell who she's talking or
>> Yeah. Tell a lie about me. I'll tell a truth about you.
>> Oh, hold on. It was gay porn. Take it was gay porn.
>> Or wait, it was of him. Maybe not gay porn. I assume
it was gay porn.
Wait, I actually don't know that it was Gabe. I just said that.
I just said that because I assumed take end would go like, "Oh,
actually that's not a crime anymore. Sorry. Was trying to tap
into Missandry and I actually um I made something up that's not
even necessarily true." Is bad. Never mind. I thought I could
tap into Miss Andre there. >> Tell the truth about you.
>> But yes, she basically I think Sick was criticizing
her for something and she decided as a dunk she was going to
bring up the fact that he >> he didn't he didn't criticize.
He was lying about me. He was telling blatant lies about me.
happened when he was 10. Like he he literally was as a as a little
kid. He was abused and he >> you don't get to you I'm sorry.
You don't get to use your past as an excuse for being a person
today. You just don't
>> again just to the most
point. He wasn't saying I'm a bad person and you have to let
it go cuz I was. He didn't say that. What happened was he said,
"I think you took money to make your your Froggen video or some
shit." Okay. And you went, "Yeah, well, you your sister knowing
that he that that was a part of a whole thing where he was and
reenacted that same abuse on his sister before he was even remotely
near puberty." And you're trying to say what which your your
response to me making this criticism of you is, uh, actually,
you don't get to say because you were as a kid that you get to
be a person now. Nobody said that, you dumb [__]
Nobody at it. Holy
>> You just don't.
And also, where is this afforded to me with Anna when Moral was
talking about me? Where was >> I have no idea what this
is talking about, but moral is gone now, so I don't get it. Which
Anna? >> So, where was this uh consideration afforded to
me? No, I'm sorry. You don't get
to use your childhood forever.
You are a grown man now. >> You just weaponized it against
him. He didn't bring it up. You just weaponized it against him.
Bro, I
h
>> Why did you choose to get drunk and tell this story
like three different times? >> Don't volunteer.
>> Uh I think sometimes when people get drunk on stream,
they tell stories about like emotional trauma that does happen.
childhood abuse story
or get ready. Like it's it's the exact same. People use my [__]
against me all the time. They use my assault against me. They
use other like my dad against >> I don't know any of those
stories. You're bringing up a whole bunch of things while reacting
to me. And I'm saying, "Hey, really weird of you to weaponize
this guy's childhood trauma against him." And you're just going,
"People are mean to me."
Okay. I Does she understand how this works? that she should like
make criticisms of me
that like you're talking to me.
And by the way, if you want to say that everybody's mean and
you wash it all away, then don't go on a stream and build up
a PowerPoint so you can go in and try to character
substance who apologize to you
ruining Pesco's [__] panel because you're a dumb
[__] And then you you go, "Oh, well, uh, actually
everybody's mean."
>> What? I roll with the punches. I don't I don't like
I'll go, "Oh, oh, how could you use that against me?
If I put something out there and you >> Yeah, that's essentially
what we're watching here. It's a little mad at myself for putting
it out there." So, Sick got drunk on several occasions and put
his own out there
>> and also on top of it acted like he was like still mad
at his sister as if she has a choice in how she feels about that.
Uh, wait. I know the I don't think he was mad at his sister.
I think so. Again, Sick shouldn't have put this out on the internet
because it is like too much and people will always weaponize
it against him in the most disingenuous way, which sucks. Okay.
I endeavor not to do that. I would like to not be the person
who does that. Okay. But I happen to know that I I I'm pretty
sure the reason Sik talks about anger at his family or he talked
about anger at his family once was because he was a child when
he was abused. He was a child when he reenacted that abuse and
people in his family treat him like he's a monster who was an
adult who made a clear decision to harm a child.
But he wasn't. He was a child who had been abused who made a
decision to harm another who who harmed another child really
without the understanding of what was going on. And he is treated
like as an adult he is treated like a pariah by people in his
family which is understandable that that would cause some like
anger on your end that would cause problems on your end. Now
I don't think he should have told that story. I think but but
not because it's wrong to have had that happen. Not because he's
a worse person, but because of how people would weaponize it
against him on the internet, which sucks. Internet's especially
these spaces just not built for certain kinds of people who would
share stuff like that. It blows, man.
I'd like to never be the kind of person who uses that kind of
information. I don't know if I'm aware of like that kind of stuff
that I've used against someone like especially just kids stuff
that feels like way below the belt. Um,
but yeah, like it's it's understandable, dude. It's that somebody
would make fun of this guy for this. This is really up. >> Don't
put your out there and don't tell lies about me. >> Intern
did that abuse on somebody else
in his life as a child, pre-teen.
>> Boohoo. Oh,
what a disgusting god. I'm sorry. I am going to have to be I
might have to break the seals on the misogyny, the racism. Okay,
I just d she needs the energy of morale. Okay, she needs the
energy of morale here. Okay, hold on. Can I find the soundboard?
Uh, hold on. If she could if she could bring the morale energy,
maybe this would be acceptable. Hold on. Hold on. Where is it?
Where is it? Where is it?
Okay, but that's cuz it's deranged. I think Stardust explicitly
is trying to say that she doesn't want to be deranged. She wants
people to show her respect. Show my religion, my culture, my
whatever respect, right? She's trying to say, "Oh, you shouldn't
be deranged." And then she's like, "Uh, boohoo.
You got as a kid. Boohoo."
Which, by the way, he didn't bring it up. He was just like, "Oh,
you're lying about that to try to get a dunk on me."
She brought it up to get a dunk on him. >> You don't get
You don't get to you again. You don't You have to use your childhood
trauma forever as an excuse for yourself. You >> Yeah,
nobody's doing that. She is just a totally I'm sorry. I just
I don't have
I don't have the vocabulary to not be like misogynist here. I
need
I need something I need something else. I need a word. Can we
get some standard words? My vocabulary is failing me. Okay, I
keep I keep reaching for misogynist. Like
she's just empty. She's just like an empty vessel of a human
being. There's like nothing going on there. She completely failed
at streaming. She's completely failed at life. She doesn't make
any money from this. I don't know why she does this. I literally
don't understand why she does this. Why she does this to herself
and every Why do you do it to yourself would be question one.
Why do you subjugate everybody else to it?
Why? What? There's no incentive. You have no monetary incentive.
You don't make money. You just get mocked and derided the entire
time you do this. I watched your chat. The only person you had
in your chat, so you had two people in chat. You had Gilded Pooh
in your chat
and you had Kathy, kosher Kathy on a random account totally trolling
you. And I think you inside, deep down knew that he was trolling
you. You probably knew it was somebody who was making fun of
you, but you actually just kept them there. So you had the appearance
of any audience.
You would rather have somebody just trolling you, a single person
trolling you in your chat to give it the appearance of some activity
than to ban them and like actually just not stand for that kind
of humiliation. No, no, no, no, no. The account didn't just have
Zog in it, Portoeller. It didn't just have Zog in it. It was
Zog unboxed. She literally knows Spider. She knows Spider. She's
an editor for Lonerbox. She knows Spider runs the channel. Loner
She knows that it's obviously a troll account that hates her,
hates Lonerbox, hates all of these things. She's not that dumb.
And so, so she's literally talking to this person because she's
so she's so lonely. She's so unfunny. She's so unwatchable that
that's the best she can do. She can have a troll in there who's
like trying to get a rise out of her. It's just sad to watch,
man. >> And just don't don't volunteer it. >> Roughly
when it happened. Uh maybe um well, everyone kind of made fun
of him >> and don't and don't and don't live in don't live
in the past. You know, >> first when they didn't know the
story, but she um
but she went off. I think he he leaked something about uh Arrodite
or something. He leaked his DMs with Aridite or something and
she really didn't like that. >> It wasn't about Ardite.
I was I what I was doing. >> Wait, it was about Ardite
though. It started it was a it was a glam avatar. Yes, it started
as an airite thing.
>> Was wishing somebody well.
>> This this is also just obsiscating,
right? Because if he told the truth here, then it would make
sick look bad. I was wishing somebody well. >> Hold on.
I I actually don't know the truth here. Uh so if she says something
and it could be backed up, I'm totally down with whatever she
says. >> Froen. I'm giving my best my best recollection
of this covering it like I think a day or two later. >> Then
sick replied to me, "Didn't you do a a video paid for by Briana
Woo to slander Broen as an anti-semite?" I was not paid by Briana
Woo
to do my [__] video. I came up with that video. That
was my [__] >> I could have sworn this is downstream
of a conversation you guys were having about some air leaks.
Am I crazy?
Like maybe they started fighting at a different point, but I
could have sworn that there was an error a set of like sick was
leaking his aerodite messages that was connected somehow. Where
am I? Somebody explain to me where I'm like missing. I'm missing
something, but I don't know where it is. >> Baby, I did
think that Frogan was acting anti-Semitic. Yeah, but I I was
not paid for that video. Then if you're going to imply that like
I'm somehow funded by external sources
and I know that you're not going to face any repercussions for
just blatantly lying about me because none of you guys do. Yeah,
I will hit you back with the truth. Don't volunteer your
use against
>> So again,
sick didn't bring it up, right? And he's he's consistently talking
about it. So you were here you expressed how you're bitter towards
your sister and your family as an adult. Your sister can't help
her memories. Okay. Uh where's the rest of this? More was sick
Oh, this is definitely Dan like in this person's messages. Stardust
messages. Dan's pointed this connection out that uh Sadame is
like this person before. He's like pointed that out to me directly.
Dude,
it's uh I can't Dude, I swear to God, somebody explain to me
where the air thing is cuz I'm I'm almost positive that it's
like right before that and that was like what started their arguments.
And it's possible Sik went over and like cross talked into something
about her video. Possibly. Also, why is this original tweet deleted?
We have like an archive of this. Hold on. There's definitely
not going to be a web archive of this, is there? Somebody should
have archived it, but I don't think we're going to get lucky.
Dude, web archive takes forever to load, man.
Wait, 503. Oh, this dude.
Is this 503 because of web archive or is it 503 because of >> me?
You use my dad against me. You use my like assault against me.
Like I've had people in this community do it. Um people again
people use other people >> where where where
how does this justify anything?
If this is how you want to talk about it, if this is how you
want to put this, then obviously the sh did a pisco with regards
to substance is insane
>> against them all the time. Don't volunteer your if you're
not ready for people to use it against you, especially if you're
going to lie about me. What a lying little [__] too.
Jtock is such a lying little >> Hold on. But everyone kind
of made fun of him. I'm sure a lot of people did make fun of
him charging Jim, but those people wouldn't go and try to moral
frog on a stream about some gore post in their replies, would
they? >> Uh, yeah, they would because everybody Words are
words.
Uh, and you know, I did not consent to seeing that gore. >> Words
are words. Wait, isn't this just about how offended you would
be at any It's literally just your subjective opinion. What do
you mean words or
It's just what offends you more. And I'm going to say that probably
Sick being mocked for his childhood abuse is not like a words
or words situation. Probably has a lot of emotion that's there
as well, right? You're like, "Well, actually, it's just bad because
it's gore.
There's no way she could be this." Well, I keep saying there's
no way. Trader's here. Ain't no way this dog could sink a three-pointer.
And then Stardust just goes like swish. You think I can't be
that stupid? Oh, swish.
>> Amazing. Not
>> logic going to go, "Oh, they sent me They sent me a
cutup cow. A cut a picture of a cutup cow. They sent me a picture
of a cut." >> Well, it's not culturally significant for
him, is it? For for you guys, it's not culturally significant.
>> I forget what I'm even trying to cook right here. I
don't >> I'll be honest. This guy might say something.
I don't even remember what I'm trying to cook. beyond just culturally
significant.
I like I lived a good portion of my life as a vegetarian. Like
>> your culture of vegetarianism.
Wait, is this is that Wait, is that the point she's making that
it's like her deep culture of vegetarianism? Cuz obviously she's
not talking about her deep connection to her Indian past when
she is literally
when she was literally the pick me minority for the stream and
every white supremacist that existed online for years that sat
there while they denigrated and demeaned her repeatedly over
and over again. And then she goes, "Actually, I have a long history
of like a strong commitment to my Indian and and Hindu, you know,
cultural roots." No, you don't. No, you don't. Why are you just
lying? >> You know, what am I supposed to do?
>> Of course. Of course that. Of course you wouldn't feel
that way. Of course. Also, you're a man. You guys send sick to
each other all the time. Women don't do that to each other, >> bro.
This is like a very pathetic display. Like I Dude, I I have like
the worst barometer for how There's so many Yeah, I know. I know.
Hop on the stream straight, if you want. Um, dude, there's so
many I just don't get it.
Oh, but also I was going to say I have like such a high bar for
where I want to get into like arguments with people. Like I unless
I really want to analyze something or or try to be correct, I
don't even bother talking to other people or analyze it like
right and then she comes over here and she's like talking. She's
just saying the dumbest thing just bar she's going bar for bar
being a complete like just over and over again saying the dumbest.
>> No, of course. Of course that of course you wouldn't
feel that way. Of course. Also, you're a man. You guys send sick
[__] to each other all the time. Women don't do that
to each other. I don't go looking for
do not do not look at your significant other's close female friend
group chat. Okay. Do not do not do not wait. Hold on. I'm trying
not to be racist cuz she's doing this whole anti-Indian racism
thing. I'm holding it back a lot on the anti-ind I also feel
bad for anti-IND racism a lot of the time. Okay. But by all means
if you want to come on and you want to go toe-to-toe on this.
I'm I'm
>> you know I could get it done. >> Women don't go
through their live leak phase or whatever you guys do. You guys
are up in the head. >> I don't go what I didn't go through
a live leak phase. Off. I've never been somebody who just watches
gore. I think people who do that are weird and
>> I I' I've never No, I didn't go through a live leak
phase where I just watch people getting their heads cut off.
That ain't me, bro.
I did that. Uh, least shocking information of 2026 so far. Least
shocking information. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I Everybody knew that
already. Didn't even need to be said, but thank
>> You can't engage in the behavior she's engaged in.
Oh, also this stupid [__] is from like the sector
blood sports age
and she's >> "Yeah, and none of them sent me gore."
None of >> Does she not understand that that is like an
entirely subjective thing that like I'm sure some people would
rather be sent a picture of like a cutup cow,
than lots of words that could be said to them. Just entirely
subjective. It's that's it. That's all of it. That's everything.
A totally subjective standard. at me gore. I am from the blood
sports like
I have again withstood every type of abuse that there is. You
do not get
>> Oh, I might have hold on. I might have misread and I
remember the aerodyite thing happening around all this stuff.
Like I think that's why Stardust was mad at Sick in the first
place. Okay. But Sik did come back and say, sorry, Sik did say
something. one of her replies, "Didn't she make an entire video
framing her as an anti-semite in a video commissioned by Brianna
Woo? Now you're concerned about her well-being." This is about
Sardis virtue signaling on a frogen post. And then Sardis goes,
"Imagine making up lies about me when I can just tell the truth
about you. You assaulted your sister and you're so salty that
you were held accountable for it." Right? And again,
he was a 10-year-old abuse victim himself reenacting that abuse
on his younger
And that's how she decided to frame it.
And honestly, if she just because she comes from these communities
where people are fairly deranged, if she had just said something
along the lines of, "Oh, I didn't know that detail. That's my
bad." Then the whole thing like evaporates, right? But she doubled
down on why she should be able to do this, as she's doing now.
She's doubling down on this position of like, "Yeah, actually,
I I should get to say this about you. Yeah, I should I should
get to say this about you.
That seems worse than a dead cow image. No way. Cool. No way."
It's almost like the idea that a picture of gore would be worse
than words is entirely subjective. It has no bearing on on anyone's
evaluation of this. Just depends on the words, depends on the
If you just want to say that sending gore is like weird that
Yeah, sure. But it's an entirely different argument. I'd say
mocking someone for their childhood sex abuse is weird.
Come on.
Hold on. I have so many tabs open right now. This is not great.
to claim that you are aggressive >> and sit in the same
space as me
and then send me gore that is targeted based on my identity.
>> You do not. >> A cut up cow. Oh my god, it's so
bad. It's so crazy.
I'm doing this against my better
>> What? Okay. All right, dude. I can't get my um my Discord
to like ever work. I have like the custom avatar for you and
I can literally never get this thing to work. I'm gonna fix it
and then if anybody else joins it's all so on.
>> What's up? What's up? How's it going? >> Not much.
I have to be up and like to be up early tomorrow. This is our
mistake to do. >> Hey, hold on. Is this going to work?
>> Yeah, I think this works. Can you talk real quick?
>> Talking testing. One, two, three. >> Oh,
okay. >> I'm traumatized. I watched a video of a cow being
Is this a microaggression? Because aren't cows sacred in her
culture? Am I wrong about this? >> Yeah. Well, that's her
whole point is that it was targeted like culturally at
>> right. That is her that is a part of her whole point
is that it was like a racist attack, which I don't even deny.
And the guy, by the way, the guy apologizes for it. The guy wrote
a whole long tweet and like Pisco literally asks her at the end
of this. I'll just spoil it because it's probably going to take
us a while to get through it, but Pisco literally asks her at
the end. He's like, "Wait, what more did you want in that apology?"
>> Oh, wait. Something happened with Pisco.
>> Oh, this is all like this. Do you see the these people
here? This had to do with Pisco in that like Stardust came on
with a PowerPoint showing this the Substance Guys tweet. He was
like mad at her and replied with a dead cow after she said, "Oh,
I guess I hurt your
>> And she's arguing to Pisco. She went on Pisco's like
wick panel and argued to Pisco that she should time this guy
out for a week or sorry that Pisco should time this guy out for
a week from his
>> That's what she decided was a good use of her time as
an influencer. Could you
>> You think you think Hutch is bad focusing on Hassan
for hours a day. Imagine wasting your time with this >> influencer
is doing a lot of work there who is being influenced by Stardust
to do anything. >> Um
I don't I don't know. I don't even think she can influence anybody
to pay her more than a few bucks an hour.
>> Uh, no. >> And like, same same girl, same. Okay,
but like I barely started streaming. I feel like she's been at
it for like six >> Hold on. This is the start of it. Dear
Pisco, please presentation. Stardust. Dear Pisco, please presentation
January
Okay, first slide. Significance. The cow. Most people recognize
the cow as being sacred in Hinduism. But beyond that, the respect
for cows is a foundational pillar of Indian cultural identity.
This is part of our psyche.
She did this on a she went on a wick panel to publicly do this
this PowerPoint.
The cow pictures of Indians loving cows. They love cows. Are
you getting it? That Indians love cows. Do you understand? Do
you see?
Indians love cows. Do you see? Hold on. Next slide. Next slide.
next slide. And then it's what happened and she explains the
tweet and then uh hold on. >> Did Pisco really not crash
out before she got to the end of this? Because I feel like he
has very little patience uh sometimes in general and I can't
imagine him standing for these shenanigans for longer than like
three slides before being like get to the point. What is the
bit here? What's the joke? What's the argument or leave?
I think he's fairly sensitive to the idea that like people are
trying to weaponize, you know, unhinged community members against
him. And I think he probably let it go go on way longer than
it should have. >> He was respectful the whole time. He
he let it go. >> Anyway, that's what that's what we're
remember. But the best is hold on. The best part is okay targeted
harassment. Here's all the things it was. But this is the best
part of this in my opinion is Substance actually apologized that
night and it's like a well thoughtout like genuine apology
for being racist
>> and it's like oh didn't that didn't that solve it for
you?
>> It's in the apologized
>> or is it
is it
>> or is it okay?
>> Yeah. Anyway, sorry. We can go back to her commenting
over me. >> I mean, he's a faceless person on the internet,
so I'm not going to say it's like high stakes or anything like
that. But there's literally no reward in him even apologizing
because people just see it as unless they think it's part of
some extended bit, which it's not clear that it was because there's
literally no social benefit
uh to like coming out to Stardust and apologizing
over a
>> Yeah. Well, it's probably a little more than a microaggression.
I do believe that like I would give Stardust this little bit
that she he was probably aware that she's been on her anti-Indian
hate kick and he probably did something that was like intentionally
could be construed as Indian hate to with her. She was being
a bit >> What's her anti-Indian
hate kick? Is she getting off the internet? >> She's she's
spending
>> that would decrease the amount of Indian hate on the
internet if she left.
>> Yeah, I sorry. Thank you. I didn't get it the first
time. It was too subtle for me. Thank you for explaining your
joke. >> You're welcome. >> Yeah, she is not. She
just complains about getting >> someone in your chat saying
that Stardust is the Vak Brahma Swami of the uh witch bowl space
or whatever remains of it,
>> I guess. So, Vav, that's what Vive did. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you have a problem with
>> dude? At least >> I'm just confirming that's what's
being said in your chat.
It's kind of [__] up because Vive by all, you know,
all accounts is pretty good at getting people to give him money.
You'd think that would be a, you know, cultural stereotype that
would transfer over. You'd hope. >> I guess not. >> She's
fighting stereotypes.
She's so
>> This was h would happen. By the way, I told you one
of four things, right? One of four things. >> Is she like
>> does she have one of she like in momentum? One of four
things. She lost her memory. The people she used to hang out
with. Again, none of them none of
>> none of them sent me gore. >> As horrible as some
of them are, none of them sent me gore.
>> None of them sent me gore. And none of them I had no
illusions about what types of people they were.
So, yeah, they may have insulted me. They've been they may have
been horrible to me. They may have said horrible things to me,
but
I expected it from them. And even though I expected every abuse
in the world from
What just happened? How did my Hold on. My browser just went
out in OBS. What the How does that even happen?
>> I will not make cast system jokes. I will not make cast
system jokes. I'm going to write this on the chalkboard 100 times.
>> Brahman. Brahman. Brahman. Brahman. Brahman. Brahman.
Bra. Sorry. That's the only cast I know. I think is Brahman.
That's like the lowest cast, right? >> Is that the untouchables?
>> I think so. Yeah,
I think so. I don't know the other ones. >> I still didn't
get gore from that. >> No one does. No one bothers to know
the other ones. The only relevant one to people is untouchables.
And then I know that the the highest one is like priests or something.
>> Yeah, it's like they're all their nobility and too,
right? The highest
>> I think they have like essentially Yeah, I'm sorry.
That's implied in the fact that it's a cast system. >> A
progressive. A progressive who occupies the same space as me.
I was not expecting to be treated that horribly by somebody who
is supposedly a progressive, supposedly a feminist, supposedly
against racism. >> This isn't real. >> It doesn't
count. >> This isn't a real grievance. She's not even doing
a good job putting on a fake performance of like pearl clutching
over this while literally wearing plastic >> Yeah, I it
is.
I think it's pretty good. I I think this is about the most emotional
I've ever seen Stardust get. So, you know, it's it's approaching
believable. I don't think she's really capable of human emotion.
A lot of the time she seems almost entirely anhidonic. So, this
is getting close to something, you know, near human. >> She
seemed pretty in she was nodding along to uh Richard Spencer
in her 10,000th interview with him
>> when it's me, right? I'm not a woman. I am not a person
deserving of any of your considerations. Right, >> dude?
the the number of times she brings up I think Pisco does call
her on this. He's like I didn't really see how this was misogynist.
Dude, she does keep trying to bring up the fact that she's a
woman and like how this is she vaguely tries to tie it into like
um misogyny or being like anti-feminist or something is very
funny.
I am so bad and so inferior to you that when I call you out for
getting upset, you're getting your feelings hurt on Twitter,
you decide to send me gore that is targeted on my culture. >> And
you got your feelings hurt in response to that post on Twitter
and made a PowerPoint and then went on a stream and made it everybody
else's
Um the original tweet that she was upset about she um it's just
it's funny because the reason I bring up the stream thing is
the original tweet she's actually getting upset about is
she Cherry posted something about being Christian, right? And
it wasn't like attacking anybody and Stardust quote tweeted that
and mocked her and then Destiny retweeted her and then its uh
substance was like annoyed about it, right? And it's like
how can you mock somebody for because she said it was like a
crazy like character switch up or something. It's like how are
you mocking somebody for doing like a character pivot midlife
when
how can we interpret your cultural reverence for like Indian
and Hindu culture? How can we like possibly have any other view
that that's like a major pivot after all your with the stream
all of this right? Like it is a massive
>> How are you going to talk about somebody else's like
switch up? >> Yeah. I just don't get it.
So, it's just it's funny that the original thing she's calling
out is like what she's actually engaging in to try to do this
performative virtue signal she's going through. >> It's
the Richard Spencer to uh
what would you call it? Anti-antise
>> Wait, is Richard is Richard Spencer on the side of the
now? Or are you saying >> Oh, well, he was always like
he's always a Zionist. He has always been like he would go around
being like uh Israel was like his favorite argument because he
was like it worked out for the Jews. They have their ethnostate
like why can't we have ours?
>> Yeah, he's pro ethnostate. That's a little Yeah, I get
it though. >> Close to over the line. >> That doesn't
mean he's not an anti-semite, but he's not the type of anti-semite
that does the Zog memes if I remember correctly. I think he just
would use it to be like we can all have ethnostates like Israel.
>> Got to feel like that's tactical
>> more than >> really. I do think I've heard him
in
>> No way. >> Oh, hung up with her entire internet
>> and she could say, "Okay, well, I'm resetting or something
here."
>> But like, what? What the man?
>> She clearly has a reset. She did the sick thing.
>> No, the sick thing is just me echoing what you've done.
What' you do?
>> I don't know. She tried to get mad at like Cherry over
some Kelly Jean stuff and I think maybe she wanted to blame me
for that.
>> I I was very lost on this point earlier. She was like
trying to call me out for things and she has a hard time doing
that cuz I actually usually stay away from like
>> I usually I legitimately felt bad for this person.
I I I literally just felt like >> I thought you about to
say I stay away from drama. I was about to be like >> No.
No. It was like beating up a homeless person. It's like, dude,
they're already down on their luck. What more am I going to take
from them? Like >> You're more the type to just like if
somebody films the bum fight, you'll react to it, but you're
not going to be the one to incite it or film it
>> Yeah. Exactly. Exactly. I will profit from it. Okay.
I'm more like the guy who like gives somebody money cuz they
have like a business idea where they could go do it and I'm like,
"Okay, I'll I'll benefit from it >> for sure." >> Circle
Rad, thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it, man. >> I
mean, if you didn't do it, somebody else will. >> Ethan
Little.
>> Uh, is that that's vaguely the Coconut Island hypothetical,
right?
>> Is it not? >> The Coconut Island is is like to
demonstrate like wage slavery.
Well, I thought like coercive forces.
>> I thought the whole point was like if you don't monopolize
the coconuts. Okay, I'm drug dealer fallacy. I'm thinking the
drug dealer fallacy. Sorry. Different Bosch. Different Bosch
thing. >> Yeah, that like uh there's no like moral negative
to dealing drugs because somebody was going to deal the drugs.
Like it's a >> Oh, that's a stupid moral philos.
>> Uh yeah, I told her to stop spreading her. Have you
ever seen the movie Hustlers starring Jennifer Lopez?
>> Because there's a point where they're like drugging
a bunch of John's and ripping them off and one of them starts
to be like, "I don't know about this." And she's like, "If we
don't do it, somebody else will." And just like justifies the
whole thing using that line of logic.
So if Vos said that he's literally operating off the moral level
of a antagonist in a movie that most people don't remember.
>> Dude, I I was going to say, is this a movie you think
about a lot? >> I've never heard of this movie before.
>> Did you watch it recently? I've literally never heard
of this movie.
>> On noticed this. Listen, I don't
>> I don't know how to
>> Hold on. People love that movie. Women love that movie,
which is why it's not going to be insconed into the popular consciousness
because there's not enough men that like it as well. >> I
was just about to go on a rant that
>> women love this movies. I don't know how to explain
it to me, dude. Women love the movies and like fall in love with
this movies. I don't know if this movie
>> No. Name an example.
>> The Minecraft movie.
I know zero women who saw that and many men who did.
>> Wait, you know many men who saw the Minecraft movie,
>> Like who?
>> Why? What? What's the point of me naming them? You don't
know them. They're like I roll. >> The only person The
only person I know who saw the Minecraft movie and enjoyed it,
I believe, is Nick Fentes. That's like the only person I know
who's ever even talked about the Minecraft movie. >> It's
a good movie. You have people in your chat defending it right
now watching 4D. Kids like that movie. >> Okay.
All right.
All right. Fair enough.
Top of his lungs. I do remember. >> Yeah, he did that.
And again, those are just words. He didn't send me gore.
>> Oh, also hold on. We actually got the rest of the Stardust
tweet. So, hold on. >> Sick responding here. It was she
Stardust says to him at some point, "I'm not finding fault with
you for being a victim. I'm finding fault with you for being
angry that you were held accountable for victimizing someone
else." He says, "I've never denied what happened." Dude, this
is going to get heavy. People know what happened because I chose
to talk about it openly on three separate occasions. I've never
been against the separation. Uh, thank you for the raid, whoever's
raiding. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. >> Wait, really
quick. They had kids though, right? That's why they saw it. That's
the biggest cope in the world. There are just men in this world
that of their own free will and valition took the time out of
their day and the money out of their wallet and handed it to
a movie theater so they could see the Minecraft movie and they
could witness the chicken jockey scene. Come on. >> Okay,
I will say
>> I don't know about Minecraft. Okay, and maybe I'm dating
myself as like a total boomer here. >> I do know a lot
of guys who love the Lego movie >> like that. It's like
one of the best. Yes. But I think it's like generally genuinely
accepted as like a great movie. So I don't think we can use the
Lego movie as an example to be honest.
>> Why is it genuinely accepted as an awesome movie? >> Cuz
the men other men
>> I've never seen it.
>> Yeah. Okay. >> I've heard it's good. >> Not
a man.
>> Yeah, I've heard it's really good.
>> Oh boy. Um, I've never condoned my actions and never
had animosity towards the people who did the correct thing to
prevent further behaviors. My sole grievance was people in my
life continuing the stigma as if I was a perpetual vector for
harm for a thing that most abused children do grow out of. I
have only blocked people who choose to bring it up while conveniently
sidestepping the very real crimes like of like Destiny or something.
Stardust, I made one troll comment about NSE and you had a Twitter
meltdown over the course of a couple of hours. Oh, there you
go.
>> That was like >> I knew it was like the NYSE thing.
I knew it was connected. I knew I wasn't. Thank God. Made a comment
about the video you made not commissioned by Brianna Woo. And
you're weaponizing my trauma. My sister's trauma. Talking about
accountability as if it's ever been relevant to my character
23 years after the fact. Sincerely, you're a joke. The fact that
you think on principle uh think on principle or anything else
is a W is hilarious.
>> Okay. I can guarantee you what people are liking and
memeing about this situation. And it's the same people unwilling
to hold their very de about
>> I I get it. He was
>> I get where he's coming from with this.
I'm trying to avoid. >> How is it that Darius has outflanked
Stardust as far as being more sensitive to it? Because one time
>> sick came on to talk about claims that Dam had made
on Twitter or something like that, some panel that Darius was
>> And yeah, >> Darius got messaged or DM'd the drama
related to his sister and he was like, [snorts] "Uh, someone's
sending me this. I don't know if I want to bring it up, but like
uh and he starts like confronting him quote unquote on it, not
realizing that sick has literally addressed this I don't know
how many goddamn times and then was like oh if it's that then
yeah sorry never mind
like sorry
apologized for like trying to own him with it not realizing he
was like I didn't know I didn't know I wouldn't have if I had
known somebody else brought it up blah blah blah
>> yeah I even said that here it's like if Stardust had
just backed down and been like oh whoops I shouldn't have used
that at all then I'm I'm like okay if you didn't know and I understand
sometimes people bring it up and I've seen it be used to dunk
on sick and I think it's inappropriate to do but it like I've
seen it be used if you don't know you don't know but Stardust
knows and she's continuing to double down on it very strange
>> okay we have to get back to snarking we have to get
back to snarking
>> I'm ruining her stream making it boring not talking
about Stardust
>> uh yeah that's a sentence that's been constructed before
>> things are really boring can we get back to talking
about stardust. Things are Hey, this is really boring. You got
to get back to talking about stardust. >> I'm No, no, no,
no. That's not what I'm saying. That's not what I'm saying. I'm
saying that I'm making it boring because I constantly do this.
I come on your stream and we get off onto side tangents really
easily and it bothers people cuz they want the flop, the drama.
I know it stresses Ry out. >> Did somebody Did somebody
get mad about
>> I mean, Riyle might get annoyed about like some part
of this, but I No, it's fine. It's fine.
Oh, it's >> and and cow legs, right? Um,
>> I never complained about digression.
>> He doesn't. That's like the whole that was like the
whole purpose. >> Who's going to be the person? >> I
have receipts. Riyle, don't even
>> need this. Okay. The next time Pisco does Collins, we
need this. And don't put anything up in the in the presentation.
I need somebody to recreate this presentation with these Stardust
and Sick like tweets, okay? Because I think there's archives
of them out there. I'm pretty sure there's archives saved. Okay,
somebody needs to go and put that together and give
>> Don't act >> I mean, did I did I send sick gore
again? My my question stands. Did I send sick gore? Did I send
any
of his abuse?
>> I didn't send him a picture of a dead
I legitimately can't understand how she thinks that that's like
an out. Like, how do you think it's an out? That it's like, well,
at least it wasn't a dead body of an animal. That's the real
crime. Talking about him being raped as a kid, totally fine.
Sending him a picture of a dead animal's body. Unacceptable.
Truly should be gone for at least a week.
I don't know, man. I don't know. >> Did I send them violence?
Did I communicate or symbolize violence against them?
>> don't you think it's up that Stardust selfinserts as
the cow
>> then isn't okay then by this stand
I'm not addressing that I'm not touching that by this standard
Ethan Klein is not a victim right >> I mean by most standards
Ethan Klein is not a victim but go ahead >> true but even
by her weird narrow standard now literally almost no one is a
victim because the only type of harassment that's serious online
is when you're doing microaggressions against people's cultures.
>> Oh, wait. No, no, no. That totally fits in with the
Ethan Klein narrative because Ethan makes a mountain out of a
molehill and and literally says things like Hassan is worse than
Nick Fuentes. Yeah. Everything's anti-semitism. Hassan is worse
than Nick Fuentes cuz like Yeah, Candace Owens that they deny
the Holocaust. Yeah, whatever. That's like the easy type of anti-semitism
to dismiss. I I very vividly remember him saying this. You do
things like you you deny the Middle Eastern heritage of certain
Jews.
thinks that's worse than like Holocaust denial.
>> You may have actually stumbled upon how Stardust came
up with She might have gone, "Oh my god, that Ethan Tech where
he makes everything about anti-semitism." That's amazing. I'm
going to I'm going to make my whole identity about anti-Indian
hate online. >> Okay. What what she didn't factor in though
is nobody gives a about Indians, which is why you see a ton of
racism towards them online for one. And then for two, nobody
gives a about Stardust. So, it's not going to be like, and then
if if you're telling me that Sardis is getting hate on the basis
that she's Indian, not only will people not care about that,
they're going to find it funny. So, you probably shouldn't try
to make an identity out of that or carve out a niche for something
like that. >> Yeah. I don't think I could have >> Oh,
I find their culture so inferior that I'm going to send you something
that symbolizes a like violence against
a intense
>> intensely intensely important principle of yours.
Did I do that? Does Stardust have any principles, let alone important
ones?
>> I don't I literally
I I don't know.
Every principle she stated that like made this okay is like on
its face and she like you literally only have to go back maybe
six months tops to find a counter example. So no, I I can't think
of one. Maybe a principle against you know insulting Indians,
but I doubt it. I feel like you would definitely go through Stardust.
Dude, how far back do you have to go through Stardust to find
her insulting Indians? >> I feel like it can't be that
far back. I feel like she would have private proof of something.
>> Maybe. I feel like she absolutely would have done that
to show like I actually don't care. Racism doesn't bother me.
Racism doesn't matter. Look, I'll be racist against my own people.
I feel like that's something she would do. I'm I'm making it
up entirely, but hey,
I believe it. >> I mean, you want to talk about like Himleton?
Himleton uh insinuated I got like ripped by on my dad. Uh I >> I
don't know why we would talk about Himleton. I actually don't
understand why she knows who Himleton is. >> Why say stuff
like that? It just sounds like you got owned. It sounds funny.
Apparently it sounds like not only did she get owned, she's still
seething about it. Like it still occupies space in her mind.
It's Rob. >> Still see him running around in every community.
I'm not going after him. I'm not telling people to ban him.
People have used like I mean come on, you know, people people
have used my my my dad's death who just died by the way last
year or yeah literally a year ago
who I was estranged from against >> Doesn't that make it
weird to
>> go after a thing?
>> I Well, no. No, not even being estranged. It's just
like your dad died but I didn't talk to him. It's like okay.
Wait, what? Yeah, but you didn't know that.
>> Most people when their parents die, it's traumatic.
It's traumatic to become an orphan at 40 or whatever. >> Sardis
isn't 40. How old is she?
I'm guessing, if I had to put a number. >> But sick, his
thing from decades ago. Like um I mean I never you look I never
have used my dad as a defense for anything, right? Like when
people do that, they do it and I roll with it. So,
um I'm as >> actually I feel like you could get probably
more mad about people making fun of your dad being dead
than the cow thing. Like probably if people are just laughing
at you being like, "Ha, your dad's dead, you stupid." I feel
like you could probably get as mad or more mad about it. In fact,
I think most people
>> asking for one line.
one line that we don't cross and that is do not send me gore.
Like >> I can make fun of the death of my estranged father,
>> but I draw the line at sending me a photo of a dead
cow on Twitter.
>> Yep, that's where the line is. Which, by the way, did
we get an answer on this? Is this a real picture of a dead h
cow or is this a an AI generated image of a dead cow? I don't
think we figured that out yet.
I heard somebody say it was AI
>> Does it matter?
yeah, it does matter. You need to have respect for actual cows.
You don't have to have respect for AI generated cows. It's real.
I saw it at the time. Okay, well, never mind. >> Under
a pick of a hamburger.
>> Hold on. Somebody just sent me a tweet of her like using
a racial slur. She's clearly using it to make like a mockery
of somebody who's being racist to her. That wouldn't be a good
example of her like this. I'm like this wouldn't be a good example,
right? Do people actually watch the
Jesus? Yeah. For 30 minutes >> or people watch this? >> Just
say it. >> What's the point of being on this platform if
you can't say it?
Uh, actually they do sometimes get mad about it, but I've started
slipping in the fsler from time to time because it's uh awesome
and they're seeming to let it go now. So that's cool. Not in
a homophobic way, by the way. Just
>> say it's not my platform. I don't want to say it if
he's not saying it.
>> Uh, I said yes. People watch this
quote unquote joint. But this isn't her being racist to Indian
people. Obviously her like mind. >> No, it's her getting
owned. >> Racist to her. >> It's her getting owned.
Why would she say that?
Why would you quote tweet that? It would be like
>> you don't engage with stuff like that. Why give it attention?
Plus, you're linking in only fans in the reply. There's no reason
to try to like sympathy farm. >> She's severely or sorry,
she's she's severely jealous of Drew Pavlu. She wants to be like
the Indian female Drew Pavloo for anti-Indian hate. Okay. Who
just like constantly deals with getting owned? who constantly
farms getting owned in a way that
um in a way that she can like try to monetize and it's just like
dude you don't want to people like see DSP and they're like that's
the ideal that's who I want to be I don't get it people
you could make life choices that could lead you to be jealous
of Drew Pavloo
like it would be less embarrassing to say like I was addicted
to crystal meth and then went on a bender and I like killed somebody
then like I consciously was jealous of Drew Drew Pavlu.
>> Yeah. But like I honestly that's the kind of engagement
she does. Like this is she just seems very much like Drew to
me. Like that's how she engages is she just like she gets owned.
She >> The difference is that Drew Drew's like self humiliation
at least results in in and converts to some engagement for him.
>> It does. Well, it kind of does it for Stardust, too,
but she usually has to pander to like certain communities
to get it done. like she she very much um
she gets involved in a lot of like the dance stuff, the anti-
anti-semitism stuff, right? And like totally performing for that
community. I do think she gets some engagement. She also does
suck off Nicholas Dioro metaphorically
would quite be quite difficult in person. Um she does a metaphorically
>> not beating the stereotype accusations then cuz uh my
understanding is that Indians love Israel for some reason. >> Yeah,
true. They do love Israel. Did Sardos have any comment on that
era of shorts where it was just gore of random Indians getting
hit by trains?
I forgot about the Dude, we had that in chat. So, people made
that joke in chat so many times. Did you know that trains are
the natural predator of Indian people? No. No.
Not funny. This person literally challenged me in chat. They're
like, "You're not even being racist." I was like, "Why don't
you?" She's now >> you know, do >> neither of us
are actually racist.
>> Do not justify >> anti-racist and not racist people
have to say that.
>> just as a reminder to how to show people how not racist
we are.
sometimes comments get made. Okay. I'm not I'm very I'm like
not even just a little not racist. I'm really not racist. I'm
not anti-racist though.
>> Kind of racist. That would be weird.
I draw the line of anti-racism >> something. That is a
line that is too >> Sorry, it sounded like she was >> People,
all these people can like try and say like, uh, what I did to
sick was so horrible. Oh, you know, how could you weaponize this
trauma? Yeah, people weaponize my trauma all the time against
me. You don't see me crying about it. >> Who cry immediately?
>> This is No, nobody's talking about Stardust. There's
not a significant amount of people anywhere ever talking about
Stardust or making fun of like I I like I'm not even convinced
that like a significant amount of times
there are like people spending you know making fun of her even
milking her. >> I think
didn't she start I thought she started getting some engagement
on her tweets. Do you remember she fought with Lily Gatis? Do
you remember those tweets?
>> You see that? >> I remember Wick got a dunk on
Lily.
She fought with Lily Gatis and I think Lily Gatis kind of unfortunately
like totally owned her. But um
but she did get engagement on those. You know, people will flood
in. It's like, "Oh, there's a there's a there's a like white
supremacist attacking one of our one of our people." Even Stardust
is one of us when it comes to Lily Gatus. If we can get dunks
in on Lilatus, even Stardust is a human is generally how people
react to that. You know, >> Wick got 100,000 likes on a
tweet dunking on Lily. And I remember looking up his Social Blade
stats to see what a single viral tweet will get you. And he got
like 13 followers. He got like
>> You don't get followers out of basically people have
to go to your Twitter and see that it's like um they have to
see it's consistently like the thing they're looking for. They'll
like go to your profile and look. >> So to generate like
large amounts of follows, you have to be doing fairly similar
about fairly similar types of content I think most of the time.
Otherwise, they just go and they're like, "Oh, this isn't like
what they this person usually does and they don't
>> Oh, okay. So, you were reviewing a little bit of my
Tim Pool debate and the lawyer after he was asking for my for
my socials and he looked he was looking at my Twitter and my
pin tweet is a is a picture of myself and I put the caption this
one's for Jimmy for Jimmy Kimmel cuz he the whole thing with
him and ABC and all of [snorts] that and he looked at it he was
like who's Jimmy? like he was a [laughter] like he was a personal
like a personal [snorts] close friend of mine like oh you have
like a new crush or something like that.
>> Why is he asking me this in this way? >> Yeah.
I'm Dude I you told me that that he was um
interested. I was >> very complimentary towards me. We
make >> I just thought it was funny.
That's a great that's an amazing point Aaron. That's Aaron. That
is an incredible
I'm sorry. Just like he did it twice. I immediately was set off.
It was I was
>> lucky guy. This was >> everybody around him cried.
people have weaponized again. People have weaponized my assault
against me.
>> who cried? Not me. >> I no if they did that you
could be really mad about that. That would be fine. Actually,
people weaponize yours
to be >> I don't know >> substance substance on Twitter.
>> an anonymous person in her reply who did
>> I literally I Yeah, I don't know who she's talking about.
Um, I didn't even know I didn't even know that actually until
she brought it up here.
That wasn't, by the way, that's not the thing. I know. That's
not the thing. So, that's very weird. Yeah.
>> I get where you're coming from that nobody does this,
but I'm saying like even if they did, you could just be mad about
it. You could just be like, "Oh, that sucks."
>> Comparable. You You guys do this all the time where
you weaponize people's personal lives against them and act like
it didn't happen and then, god forbid, I hit back. God forbid
I hit back. Or
>> do you notice it's just like she can't explain who anyone
is in this? She's just like, "Hypothetically, somebody did this
to me so I can hit whoever."
Wait, what?
What?
I don't I don't get it, man. Why do I wake up at 9:00 a.m. to
see you streaming about Stardust? Oh, I don't know. She was like
mad about I mocked her for this whole thing she did with >> or
just straight up lie about >> I I think what I did is I
accidentally made way too much uh content for myself here. I
said she wasn't going to go and like meaningfully respond to
anything I said. And it turns out that that was correct. She's
poorly responding with no thought to what I said.
But I think she eventually she was she was like watching and
she decided to go back and watch from the beginning. So now >> she
doesn't care about this.
>> You gave her the biggest gift of the night which is
something for her to do on stream for multiple hours that's mindless
and easy. >> Yeah, I suppose.
But unfortunately when I did cover this originally I think I
had like 540 viewers. So, like I unfortunately people do like
watching like and that's the thing you you say people don't like.
Dude, people love watching Stardust get like mocked.
They do. The people do love watching Stardust get dunked on.
>> It's the same people though. It's the same like there
are people in your viewership. They're just watching because
they would watch you cover whatever cuz they're regular viewers
of yours. There's probably about maybe one like high-end 150
people that are like tuning in specifically for the Stardust
drama, but those same people are are going around doing it.
>> I had like I had like 400 viewers and then Queen raided
and those people of course were going to stick around to
[laughter] So they were people who had a naturally like they
were naturally inclined to stick around and be like, "Oh yeah,
[__] Stardust. [__] this stupid [__]
>> Get away with it anymore. Of course I was going to hit
hard on sick. >> It's high. >> Don't actually do
it. I'm joking. That's a joke. That's a joke. That's a joke.
Don't actually do it. It's incredibly >> I really do think
that those people that stuck around from the Queenman raid still
again would have watch would have stuck around for the majority
of your
>> Uh probably. >> It's not like if I don't see Stardust,
I'm clicking off.
>> Yeah. No, it's you need certain kinds of content with
Stardust out there for people to stay. Okay, we got a whole bunch
of people imitating the lawyer in the chat right now. >> Dude,
the Kathy PowerPoint would go hard though. We could do that as
a Hold on. We could do that as a >> You have my swag somewhere.
Okay, we could do that as a skit or something. Actually, what
he said is totally >> I'll explain this further. Why? This
is targeted harassment. Okay, it is it is discriminatory selection,
right? He this wasn't a random He didn't pick this out of nowhere.
It would be one thing if he sent me gore by itself and it wasn't
targeted. We would still find that gross, but it wouldn't be
this level. Um, this wasn't like a random edgy meme he had laying
around. He knew my
He specifically sought out a mutilated cow or he had one. >> Oh,
this guy's really mad. Oh man, I would think about inviting him
on stream. This Galuki guy, he's really upset. I just noticed
I didn't think he was Why is he so mad? Are you good, buddy?
Are you good? Do you want to come on stream? You want to come
talk? >> And he sent it direct. He said he quoted quote
tweeted me because he knew I was Indian, right? That's all he
knew. Um,
>> no, that's not why he quote tweeted you.
In fact, showed why he was quote tweeting like he >> Oh
my god, you stupid.
Oh my god, I'm talking about the justification for him sending
me gore, you idiot. Of course, he's quote tweeting me for the
previous thing with Cherry. Uh, he's also his justification is
that you're a dumb [__] That's why he's sending you
the the gore as well. >> His his selection of how he was
going to upset you was discriminatory,
but none of the other stuff is. All the other stuff, him him
deciding that you suck, him deciding that he wants to with you,
right? That's all just to do with you and your personality. >> [__]
Maybe you are. Oh my god.
>> he It wasn't discriminatory selection. This is actually
just wrong. This is obviously
wrong.
Uh, now the gaslighting begins, guys. Oh, it's not discriminatory.
He just found a random cow star. It wasn't anything to do with
your background.
>> Don't think anyone made that argument. It's a weird
reach out of straw man. >> No, but even the selection wasn't
discriminatory. The selection was
>> you're being like a total to Cherry. That was the selection.
>> Oh, that was selected you. He actually got mad about
the the other previous tweet. discriminatory selection as in
>> I think I clear this up because I think she was referencing
this. Um I don't know if it was super clear, but I >> This
guy is actually Oh my god, I can't believe he has a whole group
of people.
They're getting their >> They are getting their
>> She did a really poor job of presenting this and then
she's going to blame me, but that's fine cuz I get correct >> A
[__] It's discriminally selected a cow based off
of my background.
>> Yeah, we totally admit this before any of this clarification.
>> I can't believe I have to explain this. >> She's
She's literally checked out. What fantastic content. Yeah, I
don't know if you know this, but her just being here with her
camera on is helpful to me. And I'm totally fine carrying the
content. Nobody understands that I am totally like I sit here
I s I sat here for a year and a half, two years with people who
just randomly check out. That was like the point of the stream.
They could come hang out and they could check out if they want.
>> Wait, they're talking about me? I thought they were
talking about
>> No, that guy was talking about you. But that guy's been
mad at you for a while. He was very angry. From the time he started
talking about the Hobbit movies, he was upset.
>> Oh, did I insult your favorite movie?
>> I don't know. I don't know if it was about the Hobbit
movies. He was just very mad the whole time. I have >> if
I saw anybody in his chat
who was
like making light of the blatant racism
that like and the how up it is to send somebody gore.
Uh like you are no longer welcome in my community. Okay. Not
that I ever wanted. >> Dude, is not in a position to be
turning anybody away from her community.
>> Well, I I I went on a whole rant before this. Oh, wait.
you were here cuz I well I redid it maybe but it's just like
she literally sat there with somebody who's an obvious clear
troll who's using like a mocking name that is clearly making
fun of her employer and Spider at the same time >> and
Spider's like an editor in that community if you don't know who
that is. And uh yeah, she's sitting there like conversing back
and forth with this
>> She literally picked somebody from who would have be
in my community, right? or part of communities I'm adjacent to
at least and was conversing with them like openly. We literally
know, we've literally seen tonight that this isn't true. It's
obvious >> place, but I recognize some of the names there
and I am not down with you. We are no, we are not okay. I will
ban you on
>> Right. That was the selection.
>> Oh, by the way, I haven't talked down the discrimination.
I literally say that's what it is. >> Did weaponize the
culture of the image >> in a dehumanizing way?
Yes, that is what it is. Discriminatory selection. You
>> He discriminatorily
selected the cow because of my background. >> What was
that defense for? >> Sorry, I >> did you just say
that? To be clear, I never downplayed the discrimination that
Stardust faced on Twitter.
>> why are you setting the record straight on that?
>> Stop. I'm I'm saying that I say later. Wait, cuz she's
wrong. That's why. What do you mean why you saying >> there's
so many things that she's wrong about? But to be like uh to be
clear, I would never downplay the discrimination that a POC faced
on Twitter, especially not an Indian. Like it's just funny to
>> Do you think Do you think that's what I was going for?
Come on, man. I was saying that I'm about to say that. >> I
don't know why you're saying it. >> No one in this community
thinks that you're downplaying discrimination. And Stardust doesn't
even think that. She's
>> Sure. I'm not worried about her plight. I'm saying that
this guy definitely was trying to be racist to her. That's all.
I'm not trying to deny the first not I didn't offend him on the
basis of his god. Um uh it was just because I said that I hurt
his feelings. I called him
>> No, the first the reason he didn't like you, the reason
he was annoyed with you. >> The instigating
the thing that he is replying to Jtock is me saying that he is
being sensitive that I hurt
Is that why he's mad at you though? You're just >> his
sensitive feelings. >> That is what I'm saying here. We've
already explained the context of these tweets. You're just going
now obiscating
>> Want to watch some of the stardust?
>> Let's go.
>> We've already explained the context behind this.
This guy is actually Oh my god. Oh, she gets really mad because
she's talking about discriminatory selection. And I for a second
think she means discriminatory selection of her to for the response,
but she means it for like selecting the image.
But I clear up that >> brain dead. >> Did he Did
like I don't even know what to say >> because of your tweet,
the original >> The original tweet. But he didn't send
the gore to the original tweet. He sent the gore to me saying
that he was
Now she's saying that he was upset that Stardust went uh Oh,
you got your feelings hurt. >> I hurt his feelings. >> Very
good. Very cool. I'm not the person who can virtue signal about
that. Okay. Cuz I obviously am going to get
annoyed. So I I'll leave that to somebody else who can lay that
out for her why the first tweet was offensive.
But he was offended by that tweet. Not by you saying, "Haha,
your feelings are hurt." You were making light of the
We got Chud or Pisco.
Uh, I might take If I could get odds, I'd take Chud.
I think Chud's going to try to do the thing. He's going to try
his best Nicholas Dioro perception or sorry, impression. I don't
know why I said perception. He's going to do his best Nicholas
Dioro impression and try to just go uh like normal people don't
think that way. Normal people don't think that way. I think it
could work if he like ref. >> I don't think Chard's going
to do that. I think Chard's going to try. I think he's going
to try give it a real try.
>> I think he's going to give it a real try. And again,
he's going to get he's going to hit with a a wall.
He's going all legal.
Um well, hold on. Cuz he did something else with me that I'm
now just remembering where I'm like, wait, somebody determines
who who where's the determination made of like what a reasonable
person would do or like where where does that h happen? He's
like, well, they make their arguments. And I'm like, yeah, but
who decides which argument wins? And he wouldn't say he didn't
want to say it's the jury, but it is the jury. Like a jury of
your peers decides.
So it does come down to even in a legal sense that a little bit,
right?
>> Yeah. Obviously, >> like but the case.
>> Yeah. But it's like Yeah. This just it's like about
who can argue reasonability best. And I I don't know. So, it
will come down to some element of like, no, well, normal people
don't think that way, I think, but we'll see. And his response
to it, >> his response, he didn't respond to the first
tweet. >> I'm speeding this up a little bit. >> He
responded to me saying, "I hurt your sensitive feelings."
>> He did respond and he sent whatever. >> That is
not acceptable in any shape or form. I think this is again, this
is justifying the action. >> Wait, if Lab's still here,
she should come watch Stardust. saying, "Oh, he was a little
bit out of line, but it was it was kind of justified." It's basically
what JTO is saying here. Sending violence to me, I don't count
using violence to intimidate me or scare me or shock me. That
is that's totally
>> virtue signals the whole time. I actually explicitly
say multiple times it's not justified.
>> Do we do we really have to >> How is it not justified?
>> how's it not justified? Uh,
>> decision to make. Well, yeah, but that's not an actual
just that's not about the justification, is it? Let's be serious.
That's like a cop out.
>> No, it's not. >> No, it is. [clears throat] >> No,
it's not. >> That's a total copout. >> Talk about
why it's morally justified
or >> Yeah, but it's it's like, you know, you're just saying
it's a bad idea.
>> Um, I I do try to disconnect it from the gore. [clears throat]
I think like generally just being like super racist to people
in replies on Twitter is probably not like a good thing to do.
morally wrong morally wrong to just be like openly racist to
people when you're calling them like a or especially if you're
calling them out for being inconsiderate or like bad themselves.
>> I think uh that's fine. But she pressed she said,
"Oh, you mean don't hurt your feelings." So if you want to play
hard, then play hard.
>> Yeah. Well, after her doubling down on the sick thing
and then saying how much gore, especially gore involving beef,
like upsets her, I'm sure that's going to work out great. I'm
sure this is a really good decision overall.
>> Yeah. By the way, don't
sending her anything. If you're just like randomly, you know,
harassing people with gore, like sure, yeah, there's a separate
thing happening there that's bad, >> but when you're having
like >> when you're already talking
that you're basically saying like you're a sensitive clear, exactly
your behavior is clear. Everyone knows who you are and how you
engage on social media
and you you're challenging. You're sitting there going, "Oh,
do I hurt your feelings?"
>> Yeah, [__] Is that coward's head cut off?
How do you feel about that? Yeah, I can see why it happened.
I don't know if that's like justified. I don't think like I I
have a if I have a principle that I'm like generally think like
open racism is bad. Like open like avowed racism is bad that
I don't know if violating that principle is necessarily like
called for. >> Open avowed racism. But was that open avowed
racism? It was it was a racist comment. Sure. But we're saying
it was open avowed racism. I think substant literally just I'm
now going to try to denigrate you based on your race or
No, I don't think that's inherently wrong. I don't think that's
gay.
>> Uh, I think it's only gay if you wouldn't do that to
somebody otherwise. Like if you think it's like against your
principles to do. >> I just don't really I don't see after
intrinsic characteristics thing is particularly different to
going after anything else to be honest. >> Sure. I don't
think it's like it's basically like substances apology says at
all. Right. It's like I I violated like my one of my own principles
and that's like what he says like the bad thing. He doesn't say
like you don't deserve to be denigrated. He's like I don't you
deserve to feel bad, right? But I the way I went about it was
incorrect. I think there's a good apology. Like like if you're
going to actually give an apology, it was an apology that made
sense. And she whed to Pisco about why like the apology didn't
actually apologize to her and it's like no, he doesn't apologize
to you. Like you it's still you but the way he did it was a way
that he doesn't agree with
>> Yeah. Who cares who got intrinsic characteristics? I
I don't understand why there's like this.
Oh, you can go off people being fat. You can go off people being
stupid. You go off people being poor.
But don't don't ever ever say anything about someone being Indian.
Why?
I genuinely find racism funny, so it's hard. But it's like if
you are in a fight with somebody and you wouldn't normally be
racist and then you you go to racism because you just want to
upset them. Maybe in this case I could see like an exception
for like she's explicitly going, "Well, you can't you you're
really sensitive, you little bitch." I could maybe see an exception
here, but usually not.
Either either case, I'm probably not going to like straight up
say it's good. >> Um,
Spider asks, "Did did Sick nuke his account because of the Stardust
interaction or no?" I mean, I don't know for sure. I'm pretty
sure he was just scared that Dan was going to dox him.
>> It was because of the Stardust stuff. That's what I
thought.
Oh, I thought I thought he was pretty worried that um he was
going to get
If you notice, um
like they're tying the the name of
the Saddami person, the former name they used back to them.
>> I'm pretty confident that's Dan as well. So, like I
I think there was a lot of reasons he was concerned there. But
what was what involvement does Dan have in any of this? Um, I
think sick is somebody who's going after people like um who weren't
sufficiently critical of Destiny
and that happened to have overlap with Dan. I don't think Dan
was necessarily like defending Destiny, but I think it was he
>> The involvement Dan has in this is that there is absolutely
zero chance Stardust was using pim eyes on her own. That's that's
the involvement Dan has with this. Yeah.
>> Um Oh, I suppose you could say that, too. Yeah. Uh,
like I I just know for a fact that because um because Stardust
know knew who the Sadame person was down here.
Um, this right here,
I know this is something that Dan mentions explicitly.
I I don't know if that's like true, if this is their former username
or something, but I do know that Dan says that.
So, I'm assuming she was talking to Dan about this. >> Wow.
Anyway, she >> tried to she tried to dox. Yeah, that's
what Stalus does. No, >> Stalus. Or >> she did. Oh,
maybe. I mean, it's an old username. I guess you could say that's
a kind of doxing like a personally >> That's doxing. Username
is a PII. That's non-lin PII that could lead back to a
of menacing.
>> Um, yeah. I think what would the argument there be?
that this person is directly harassing them, so it's valid to
do so.
Maybe >> I guess that's what they would argue.
>> Something like that. The Dame said they got the link
wrong. Yeah, I don't particularly care. And I that was the other
thing is I said this to Dan when he mentioned when he said it
was that person. I was like, "Oh, well actually the things you
know about that guy. Like I I saw him in chat a long time ago.
I don't think that's the same guy that that person used to be
in my chat and they were like a big Mr. Girl fan. A lot of their
old posts don't make any sense with that, but whatever. So, this
moves from internet beef to being like a calculated targeted
thing against my identity. Um, if he had sent this to anyone
else, um, it would just be gross, right? Because, um, if they
didn't have my background, it would just be gross
>> by the way, I'm not going to defend that. I truly believe
that basically these substance was probably aware that you've
been complaining about anti-Indian discrimination because you
complained about it a lot. And
>> do I really complain about it? I feel like I don't.
I [laughter] feel like I pointed it out. >> Is this Sorry.
>> What? Bro, what? Bro, what? >> Very stupid question.
Very stupid question for me. >> Is that like her whole
identity for the past like two months? Is she basically on like
a rebrand of like I'm an anti anti-Indian hate person now? >> Yeah.
She's done like a video.
>> Indian Indian hate online or some [__] >> Wow.
But like I don't um I don't complain about it when it comes to
me. when it comes to me and I've like entered the fray, right?
I've entered the frey and I've like provoked somebody. I know
what I'm getting. I know what I'm getting. >> Clearly not.
>> Dude, what?
Uh, okay. All right.
>> Um, but like when I'm talking about
>> Spider, why don't you call into the show? Why don't
you come hang out, ask your questions via voice.
We'd really love to just hang out with you for a little bit.
>> We just You're invited inside the house. Come on in.
>> I I was thinking maybe we could get a queen an apology,
okay, for reading a chat message that you then said was him directly
saying this thing about you. I I think we get a queen an apology
for that. You know, >> apology for what? Wait, apology
for
>> Didn't you call him some sort of um weren't you implying
he's something of like an Uncle Tom?
>> Well, that's why these lines. >> I I just did
it again.
>> You did just do it again. It's kind of a fall to be
honest with you. Also, Spider, are you like uh can I can we get
confirmation of this? Are you black or are you Hispanic
or both? >> I got to clip some stuff. Working for free.
Working for free for loner box. >> Mama said there'd be
days like this. There'd be days like this. Mama said
>> not Indian. Wait, I didn't say Indian. I said Hispanic.
I thought you were Hispanic. Screaming guy's racist.
Not some racist type [__]
[laughter] >> [__] this type [__]
>> I'm black, NOT INDIAN. NOBODY THOUGHT YOU WERE INDIAN.
>> Where are you? Where are you getting [laughter] Indian
from? >> I didn't realize black people like furball. I
thought I was only Hispanics.
>> This guy This guy's just making it clear for no reason.
Listen, Stardust Spider's in here and nobody's ever accused him
of being Indian. And he's clarified multiple times he's not Indian.
I'm not reeducating this guy. Okay. I might need some re-education
over here >> outside of the space that I'm in. People who
are not involved in this online sphere who are seeing it on social
media, seeing it on Instagram, seeing it on Twitter, and they're
not tuned into my algorithm. That's where I have an issue.
But I have never complained about
you know, I like I just feel like yes, there's an issue with
it. There's a there like clearly botted on these social media
sites. There are whole influencers who make
>> I really don't hate b saying politics is botted. It's
like no >> there is something deeper. >> There might
be some massaging on the on the edges of specific you know specific
talking points or specific people at different times but it's
the broad
of fake. No,
no. People have just quite a negative,
>> bigoted view of Indians generally on the
>> it is that way unfortunately >> ecosystem an economy
um based off of it. But how is that how is that justifying anything
here
and in fact it doesn't it doesn't make substance argument like
you're not defending substance here JTO you're saying oh substance
knew that you were uh talking about this issue. Wait, it is a
defense. It's saying downstream of you being a he was like, "Well,
how can I upset this?" And then he was like, "Oh, she's mad about
anti. She's mad about Indian hate." Well, here's a little
beheaded cow. There you go.
It's basically saying that this person is not inherently racist.
They were like, "Oh, racism offends this person."
Doing a 24-hour stream. No, but like I probably was going to
be up late anyway. I said yesterday I stayed up late watching
Chad. I'm probably going to end up doing something like that
again today, unfortunately. We we'll see. I don't know if there's
going to be a stream tonight. We might have to take a night off
and try to put to sleep. >> So that's why he chose it.
Doesn't that make him a little bit more psychotic actually? So
you knew that it was it would it would absolutely hit home with
>> Why did you bring up childhood sex abuse? So right it's
like I'm sorry. It's like yeah, here's the worst thing I know
about you. I don't know if she's noticed this. That's how a lot
of people are online. Here's the worst thing I know about you.
I'm going to say it now. >> It wasn't just meant to to
scare me and shock me. was meant to deeply wound me from a cultural
standpoint. So it doesn't make him look better what you're
>> So this moves from internet beef to being like a calculated
targeted thing >> somebody somebody has to define me her
making this point about how like cultural insults or race-based
insults were deeply upsetting to her with from her time on the
stream. Okay. When Ethan Ralph would just go off on her with
every single anti-Indian pjorative that exists, was she like
deeply hurt by that or the answer is no. By the way, >> spread
your nasty
flaps on the internet.
>> You want to get dirty with me? Let's get nasty. Let's
get dirty.
>> Uh she basically I she responds to me making that point
at some other point here and she goes, "No, no, no. That's not
a picture of Gore." It's like, okay, >> it's my identity.
um if he had sent this to anyone else, um it would just be gross,
right? Because um if they didn't have my background, it would
just be gross because,
>> by the way, I'm not going to defend >> Okay, so
listen here again. He's he's uh he's just basically admitting
it here. Like, oh, so it's not just that he found it based off
of your identity. Like he knew that you were like looking into
this specific issue and talking about it, so he looked even further
and decided to send it to you. You look like a psycho. This does
not make the argument you think it does. This is not a defense.
It makes him look worse. >> I truly believe that basically
these pe substance was probably aware that you've been complaining
about anti-Indian
Uh I don't I really get on the stream, Spider. We're going to
be friends by the end of today. Okay. I really don't get Stardust
behavior here. If she actually wants the interactions to stop,
why not just block him? Block them. Letting it keep going just
makes it feel like she wants the back and forth to continue on
the same level or on some level. Sorry. Yeah, probably. Yeah,
she she didn't block substance. I don't know why she went on
and did this. She's just looking for any engagement she could
get. She only knows how to rage bait.
Unfortunately for Stardust, she's in the DSP situation where
the rage baiting of her generates like
100 times the views. Like, sorry, sorry. The rage baiting she's
engages in
generates 100 times the view of views of people just mocking
her. Like basically people will show up and watch someone mocking
her >> at 100 times the rate that they'll show up to watch
her stream.
>> So like she wants to rage bait to grow her platform.
>> Um but it is never going to happen. It can't happen.
She's like Pearl. Uh actually an incredibly apt comparison. Yes.
Uh far less successful version.
Pearl's probably just entirely bought it. But >> yeah,
Pearl got a hand to
Yeah, I hate Stardust. Yeah. Isn't Pal like literally a rich
kid? Got it all handed to her and >> Yeah, I think she's
mostly bought an engagement and she sort of popped off for a
second and then people started >> Even when she popped
off, didn't she have like a channel manager and she was like
there were people basically running it for her >> almost
certainly. Yeah. I think she she had manager. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Definitely >> played about it a lot >> and
I don't think I complain about it that much, but okay. >> Probably
aware that he thinks you're a disgusting vile like imu inhuman.
You put those two things together and he's going to go, "Oh,
what's the thing you're [__] about?" "Oh, anti-Indian
racism. Let me cook up a little anti-indian racism. Here you
go."
>> Okay, that totally sounds [laughter] completely
That sounds so sane. That's such a welladjusted thing to do for
a human being. Oh my god, substance is such a welladjusted thing.
>> It's like the craziest virtue signal when she's done
so much disgusting herself. I just like how do you
say this? How do you do this with a straight
>> And but she'll like actually say this. She's like, "Actually,
people are crazy to me and I've been crazy to it's like, yeah,
that's the whole point is like this whole PowerPoint is crazy.
This bring this up, right?" >> Like, none of us none of
us are that upset that you said some mean.
>> Like, it's just you. >> Like, I literally cannot
remember. I'm sure that it's happened. I cannot remember a single
mean thing Stardust has said about me. I could not if I sat here
and racked my brain for the next 10 minutes, I don't think I
could recall a single
one of the actual things she said. if you know what I mean.
>> yeah, sure. >> You should probably you probably
just get past this. It's probably just like one Twitter interaction.
You should
>> use her and move on. >> Yeah, you missed earlier
where she started listing off like all the people who have said
mean things about her or done mean things. She brought up uh
for some reason Cherry like mocking Kelly Jean's medical condition
or something. I don't think she understands that story. Um what
else? Oh, she started bringing up that Hamilton was mean to her
and I'm like how the do you even know who Hamilton is? No way
you got bullied by Himleton. There ain't no There ain't no way
you got bullied by Hamilton.
>> And it's like in her head like when she complains about
these things and says that they're bothering her like it's just
it's obvious that people are in her head. It's very str it's
just strange >> Oh my god. >> I fully believe he
did that 100%.
>> It's you know separate cow headow
added >> that you're saying the selection of the cow was
deliberate based on your >> So you're saying it was deliberate
Jtock? You're saying it was deliberate. You're not You're not
disputing it. You're saying, "Oh, well, it's not really discriminatory
selection." Because he knew you were talking about this, though
he selected it and he said, "Let me cook up a little anti-Indian
racism and here you go." Like, that sounds selective. It is.
>> Yeah. I was saying she he wasn't discriminatory in selecting
the target. >> sounds like discriminatory selection to
me, buddy. You knew it is discriminatory. You just You're Oh
my god. I cannot believe. Does this guy like have a >> I
think she did a really poor job of explaining what she meant
by discriminatory selection, but because if if it's just about
the uh image, if it's just about the image, then discriminatory
selection. >> Wait, I thought discriminatory selection
is saying to to me,
she's saying he targeted me because I'm Indian, but he didn't.
That's not what happened.
>> Yeah, that's what I thought. But she's now arguing that
the image was selected in a discriminatory fashion. But then
I don't know how you separate cultural weaponization against
discriminatory
>> Yeah, that's
like no no one would interpret that phrase that way. And it's
weird to use that phrase.
>> Yeah, I think Yeah. >> learning disability or
something. No offense to learning disability uh people, but like
this guy's got to have a severe one, right? Yes. Yes.
>> No offense to But this guy's
turn. It's cultural weaponization. He took a symbol of peace,
right? Um a cultural taboo basically. Um >> it'd be like
a >> She doesn't enjoy streaming. Why? Why doesn't she
quit?
>> Oh, I went uh I I hope Substance clip that if he was
watching earlier, I just went on a whole thing where it's like,
why are you inflicting this on us? Why are you inflicting it
on yourself? Like, you suck at this. You don't make money from
this. What is the purpose? Like, >> you will never make
money from this. You have never made money from this. This will
never go anywhere.
>> You're kept around only like this is the thing you need,
people need to, you know, realize >> Nick Dorio keeps you
around cuz you'll never be a threat
and that should tell you everything you need to know, >> dude.
And I mean also the free labor from that she gives to all of
these people like that is if you have to just help people if
you have to do free labor for them for them to pay any attention
to you or care about you at all like that is just letting you
know like just go do actual labor for somebody who will pay you
for that labor. Like you're you're never going to be able to
trade you editing for people, you giving research to people,
you being nice to people. You're never going to be able to trade
that in to be entertaining. It'll never h it can't happen. don't
work like that. Picture of a cross on fire, right?
>> Well, I think it's a little bit worse than that because
it's gore.
>> right. It's just gore, right? Uh but um uh basically
I think he he you know it's like you're sending what isn't my
brother has a learning disability. This guy's just [__]
stupid on a Stardust binge. [laughter] Hello, how's it going?
An image of peace to somebody but desecrate.
>> You know what Stardust needed to do? Sus needs to plug
into Hindu Twitter and she should have just retweeted substance
tweeted her with like adding some anti-Hindu hate account. Dude,
you get that guy plugged into Hindu Twitter. Holy [__]
Substance going to be right. >> I mean I could have I could
have but I didn't I could have I >> That would have been
awesome dude. We would have gotten awesome tweets at Substance
to laugh about that would have been so good. >> Stardust
you could still do that. Actually, nobody will be mad at you.
>> No curse on your timeline right now.
vigilant Hindu Twitter accounts that don't like that kind of
stuff. I could have done that. >> Wait, doesn't Hindu Twitter
mock stardust? Wait, do they really?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think so. >> Dude, it is crazy that
she's trying to do the sacred cow thing and she's not >> The
Hindus I think she's complained about this before is the Hindus
hate she's like a Muslim Indian or something, >> Okay,
maybe. >> So, I think the Hindus hate her because of that.
She like complains about how >> that's interesting. >> You
know, even even Indians are racist >> Oh, well that's cool.
I didn't know any
and she really is. She's got a she got a rough. Okay. A tough
she got a tough hand. She got a tough head and dealt to her.
Okay. >> Being a sub three woman is that is a life to live.
>> That's wor Dude.
The only thing worse would be >> huh? But
>> What was I thought I say? Say that >> man. Just
any Indian man. Okay. >> I didn't. >> So [laughter]
[__] >> Like out of the goodness of my heart.
Really? Okay. Because I don't care about this guy getting lit
up by um Hindu nationalist Twitter. Okay. I have plenty I know
plenty of people in that space. I don't care. I don't want to
get him lit up by Hindu nationalist Twitter. Um I just don't
think you deserve to call yourself a progressive. I don't think
>> Did you mention that Gilded Pooh talked about Stardust
earlier? Oh yeah, Gilded Pooh was in her chat. He was the only
It was literally it was Gilded Pooh and Kathy on an account called
Zog.
Zog Unboxed like it was uh like his [__] Spiders
[laughter] >> What do you mean? >> And she was engaging
with Kathy over and over again. Okay. As if she didn't know as
if she doesn't know who Spider is. She doesn't know that Loader
Unboxed is Spider's account. She doesn't know that Zag gun box
is clearly like somebody trolling anyone in the loader box sphere.
Like she just talked to this person. And I'm I'm positive that
this was be not because she couldn't identify it, but because
it was like any engagement at all. Had a girl with a >> So
she just kept engaging was a normal >> They were trying
to bait her into coming on my stream and she just kept engaging
with them like they were a normal person.
And I'm like, dude, that's just tragic. like you know that that's
somebody trying to troll you and you're gonna engage with them
because you just want anybody to engage with your channel at
all.
>> It was uh >> very sad.
>> Was rough but Gilda Poo was also there. Uh I think he
said that wait J said you have a flat ass which I did not comment
on her. I don't see Stardust is like a
>> Yeah. Stardust is not a creature to >> Gore with
no consequences.
Everybody needs to know. People that you care about, the people
that you care about and their opinions, they need to know that
you are a psychopath. Of course, you wouldn't care about Hindu
national.
>> Again, I'm I'm I'm just going to sit here and be like
like I understand. I'm not going to accuse her of like defending
Destiny now, even though whatever. I I'm not going to accuse
her of it, right? But she did hang out with the guy who tweeted
like at least that level of derangement to people
>> Yep. Like where where is the
where's the >> I thought it was funny when Wick said it's
like tweeting a burning cross at someone.
So very true. It is exactly one hold on one. It's like actually
not to that extent. Okay.
It's not like that level of visceral. It's not it's not a symbol
of like the oppression of those people for it's not. But yes,
also it is funny because
that that would be the worst thing in the world. I'd never hang
out with somebody who did something like that. That'd be horrible.
Twitter.
>> Why? Like why why would he like he felt bold enough
to desecrate the culture? He's not going to be bothered by that.
Whatever the rest of his life that right and then >> the
culture,
dude, like she's
h I feel like she watched like a couple episodes of the Breakfast
Club re recently. Now she's talking about the culture. Okay.
But she means like Hindu culture or Indian culture around holding
cows sacred, having literal sacred cows.
Jesus >> Obviously, identity dehumanization.
Um, he is using he has stepped over the line from going to just
a normal um conflict back and forth to using my identity. And
that is fair game for him now. And it's not just that he's using
my
>> uh a dead cow is not equivalent to sending a black person
a burning cross. Holy um
>> so she's trying to build the argument, right? These
people don't know. These people don't know how sacred cows are
in Indian culture.
330 million dies
are supposed to be in one cow. >> Okay. Wait, is that a
thing? Hold on. Is that a thing from Hinduism?
She invoking Hinduism right now.
330 >> 330 million deities.
>> Deities.
330 million deities are supposed to be in one cow. Yeah, Porter
Beller, how many deities are on a
Not that many
>> are supposed to be in one cow. 330 million deities.
Okay, that's how significant it is for Hindus. Okay, if we're
just talking about symbolism, if we're just talking about respect,
if we're talking about like foundational,
>> is it really like a foundational respect thing for Indians
or is it just that the people who weren't Hindu knew they could
be getting their head cut off if they with a cow? Like is it
really a is it a respect or is it just a respect that was like
gained because people knew they'd be getting their [__]
heads cut off if they the cows by the Hindus?
>> I don't know >> principles it is immensely important
>> build the argument that she's like a devout Hindu. She
thinks the cow is a symbol of peace. >> I literally said
I'm not a Hindu in this
but I mean again talk to any Indian person like they'll they'll
>> no way you called her a Hindu. They'll confirm like
you know the cow is a very important symbol in Indian religion.
Like I can't believe that like these people actually >> I
assume she was trying to make some religious argument. How how
am I supposed to know she's Hindu or not? I assume if you're
making this argument you're Hindu. She literally just made a
307 million deities
She's not Hindu. She's invoking Hinduism a lot for someone who's
not Hindu. >> Actually want me to prove that I was disturbed
by this? Isn't that what you wanted? You wanted me to be disturbed.
Well, I'm telling you I'm disturbed and now you don't believe
it. Like that was the goal of you sending that, right? That was
the goal of >> I did not send this to you. She also does
this a lot. She like conflates me with everyone else.
I didn't send this >> substance sending that was to disturb
me. Congratulations. You did it. You disturbed me.
I had intrusive thoughts for a week like over this, you know.
>> Why say this, dude? Literally, here's some embarrassing
information about me.
Please don't bully me with that. >> It's
It's like the whole >> Hey guys, this is a really good
way of like sending me into a weekl long spir if you tweeted
me like this. I'll go into a week long spiral, guys. Okay, Stardust,
whatever you say, Stardust. >> You know it's going to be
my fault if that happens, right? Like I I'm going to be to blame
for it. >> Can't believe this guy [__] He's
streaming. He >> I'm telling you, >> there are these
clips. It's like it's like the easiest thing. Stardust, you went
on stream and you said you would crash out for a week if anyone
did this to you. Of course, they're going to do it to you, Stardust.
How else to explain >> Oh, but hold on. She literally does
explain this this exact principle a little bit earlier in the
stream >> Um I
you know I was tortured by it. Like I don't know like Yeah, you
sent that with the intention of upsetting me. And guess what?
You you won.
That was the one thing you crossed the line. That was the one
thing that >> Substance one. Substance one.
>> It's
Yeah. Like
>> I mean I've been saying we need to we need to figure
out what our version of the iron cross is and substance is getting
the first one. Okay. [laughter] >> Okay dude.
>> um and you know of all the things right of all the things
like I've gotten over the years.
But yeah to act like um to set out to upset me to set out to
harm me. And then when you are successful in upsetting me the
one time you are you want to act like I'm not that I'm pretending
that I'm trying to be I'm pretending to be a devout Hindu. when
I I've said multiple times during the presentation that I'm not
Hindu that it's just an important part of Indian >> I do
say at some point in here that I don't believe that you are actually
that you give a about like Indian culture. I don't think you
ever have. I think it's why you were the token minority on the
stream and >> and your actual culture is American culture
and go into any McDonald's and see what they think about cows.
>> Okay. Like you are you're not even Indian. You're you're
not culturally Indian. I don't know why you're >> So let's
drop this. Oh, I'm Indian. I'm Indian. No, you're American. You're
an American. Okay. >> Oh, actually none of you are white.
None of you are white. What does she think about Froggen and
her cultural Muslim? Is she culturally Muslim? What have you
said about Frogan being culturally Muslim? I wonder if we couldn't
find you going, "No, [__] you're white. No, you're
from California,
>> right? That's facts. >> I feel like I've heard
that all over the place from people adjacent to her. Maybe she
hasn't done it, but I I believe it. I I would I think we can
find it. We'll take a look." No, he knows what he was doing.
Turkey, he knows what he was
right? And that it is offensive on the level of like >> he
has other tweets where he was using Indians as a punch line.
>> And if all of that is true, she's a devout Hindu. She
believes the cows a symbol of peace. >> I never said I
was I never said I was a devout Hindu. If you talk to Muslims
in India, they don't. >> She keeps rewinding and getting
one guy by the same comments. They don't kill
you know like
people in India like cows are cows are important you know like
even in Pakistan and cows they the cow farmers there they dress
them up that you know even if they do end up you know some of
them kill them but like they dress the cows up they put um >> that's
a whole different thing and I don't think the Hindus would approve
of what those Pakistanis are doing to the cows they dress up
okay it's not good
>> about cows what they do The lizards. >> What the
they do to lizards? What
>> do I want to know? Whatever this is. This is some [__]
cursed knowledge.
>> I'm sending it to you. >> Substance explicitly
like is using that weaponizing that against her. >> Don't
send me some posh logs. Okay. I already know what he does to
lizards. >> Okay. Right. Remember, she's not even Hindu.
See, that's the thing is like >> but I explained this and
this. See, exactly. This is why I had the explainer at the beginning.
So, he's saying like, "Oh, is she really doing this? She's doing
a learning thing. She's doing a Oh, she's teaching us, you know,
making fun of me teaching. Well, clearly you didn't pay attention,
right? I demon I literally explained this. I laid this out for
you. I laid this out that I explained why despite me not being
>> I was too busy laughing at her and mocking her to actually
pay attention. That's up. She has the right to call me out for
that. That was messed up with >> This is a very, very important
part of Indian culture. I think most Hindus would tell you that.
I laid it out and now and now you're using an argument I never
made to to invalidate me. I never said that I was Hindu. If anything,
I said the exact opposite. So he's he's claiming that I'm trying
to paint myself as a devout Hindu when I never did.
>> I literally just got corrected and I'm like, "Oh, if
she's Hindu, then this makes less sense to me." >> I never
did. It's just it's just deceit. It's deceitful language. It's
uh he's doing it either he's doing it on purpose or he's deeply
or both. Probably probably both. feeling that Stardust is not
particularly religious and it's like just cheap like h you're
Indian cows like it's not it's not the level he's not taking
it to the level and that is not in the same way that like that'd
be like tweeting a watermelon at a black guy right >> no
it's not it's it's not you tweeted violence he tweeted violence
at me >> like
it's like I'm I'm just tweeting a watermelon at you
>> no it's not even >> what's is there a >> not
even I mean I've had people tweeting again I've had people tweet
literal dude [__] on the street >> I'm like
waiting cuz I know I'm about to say like a gorier version of
this that we could do >> on the street. You didn't see
me making a big deal out of that, right? I >> Oh, also
the reason she's pausing so often is because I said she's a lazy
loser who has no thoughts of her own and that she wouldn't like
actually react to it meaningfully in any way. So, I'm assuming
she saw that and decided to go back to the very beginning and
react to my entire thing. >> Scroll past it. I scroll past
all the memes that people make of like, you know, all the associations
people make about Indians and feces. I scroll past those. There's
some pretty nasty things that people like image-wise people will
send to me. My line is the violence.
You are weaponiz like you are literally weaponizing my identity
against me and you're you're telling you are communicating to
me that you find me so low that it is justified. It is justified
for you to like, you know, like send me gore like of this this
symbolization of like my like a a principle of mine being like
uh or like a deeply important
foundational principle of mine being violated. You know,
we're just talking about the gore. We're talking about the gore
tweet >> version. I don't know. I don't know if there's
a version with gore that could be like funny in the same way.
>> It's not funny. That's funny. >> It's more excessive
than that because of the gore element. It's obviously more excessive
than that, but it is that vein of like it's just a cheap throwaway.
>> It's not a cheap throwaway.
It's sacred to Hindus. And
>> she's like basically arguing. She's doing the whole
like, oh well, you I'm I'm sub I subjectively like feel violated.
Like my subjective experience is I feel violated. And I don't
know if she just skipped the entire time she was supposed to
be in Twitch politics. But it's like that's not really how you
evaluate things. That's like the pronouns argument. It's like
a whole bunch of other arguments you wouldn't actually take seriously.
Right?
Like, yeah, you could say, "Oh, well, Hindus take this really
seriously or other people take this really seriously, but it's
like I okay,
>> it's like a blasphemy argument. It's like, uh, don't
draw Muhammad, you
>> Yeah. It's just >> and and and deeply like historically
and princ like it still symbolizes peace to to Indian Muslims
even
like it's still a symbolization of like this this animal that
gives everything to you and expects so little in return just
some grass just some water
>> identity he is he's saying like it it is a it's a fair
target
>> and um and he's basically communicating that um that
like that's what he feels about me, right? How else am I supposed
to interpret that, right? How else am I supposed to interpret
that? >> No, I think you should interpret it as he doesn't
think you're human. He thinks you're a like horrifying like bile.
>> Yeah. Okay, fair enough. See, he's admitting it. He's
saying it. >> Yeah, I think everyone would say that about
you, Stardust, actually.
>> Well, Stardust, have you ever had a shortage of people
saying that about you? Like, >> or though, right? Like,
it's one thing to say, you don't view me as a human, you view
me as subhuman, you view me as inferior. It's another thing to
send me a piece like an image like gore. You're sending me gore
to communicate that. That is just that's just a level where we've
gone too far. We've gone too far
>> Gore too far. Hey sick, didn't weren't you mad at your
sister cuz you her? Hey sick, wouldn't you? And then he like
does this whole thing. People explain it to her and she's like,
"Yeah, well if you if you lie about me, I tell the truth about
you." She said that again, by the She said it on Twitter before.
She
said it here as well.
I the virtue say she's very gay.
Very goofy >> is you're admitting I mean this entire Jay-
Sock stream is pathetic. He's like saying oh no it's not that.
Then a minute two minutes later him
racism intentionally.
>> Oh it wasn't target. It wasn't targeted discrim like
it wasn't discriminatory selection. He just saw that you've been
talking about this one issue
and he knew you were Indian and he said you and he he cooked
up some anti-Indian racism and sent it to you like literally
word for word like bro you were admitting to it now it's like
>> is she actually
>> yes she's taking that one thing where apparently I misunderstood
her like her poor framing of this and I even like I'm I said
oh like I guess I
have adopted her entire purpose this is like the inverse of the
Aiden thing where it's clear like what I mean and I mean what
she means, but she's going to be like, "But you said the discriminatory
selection thing was wrong, so I'm going to pretend like you're
making that argument still." >> Imagine if this like worthless
low IQ would just get on a stream and talk about this. Imagine
if like this worthless subhuman low IQ would just get on a stream
and argue this if she's so [__] about it. >> I
actually uh I did a whole bit last night where I time Substance
out for a week and just said like, "Hey, just so you know, so
you're safe. Substance is out for a week." Even though Pisco
wouldn't listen to you. I did, but she No, she wouldn't do it.
>> Well, he's not communicating. >> I also invited
Gilded Pooh and then he was like, "I'm actually sick and I can't
come on either." >> Oh, right. Just like he had a family
emergency right after he released his headpiece on me. Right.
Of course.
>> That he's communicating that he thinks >> debate
gamma the other night some for some reason.
>> And go on and talk to Aiden. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep. Yep.
What do you debate gamma about?
>> I shouldn't.
>> yeah, that is what I'm saying. You
>> weird. I can't imagine what it's like. I feel like I
could see it in her eyes.
There's like an existential dread that must happen with some
of these people when they like when they've probably done enough
of this to know that they have a difficult time processing information
and like getting the situation right, the scenario right. Like
like she probably has some idea that she's misreading this and
like she just has to keep doing it. Like I I can't imagine how
that must feel to somebody. Like the dread you just feel that
you're like saying these things confidently while in the back
of your head just knowing that like I might have this totally
wrong. I actually don't really know if this is like if I'm even
getting this correct. I just it must be terrifying, man. I can't
I just can't imagine the ex zero cognitive dissonance. She don't
feel it anymore. Uh but honestly he seemed to have thought that
from the moment the first tweet went so mad at me if somebody
is so upset with me that they are willing to de completely dehumanize
me to the extent that they that it's not even just my my sensibilities
as a person of Indian origin it's my sensibilities as a woman
right like what kind of
>> wait what I wait what >> is it is it is it uh
is it nice behavior for a man to send a woman violent
>> Why is she making it so weirdly gendered, dude?
>> She tried she tried to get this card in too. The gender.
She tried to get this one in, too. >> Actually, this was
really misogynistic when you sent me this score, too. Not only
was it denigrating the entire entirety of Indian culture, it
was also
>> Is it is it like
is that something you think that women look into frequently?
Is that something that women do women go on live leak the way
that men do? Is that like a thing for women? No, I don't think
so. >> Why? Say, "Oh, you stupid." >> Also, I never
did the gore thing. I know a lot of I know guys did. Maybe that's
like a guy experience, but I just I
Whatever. I don't know. Weird. >> Yes, it offends my my
sensitivity as a woman. Yeah, it does. Uh because >> your
sensitivity as a woman did that did you come into that in your
30s as well?
Was that not there? Again, hanging out on the stream with the
most insensitive people on planet Earth. I just don't get it.
Where is this coming from? This is totally like
I
Pirate Software hit puberty in his late 20s, early 30s. Stardust
grew, I guess, a sense of femininity that wasn't there before.
Very interesting. Very >> When you think of the way you
think of the things that you send to women, you you can send
them like it's one thing to again, it's one thing to send me
insults and send me horrible memes or even send me people on
the street, right? sending me violence. You as a man sending
me a violent image. How am I supposed to take that? Like you
as a man, you are sending me a violent image that is symbolizing
that you think I'm below you. You think that I'm subhuman
that you think that like the cow the cow being beheaded or >> you
think it's uh think we should read anything into the fact that
the Stardust is consistently selfinserting as the cow. Can we
read anything into this? Do you think?
Oh, he walked away. Also, I [__] up. Sorry, I didn't
realize I was muted. I'm looking at food.
>> Oh, yeah. >> Is it like being disembodied? >> Is
it Is it more justified to order food in the middle of the day
if you're like sick or is that still like
kind of >> It depends cuz I think food keeps you sick longer.
It's probably a little less justified in some ways. But
>> like food you could Yeah. Like >> no. It's like
ready.
>> Yeah. If you don't have anything, then it's Yeah, it's
fine. Only if you order >> You're sending me that like
that's >> If Indian culture is so important, why can I
get Vindaloo beef?
Excuse me. Can Can somebody explain this to me? Why can't I get
Vindaloo beef? Why does this exist? Why did this ever become
a thing? A >> symbol of my culture being desecrated. >> It
It's essentially what it is. It's a symbol of my culture. It's
a a symbol of a founding principle being desecrated
and you're and you're sending it to as a man, you're sending
this to a woman. Like, do we not have um standards for the things
that we we send to women? I don't know. Maybe again, maybe I'm
oldfashioned in that sense that you don't you know, you a man
is not supposed to do that to you, you know, but you're using
violence to intimidate me
or scare me or shock me. And guess what? You did. You did. You
won. You win. You used violence, a violent image to scare me,
to shock me, to upset me, and you won. And now you want to act
like I'm pretending. >> I do think she's pretending, but
I also could be wrong. So, still don't know about it. >> You
want to act like I'm pretending? No. You won. You win. You got
it. You sent me Gore.
And it upset me. I super super wouldn't advise any of this, but
you know,
she is she's getting a W in substance for sure.
Um I hope she's lying for her sake.
>> You used violence to scare me and you scared me.
>> Is a woman.
>> Pardon me.
>> Uh Steve uses that kind of it's like this this is a
this is common tactic, right? So, just to be honest, so you think
it's it's targeting you both because of your ethnic background
um and national background, but also because you're a woman?
>> I don't know. I don't know if it's intentionally targeted,
>> dude.
She folds so fast to Pisco just asking a question. Oh, you think
it's like because you're a woman, too? >> Because I'm a
woman. I just think that it's offensive to me as a woman, you
>> Stardust operating under clear delusion. Okay. She was
she was sort of operating in reality before, but now we've straight
into clear delusion. Imagining that substance sees her as a woman
is just obviously false. Obviously. >> Yeah. Of course.
Yeah. No, I mean that's also one of my points, right? Like he
doesn't see me as a woman. Of course. Of course he doesn't see
me as a woman. He cooked this up to call you a Yeah. He cooked
this up. He cooked up some anti-Indian racism to call you a >> Yeah,
that's what happened. Yep. >> It offended me as a woman.
What? You set out to upset me and you upset me and now you're
acting like I'm not upset that I'm just making this up. Tell
me, has Substance called any other woman on here
>> Has he used that word for any other >> woman in
this space?
>> I don't think so.
It's just justified when it's me. It's just justified when it's
me. A three-word joke is what led to this, guys. Three words.
>> dude. I
I think her pivot, her like weird character pivot is
far less genuine. far less believable than the person she was
>> the illusion. That's crazy. That's wild. >> Yeah.
Um uh but you know, >> who is this? Just just to be clear,
who is this person and how is it connected to Peace Go specifically?
>> Um that I have been told that this person is like a
member of his >> By the way, this is this is deeply
>> Just this whole idea that you're trying to oppress him
on Wick, but >> Okay, I think we're back at where we started.
Deeply embarrassing again.
It is deeply embarrassing
to send a woman violent imagery. Like he admits it. He admits,
"Oh, he cooked up the anti some anti-Indian racism for you to
call you a he was like, here you go."
>> Okay. Yeah, it is discriminatory
>> Say that. Yep.
>> I don't know what. How'd she leave back to that?
>> Um, it is discriminatory selection. You admitted it.
you like
you wanted to make me upset. You won. You made me upset. Don't
act like that. That wasn't the the goal. Don't act like that.
I I'm not upset then. I the the point was to make me upset and
then you upset me and now I'm pretending. Is that what this is?
So, okay. According to
>> he's saying I'm only doing this because I'm not upset.
Then he's saying that um well it I'm only doing this because
I'm not upset and it's about him and Queman. It couldn't possibly
be about the fact that this guy is sending me gore that is he
has selected based on my background. >> No, I literally
say he selected it based on the background. He just wasn't paying
attention.
I said I clearly misunderstood the discriminatory selection thing
even though it's poorly framed. I'll even give her that. Okay.
But she I literally said the selection was discriminatory of
the image. Can't believe this is JD Vance's wife. Well, believe
it, man.
Believe it. He falls. Obviously a delusion. That's crazy. That's
wild. >> Yeah. Um uh but you know,
>> also Yeah. Again,
>> Substance has not called anybody else a Okay. And you
don't send like you don't send women like he's making my point
for me. He's saying, "Oh, it's ridiculous because Substance doesn't
even see you as a woman." That's my point. That's my point. How
long has she been going? She made it through like five minutes
like >> Every time Every time she gets one >> well,
I guess it's not getting one guide, it's reacting. But every
time she actually pauses to react, >> she goes backwards
and reacts to the same thing and has the same reaction. She's
looped like four times on the same
Like she'll she'll loop back and react to it again. I don't know
if she just forgets that she's reacted to this >> To be
clear, who is this person and how is it connected to Peace Go
specifically? um that I have been told that this person is like
a member of his >> By the way, this is this is deeply
>> Just this whole idea that you're trying to oppress him
on Wick about his about his Discord or something, >> it's
so deeply embarrassing, man. I just I have to go back to that.
Like, >> how is it not deeply embarrassing to be such an
antisocial?
>> She already reacted to this. Deeply embarrassing. Deeply
embarrassing. Deeply She's already reacted to it. this exact
instance of deeply embarrassing >> freak that you on Christmas
Eve decide to send me gore. How How is that not deeply embarrassing?
>> I just want to point out it's so deeply embarrassing
to be on Twitter on Christmas Eve. Okay, that's
like
Okay. No, it's maybe it's not that bad. I I'll be honest. I was
on my phone a lot at Christmas because literally my parents are
old and they sleep a lot. Um, well, actually, no, it was my sleep
schedule as well. But it's like not weird to be on your phone
at Christmas. It's whatever. But also, why is she It's not weird
to send gore to somebody who's being a total. It's like not unexpected.
It's not totally unexpected to send something that you are intentionally
crafting to offend somebody to someone who's saying, "Oh, did
I hurt your feelings?" It's pretty much expected.
It's not good. It's not good.
This is not deeply embarrassing.
It's not deeply embarrassing to engage on Twitter how you normally
would.
>> You're not living your life with your
like Jesus Christ, dude.
>> Presentation with Pisco's name in it to go after this
guy weeks after it >> Not weeks again. It was on Christmas
>> The substance of Patter. Uh probably. I
It's not weeks. It was on Christmas Eve, which was
one, two, nearly three weeks
So, it was literally weeks ago,
not weeks ago, it was Christmas Eve. >> 3,000 3,000 chat
messages in his server.
>> And he watches Pisco sometimes.
I think Substance is a part of like that sort of left-leaning
crew here who do watch like Pisco, me, Queenman. I do think so.
>> I don't know how you can I don't know how you guys can
claim that you're left-leaning and engage in this kind of stuff.
Like, it's one you think that I'm like um subhuman or whatever.
Um, like you said it, right, that substance obviously thinks
I'm subhuman, right? >> Wow. Yeah. Stardust has never hung
around with any left-leaning people who use the term subhuman
and see people as subhuman. That's so true. Stardust, you're
very smart. I totally don't want to.
Well, >> it's like it's so
>> dude it's so because I'm like trying to get away from
like even referencing
that community, that person, but it's like just the perfect counter
example for total like this of like >> how they're being
totally disingenuous
and it sucks because it's just the easiest like Yeah. Uh did
you do you have a problem with this? Is this actually your It's
unfortunate that it >> You're making all my points for
me. >> You made my points for me. Like I I feel like I
don't have to do any work here. You guys literally did it. Congratulations.
You made my point for >> Well, it's done then. You've won,
right? Stardust. Do you feel like a winner? >> How long
straight had a good point though that I did kind of give her
what she wanted. She wanted a way to like basically, you know,
without being creative or entertaining at all,
Yeah. Have a reason to like just keep streaming, [cough] to be
able to get through content, >> like to be able to you
know, say with some level of plausible deniability that she actually
made some content. >> Um, but yeah, like I mean, yeah,
you see, you achieved your goal.
Um, I but yeah, I hope they watch this. I hope they follow up.
I think we've reached it. I think we finished it. I I think they're
mentioning me in the chat, but um I'm not sure.
>> Uh, you think you watched the whole thing? There's a
lot more of that presentation left. or it's worth it for me to
even
I I mean I don't even know what to say. Like like we've covered
the >> Are you still
um
>> like what I didn't even hear what she said reading.
>> What did she say? >> I don't even know what to
say. >> I'll give her this. She did react quite a bit.
She in fact reacted so much she reacted to me making the same
statement twice on at least like two or three different occasions.
>> Very impressive. Okay, >> I think we've reached
it. I think we finished it. I I think they're mentioning me in
the chat, but um I'm not sure it's worth it for me to even
I I mean, I don't even know what to say. Like like we've covered
the entire thing. We covered the part where I came in and I was
watching him reacting to it. Um I rewinded back to the start
of the presentation to see what he thought. He basically confirmed
everything like every argument that I put out there. >> Yeah.
That he was being racist in picking that image. I mean, it doesn't
confirm every argument.
Was it wrong? Was it Is he like wrong? Is he evil? Should he
be banned for it? Um, is it not embarrassing that you went and
did this and like pressed Pisco with all the other stuff going
on? She, by the way, says, "Oh, I had no idea people were accusing
Pisco of anything with his
>> She says that at some point here, >> cap cap cap
cap. >> It's like,
>> this doesn't make any sense if if you don't know that.
It makes >> you lying stupid lying stupid lying up human.
This why I hate her so much, man. She's just such a
disgusting dishonest person. It's so lame. Um,
>> And then she hides behind. Oh, I'm a I'm a stupid ugly
Indian. I'm a stupid ugly Indian. Everyone just hates me being
a stupid ugly Indian.
People hate you cuz you're like a nasty.
>> This is some genuine hatred. I just feel like a lot
of I said this. It's like the reason I've never the reason I
don't like go as hard as you go is I literally just feel bad
for her >> cuz she's a stupid ugly ind. Yeah. She she doesn't
realize how much leeway she gets from being >> a stupid
ugly Indian. She thinks that's why everyone's after it. But no,
>> we have to way more if she was like trans or something.
>> Confiscator
sent. So call the NHS report fraud. Okay.
>> Yeah. Every argument that I put out there, he confirmed.
Thank you, J. You literally made my arguments for me. Thank you.
You would deny the argument and then 30 seconds later affirm
it. Like literally behavior.
literally
>> Damn, she got >> Moral, the guy who loves underage
girls on his stream now, apparently. So
>> that was true. Yeah, Moral was here. >> Yeah.
I mean, obviously the the goal again, once again, the goal was
to upset me, right? The one like the one time again, I said I
get sent pictures of people in the streets. I get sent pictures
of like really nasty memes, whatever. Okay. You sent me gore
with the with the per >> in honor of stardust. I shorted
a quarter pounder. Okay, let's go. >> Purpose of upsetting
me. The purpose of demeaning me. You think I'm subhuman. You
don't consider me a woman. Congratulations. You upset me. What
did you think was going to happen? You didn't think I was going
to go public with this? You didn't think I was going to put you
on blast in a public way? >> Literally, nobody would have
a problem. Like nobody would have a problem in the way that I
have a problem with this if you just gone to Twitter and said
this guy this Twitter this Twitter user is insane and they called
me a and they sent this and blah blah blah blah blah. Right?
It's the forum you chose to do this in that you went to Pisco's
thing where he was getting a whole panel on Wick like where it's
Pisco versus the world and you decided to press him about a Clipper
who made fun of you who like offended you
three weeks ago.
Like that is what is embarrassing here. I don't even care if
she's upset. I don't care if she wants to make a tweet about
it. I don't care if she wants to do content about it. But she
went to take Pisco's platform and complain there. Like like she
went on Wick Wick's platform to take away from Pisco's time,
not to talk about any of Pisco's ideas or his political positions
to complain about to complain about something she didn't even
bring up to his moderators.
Um Oh, hold on.
That might Oh, what does she want? That might seem rude, but
is it uh but is she just going for content or does she expect
a new apology? She wanted a better apology and she wanted him
timed out from Pisco's Discord for a week. She did this all for
a week long timeout.
She says
what she really did was she just wanted to get this in front
of people. >> What's up?
>> Don't waste your [__] time. It's like obviously
the point is is about going off pe.
>> Yeah, it's like it's obviously transparently the point.
She she got like all mad and was like, "Oh, these guys are so
conspiratorial for saying I'm doing it for this reason." It's
like, "No, it's literally the only reason to do it.
It's the only only reason that this would be done." Yeah. Very
sad. >> You don't You didn't think I was going to make
a big deal out of this. You claim that I complain about like
anti-Indian racism all the time. I don't I don't complain about
it necessarily with me as much as I'm complaining about the
um huge uptick in it on social media. though I do think some
of you guys uh certainly don't help yourselves.
>> you certainly don't help yourselves. But I mean, yeah.
Again, I literally
>> She also complained that we watched a Kathy vod
while Kathy was the only person in her chat. She was like, um,
the last time Quan and JC actually watched some of my content,
they immediately followed it up with watching like an Indian
guy doing a prank call. Like somebody doing an Indian prank call
in a goofy voice. It's like and then she like started responding
to the Guam account in her chat. So funny, man.
>> Kathy really stacking W's recently. It's kind of hard
to deny. Okay. Really like they just it's it's been kind of crazy.
He's on something of a
something of a run. Maybe not quite generational yet, but it's
getting
>> Yeah. What is the current broad claim against Pisco
or his community? Just tolerance of people friendly to you and
Queman. Yeah. And that they I mean the Destiny thing was oh they're
really crazy and they like talk [__] about me all
the time.
I mean I
What do you think you'd like widen it at all? I think that's
about it. It's literally like they just don't like that.
I don't know. People are mean to Destiny. I guess it's they're
now trying to follow it up as it's like a stalker unhinged. These
people are like super harmful. They go to like other people's
streams, they make really mean comments.
Like I there's generally like the idea that the communities are
harmful, that these chatters are like harmful and collected here
or something. Seems like has anyone brought up how gay that is?
Uh many people, yes, several times in >> weather everything.
But I mean, you set out to upset me. I I got upset. So yeah,
I'm going to make a
I'm going to make a bunch of noise about it.
You can't be mad at me when that was your goal. You achieved
your goal.
>> Everybody's a winner here. Turns out we all won.
>> Still mind-blowing that Becket was e dating her. Talk
about long-distance
I listen. Becket's fine.
It's fine. He's doing fine. Oh, welcome sourcing support. Welcome
friend to the
Oh my goodness. I We've hit 12 hours just about, guys. We're
almost done with Stardust. We're all going to bed. >> I
even expl I explained the s the the significance of the cow at
the beginning of the presentation
and he's like saying I'm trying to pretend to be a devout Hindu
when I never did. I literally said in the presentation, I'm not
Hindu. >> So true, >> man. The amount of people who
are just justifying it is just insane to me. Uh,
stay up till the pisco the Chud Piscoco talk. Dude, I can't.
I'm sorry. I've been up for a long time. I
can't do it, man. >> Okay, I think I'm going to log off.
I am done. Um,
>> the special occasion for 12 hour stream. Um, people
just kept rolling in and then it was like fun fun vibes. So
yeah,
like RA came in and I I was going to end and Rao came in and
then I was going to end and straight raid came on and then I
was going to end and uh Boom came on.
So that's that's how it should be. >> I had fun. I hope
you guys had fun. I hope you understand my arguments. I think
I I think I made a decent, you know, uh made some decent arguments
in my favor. Um, but yeah, I mean, if you justify this kind of
>> You literally couldn't even tell that you were responding
to the same point accidentally multiple times in a row. >> If
you turn the other way, I I don't want anything to do with you
really. Like, if you were justifying the gore, if you were turning
the other way when I am being sent gore, I want nothing nothing
to do with you. Nothing.
>> I think JC explained your >> This is like the
This is like the Stardust Blacklist, guys. your argument as well.
He justified them for sure. He said, "Oh, she well, she's wrong
about that." And then went on to basically make my argument for
me,
>> dude. I It's I I try not to, but it's like rough. You
think she's scared to
>> Oh, she Well, she's wrong about that. and then went
on to basically
>> like like it's just it's actually tragic that you end
up looking like Danny DeVito playing the penguin
>> like when when when she's smile like it's just like
I would be terrified
I I would just be it would be horrifying >> though. Yeah.
>> This is why she said I'm done with it. I'm not I'm not
okay with it. It's not okay. You've crossed the line when you
start sending me gore. That's it. >> Uh Stardust versus
Food Shops headtohead. Who you got?
probably food chops cuz as much as food chops doesn't make coherent
arguments either, she does at least know how to like signal or
or like you know fain emotion, feel emotion even like food chops
has some amount of emotionality to the content. Stardust has
like nothing, right? Stardust doesn't even get
I don't know
it there's just nothing there. Unfortunately, it's it's almost
certainly food shops and you know Stardust clearly has no shame.
Boot Chops has taken the shamelessness and made a channel that's
got some subs and some viewership. Right. Stardust has taken
the shamelessness and produced nothing at all ever.
>> That's it.
That is not how normal human beings behave. Okay. All right.
Bye, guys. Have a good one.
Damn.
H
chill evening stream. Who's this? Somebody's getting recommended
to me. I've never seen this stream. I'll never click on this
stream. I want nothing to do with this stream. Okay, pointing
that out. Appropo of nothing. Boom. There it is on the record.
No idea who that is. Neverend who that is. >> Kinda, my
favorite Kinda. My favorite >> No idea who that is. I have
nothing. My favorite streamer. I spend all my time obsessing
over. >> This fellow seems to have some idea of who that
is. I don't know who that is. I don't talk to that person.
Okay. >> I I've never watched one. I haven't seen any other
drama with that person. Destiny just sort of invented this idea
that I was like, "Hey, Logan the
>> When L even when I got linked the video of I was like,
"Whose auntie is this?" And then moved on. >> Dude, I I
like I saw that somebody had mentioned her maybe somewhere on
Twitter, maybe some Discord. I don't even know. Like, oh, I Why
do I care? Yeah. It's just I I think they had Loner Box on at
some point, right? Is the thing that made people care,
I think. Yeah, Loner Box went on and debated like Kathy and Emory
and people like that. I think Riyle.
>> Oh,
that could have been funny. Um, still not looking at it though.
>> Not going to do it. Ogre Boy, let's go. TPCA. I should
I should have CPA CPCA on stream sometime.
I've I've him off the stream for a long time.
All right. I think Jesus, Rakita's been online for a while, too.
>> Oh, no. He gone.
He gone. Damn. Okay. Uh, I think that's it. I think that's got
to be it, man. It's been a long night.
11 and a half hour stream or something. It was a good one.
W stream. Be back. Well, actually, I It's possible I take a day
off tomorrow.
Possible. Possible. Possible. Okay. Have a good night, guys.
We'll see all y'all
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Have a good day at work. for anyone
who's just getting